[Laughter]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
welcome to india
the game of chess was born here
thousands of years later many of the
world's best players have made the trek
to represent their countries at the 44th
chess olympiad the most prestigious team
chess event on the planet
in chennai the chess capital of india
circumstance has cleared the way for
perhaps more countries than ever to set
their sights on gold
india has high hopes for keeping the
hardware at home
with three top teams competing in the
open and the top seed in the women's
section the host country has legitimate
reasons to believe it can sweep gold and
more
entering as the favorites
team usa has suffered multiple dramatic
disappointments so far
will they have what it takes to finish
strong and keep their metal hopes alive
while medals count
some accomplishments won't be measured
in gold
the women's team from ukraine has
overcome adversity just to make it here
now they hope to honor their nation with
a memorable performance
namaste dosto
in one place for the first time in four
years these olympians are together again
the 44th olympiad has brought the
world's best to the place the game of
chess began
and with that let today's games begin
okay welcome ladies and gentlemen this
is the 44th chess olympia this is the
final unmissable round this is when we
find out which country prevails among
the hundreds of others in this the 44th
chess olympiad i'm your host grandmaster
daniel naredicki alongside me today the
one and only the rock grandmaster
archers nakesans arthurs good morning to
you good morning daniel it's good
evening ashley to you namaste dosto
everybody so very very happy to be here
for the final round i mean so far the
first 10 rounds daniel it's been an
absolute rollercoaster every single day
there's a drama or even couple of dramas
and then i just so pumped what this
final round is gonna bring us
absolutely the amount of storylines the
amount of
pain and joy and pleasure
and what emotion hasn't been experienced
by the grandmasters here at the olympiad
but before we delve into the games a
couple of logistical notes let's start
with a format we know that the olympiad
is an 11 round swiss this of course is
around 11. each team consists of four
players each team plays against another
team of four players and the team with
more game points wins the match archer
the rules the format is very simple if
you don't know the format where have you
been
right so indeed four players for uh per
team one reserve player and the time
control actually is slightly
one of my favorites solo speak i'm not
sure about you danya probably you're
gonna agree 90 minutes for 40 moves very
nice then you get an additional 30
minutes until the end of the game and of
course plus 30 seconds per every minute
move
it's simple it's relatively short and it
leads to some fascinating time scrambles
now the standings let's start with the
women's section going into the final
round we obviously don't know the final
round standings until it happens right
now we have india in clear first place
with 17 match points they have won eight
matches they've drawn one and they've
lost only one poland in second place
same thing but instead of the eight wins
they have seven wins and two draws
arters india has a tough challenge
they're playing usa but they are the
clear favorites going into the final
round
right i also
think that india has everything in their
hands because yesterday they scored a
major victory over kazakhstan here today
if they're gonna win it they're gonna
take home golden entire india is ready
for that to happen
absolutely and in the open section going
to the final round we have a absolutely
crazy situation we have uzbekistan in
first place right now armenia very close
behind and second with india two and
india third and fourth and team usa
uh closing out the top five any of those
teams can win gold and we will be
delving into that as the round is
underway but
uh team uzbekistan arters what an
incredible run it has been uh for all of
those young players absolutely
incredible right i mean all of the four
players have been scoring over about
2700 reading performance i mean maybe
yesterday's results have slightly
lowered that 27 congress 28 congress i
mean look at the roster of team
uzbekistan they have some of the
youngest players in the field right
average 17 18 20 another back up the
satori one of the superstars of the
world chess yesterday's drama against
gokesh i guess we're going to talk about
that in a moment
wow just just insane
insane and when you're playing this well
the luck goes your way and the luck did
not go kukesh's way yesterday despite a
perfect score tragedy struck team india
yesterday let's watch the concluding
moments of that game
wow i mean this this queen b7 feels like
a stab really it's like
your heart just sinks right there of
course he already felt that the game
went not his way but to receive queen d7
after such an amazing run against danya
eight out of eight eight and a half out
of nine he was winning in this game and
boom and this happens
completely winning and the the craziest
the saddest thing is that only a draw
would still have secured victory for
team india's pragnanda pulling out that
technical endgame victory so gukesh all
he needed was a draw in a plus five
position but all credit to notre back
his defense was it was it was
unbelievable in this game the amount of
time that he survived in that lost
position as he picks up cash's night
saving the match for uzbekistan and the
big question who is going to win tonight
that's a beautiful graphic and we see
team uzbekistan the largest on the
screen in front of you as they lead
by tie breaks the nerves arthurs the
nerves today are going to be
incredible who can hold themselves
together
well i have no idea daniel to be honest
i'm looking at this and uh i have a
feeling obviously it's gonna be either
armenia uzbekistan because if they win
uh there's a very fair chance they're
gonna take it down if uzbekistan wins
today this i think pretty much means
they've already gotten the gold in the
bag however in case they draw this is a
chance for usa or team india first or
second team india and also even the team
netherlands have a very slim chance to
take it all
yeah and from previous olympiad
experience we know that crazy things uh
they don't just happen hypothetically
they actually do happen again it's
because of the nerves it's because
everybody is so strong and as we review
real fast the team matchups today
starting with the women's section we
have india usa india of course is in the
lead but a strong and resurgent us team
that has won the last few matches might
have something to say about it with
ukraine and poland on the second board
azerbaijan and georgia and uh very
strong matchups on the fourth and fifth
boards as well and in the open section
arturs we have mouth-watering matchups
all around us team uzbekistan will have
to hold against an angry and powerful
and motivated netherlands team that is
going to spoil their cinderella run
right
anish has been on fire i mean so far
playing really wonderful tournament very
inspired chess to be honest danya i lost
account how many times gary sacrificed
an exchange in this tournament he's
clearly playing very wonderful chess and
uh this final round i think we might see
again something super exciting ladies
and gentlemen buckle your seat belts
because the gang has sounded
it is i don't even know what local time
it is in india i don't even know what
time it is here in charlotte i've been
flying all day but it doesn't matter
because the games have started and uh
vince and kymer playing d4 against
google yes it's 10 am i think it's
definitely in time right so it's called
early arts for a chess player
yes 10 am is the nightmare for every
single one i mean don you've been there
many many times before you play
tournament and then you get this final
round you have to wake up 10 a.m and
sometimes even worse 9 a.m or 8 a.m your
brain is still sleeping and yet you have
to produce the best chest possible for
the final round
yeah and the most important round in
both sections nothing has been decided
and we start
uh in the match of india 2 and uh and
germany with vincent kymer playing d4
and c4 and one of the story lines
archers as we were discussing earlier is
will uh gukesh despite overall his
unbelievable performance but will he be
able to put his result yesterday behind
him or will it impact his play what do
you think
i think absolutely it will impact his
play daniel because i think all of us we
have been there suffering painful losses
and yesterday gokesh suffered one of his
most painful losses so far in his very
short career so far he's still young
he's still not experienced and actually
what is not in his favor is that the
short time frame from the end of the
last game and today because it's been
what i mean 12 hours or maybe maybe
slightly more right it's very very short
time to recover and also this is a
perfect chance for winston try to score
because vincent has been winning the
last two games in a row and he's looking
for revenge to take against cash because
they already met against each other a
couple of weeks ago in beal
okay so uh
these two players they have a history
and we have a potential ragozan or a
queen's gamble decline depending on
where
kukesh decides to position
his dark square bishop i'm not too
familiar with his opening repertoire i
mean i i haven't seen that many goo cash
games before this tournament um and i
guess i belong to the majority i'm sure
after this tournament all of the
analysis and the predictions
uh will will really begin in earnest
i think uh gukesh is uh fencing uh some
ragoza setups with bishop b4 i'm not
really sure what he's going to do here
for example in the bill bill tournament
they did play something else so winston
didn't opt for knight f3 he played
knight c3 then after knight c3 uh i'm
sorry yeah c4 it was slightly different
order of the moves but
after
the third move the fourth move for white
was cedex on d5 and bishop g5 so knight
of three this is something else clearly
winston doesn't want to repeat what he
played in beal he has preferred
something else
i see
interesting observation and uh as goo
cash ponders which uh line to play it is
possible that he was expecting vincent
to
uh to rehash uh the carlsbad but in the
meantime we have so many other
fascinating games
uh to to get into uh nishigiri by the
way uh i don't want to jump to the
uzbekistan netherlands match just yet
we'll do that next but he played a very
fascinating line of the night off shall
we take a look at the other boards of
the india 2 germany match first let's go
we have sedwani and escipiano
um in a pretty standard karakan so we
don't have to spend uh too much time on
this game of course nisipiano
isn't it amazing archers to have a
player like that on your team who's so
experienced and who is very likely uh
not to quite feel the same
uh amount of nerves perhaps as some of
the younger players
right and i feel also the teams daniel
they need to have this anchor somebody
who is solid who is bringing the
experience to the team
and for example all of the younger teams
like uzbekistan like the second team of
india also team germany is one of the
youngest teams in the olympia they have
somebody who is bringing the experience
and wisdom to the team and i have a
feeling that nisi piano's presence also
helps for the team because experience he
is he knows what he's doing obviously
indeed and as you're saying the rest of
the team is very young and one of those
younger players is rasmus vane
who is a
uh incredibly strong grandmaster he's
been over 2600 for a while he's close
closing in on 26.50
and uh he is facing uh the hero of
yesterday's match against uzbekistan our
pragmata and they have a kind of a kings
indian attack catalan cross
not a particularly theoretical opening
as far as i know
um no no not really so uh here after d4
i always believe that this is not really
so dangerous for white because after c
dx 94 the strongest move is e5 and then
black helpfully uh continues his
development and e5 by the way is
immediately played otherwise if black
doesn't play e5 what very quickly plays
c4 knight c3 and usually these catalan
like positions i i really really prefer
for white
yeah i agree this is this is the
principled move and
i don't remember where the knight
generally goes b3 or f3
i think i think both moves are possible
to be honest if i think i think knight
b3 comes together with some f4 ideas if
i am not terribly mistaken maybe i'm
terribly mistaken i'm going to be the
first time but uh not if three
or maybe i'm just remembering wrong yeah
i think knight between the way i keep
playing
there's so many different types of
positions where you know black has the
center that they're they're they're all
getting jumbled together in my head but
yeah knight b3 knight b3 sounds more
logical it's on the board and we have
this uh interesting kingzinian attack
structure
uh on the third board and finally we
have uh well we looked at kaimur against
kukesh they are indeed in aragosan and
in nihal saren's game against blue bomb
we have a london system so i'm pretty
sure we can skip this one
you don't like the london daniel don't
you oh god well in the second round of
the tournament i just played i barely
beat a a 2000 player in london
um he just put the structure together
and then was moving back and forth
and it just occurred to me that in the
london everything is defended eight
times
and there's just nothing the black can
do
so a pretty good choice by knee hall
yeah very interesting choice on nicole
we already have this discussion before
sarin nicol is one of the most versatile
players he plays literally everything
and he has played online so many games
daniel do you know have you ever
prepared against siren it's just insane
i mean he casts up like 40 000 games uh
on every platform i mean you often in
every opening just just intend e4 d4
c493 b3 of third the same with black
when i was preparing against him i was
like i have a terror i mean i just
cannot prepare against him
no he's he's totally unpreparable he's
part of the new crop of players who just
can play absolutely everything but he
has played the london he plays the
london a lot online
uh so so he's experienced in these
positions
uh i think that he was instructed
probably to play a little bit more
solidly i mean this is the final round
you don't want to burn any crazy bridges
in the opening and nihal is a big fan of
these longer kind of drawn out games uh
positionally he's just a wizard so uh
you know we will see in in a couple of
moves whether this was a good choice as
blue bomb uh carries out one of the main
plans and puts his bishop on d6 okay so
this is the germany uh india two match
and i know everybody is very excited to
see uzbekistan against the netherlands
so here we go starting with abdul
satorov and i apologize it was notorbeck
who played the rook g1 system against
the nishigiri who has the black pieces
wow i mean uh is this even legal
i mean i
don't think i've seen something like
this before rookie one against the
dragon setup
well
yeah gary decided to play the dragon
setup after rook two one he played first
of all he plays h5 which is also as far
as i know pretty unusual against rook g1
right so rook g1 i guess the idea is
push g4 g5 so anish's h5 is more in the
spirit of the night orphan again if he
would talk about english attack against
the night of the system of f3 bishop e3
g4 g5 is one of the most dangerous
systems that black can face in the
neighborhood that's why this rook g1 was
stopped by h5 anish felt that this is a
perfect moment to switch to the dragon
really interesting stuff
yeah and and what's also interesting is
that notre back responds with queen e2
so and as you pointed out normally the
queen goes to d2 but recently uh queenie
ii queen f3 queen d3 all of those
developing moves uh have been have been
played so many times
now one question is is why is white
delaying
g4 and probably the answer has to do
with the fact that white does not want
to prematurely open the h file before
black is castled
indeed i think that's a very good point
and also
um uh this g5 threat perhaps with the
bishop on g7 no longer is so dangerous
so actually i wouldn't be surprised if
um abdusto turf is going to make
adjustments we have seen this happen in
modern chess so many times you play rook
g1 queenie with the idea to play g4
something happens your opponent plays
the dragon and suddenly boom there you
go you switch your plans and you go for
something more center based and just
forget about g4 at all
yeah and the other interesting thing
about putting the queen on e2 is that
after you mention the word center based
after you castle the rook will be
aligned with black's queen so you might
have ideas of going e5 of course and you
could easily move his queen to a5 or to
c7 so we are guaranteed to get an
incredibly rich position here will it be
opposite side castling of the world a
niche remain in the center that remains
to be seen but what is for sure uh is
that we're about to get a barn burner on
on our top board of our uh
of our uzbekistan netherlands match and
going to the other boards we have warmer
dam against vaquidov
um i guess that's technically not the
second board is technically uh
ivan forest against yakubuyev so we can
start with that one
all right indian bishop g4
what do you make of that oh wait
the g4 is not really the most
dimensional way to continue right no
look at this but white actually played
bishop d3
now black played bishop and white moved
back to e2 so white's playing this down
at tempo
wow what do you make of that because i'm
not really a king's indian player i mean
i definitely recognize that bishop g4 is
clearly not the main move because as far
as i'm concerned black is trying to
apply pressure against the pawn on d4
but why does willing to go there and
lose a tempo i mean is this all right
yeah i mean
just to give some context uh after the
main move bishop p2 bishop g4 is a move
it's sort of an old-fashioned uh line
and i never played it because i felt
like it violates the spirit of the
king's indian
i never liked giving up my my light
squared bishop but the general point of
this setup is is you
well if white plays normally then
eventually you trade the bishop for the
knight and you put the knight out on c6
and you apply pressure on the d4 pawn
that's why you take the knight out of f3
um
now this is considered better for white
unquestionably
i don't know if i would go for this down
a tempo from white's perspective but
maybe even forest believes that it is so
important
uh to get black's bishop off the board
that he's willing to do this
down at temple i'm expecting knight c6
here knight fd7 by black i i think one
thing is clear black should be already
out of the book
yeah no question about it you play this
from deep bishop there's no way you
prepare that in uh pre-game
preparation
all right do we move on check another
game maybe yeah yeah let's move on
within the same match we have sindarov
against benjamin buck
who are in an italian
and ooh all right doubled pawns already
so there's been some exchange on e3
actually you know daniel it's
interesting um maybe you can
tell about your opinion what's so
special about this italian game setup
because i've seen also another back of
the satori playing exactly the same
italian game setups so it's just usually
i mean the word is that this is not
dangerous right you you play knight c3
bishop e3
maybe
discussed in some very old chess books
right this is not super ambitious and
yet i've seen norbeck playing this now i
see sindarov playing this this is
clearly a team analysis and they have
some ideas here what do you think about
this
yeah i guess it's it to them it's it's
just purely about getting a position
that they're comfortable with uh that's
the only way that i can explain it
because there's there's no question that
this is
from a theoretical standpoint innocuous
like if black knows what he's doing and
i presume that benjamin does
okay and maybe once in a while you're
gonna get a slightly worse position with
black but
white is not trying to to win the game
out of the opening
uh i feel like you know these uzbek
juniors you know they've just analyzed
this for many many hours
they are comfortable with all of the
ideas and they feel that in an equal
middle game they're just going to be
more comfortable
uh you know handling the steering
you know they're going to know how the
car turns and you know they're not going
to
drive the car into the water whereas if
you're black
and you're not quite as familiar with
some of the ideas i have seen a lot of
games where
you know the result of the opening is
totally quality but then black starts
slipping into inexplicably slipping into
a worse position and already arters i
think that
benjamin has some decisions that he's
got to make in this position he can't
play bishop e6 or maybe he can but no i
don't think he can because of d5
uh there's a cool line d5 knight a5 and
i think the bishop can just drop back
before traps the knight cute cute little
line but how exactly does black complete
his development here does he play bishop
d7 and leave this bishop uncontested
i don't know
right and also indeed a very very very
good question there dania because where
do you position the bishop uh you look
at the diagonal what has conveniently
played h3 this means you can never play
bishop g4 maybe reposition it on g6 so
there's just nobody squares also queen
e7 jumps under 95 ideas maybe not even
right away but at some point later and i
think you're right uh this is the point
that cinderella definitely feels
comfortable with this position he feels
these ideas and i have to mention that
the entire team of uzbekistan they have
one of the greatest coaches probably in
the world even sokkolov he's been
working with a team for quite a while
he's widely regarded as really an
awesome coach and the results are
obviously visible
yeah i mean these these young players
from uzbekistan are disciplined
they are emotionally strong they don't
get too low with the lows they don't get
too high with the highs
and uh to be leading the olympia this
olympiad of this strength going to the
final round that simply cannot be a
fluke and it takes a village okay so
finally in this uh match we have warmer
dam with the white pieces against uh
johan gervajirov and a rosolimo with an
early c3d4 a line that has been all the
rage
as of late and akira seems to be the
first one
to be taking a good amount of time
all right and uh now the very obvious
question dania can i take the pawn on e4
i see a pawn i take upon gobble gobble
okay so my first guess would be that
white plans d5
a knight e6 this this guy has to be the
idea i think i've seen something like
this before inter mets a move attacking
the bishop
i don't know where you go bishop d3
bishop a4 but i guess the next move for
black is 95.
yeah i guess okay let's say i go bishop
d3 you go 95
and we get a position like this where
okay my guess is that maybe warmer
diamond 10 something light something
like this
now but then already like e6 queen h4 is
unpleasant
yeah i don't know the compensation here
looks pretty questionable maybe rookie
one yeah rookie one target
seven yeah by the way rookie one and
then bishop h6 because if you play
bishop g7 aka bishop g5 now you play
bishop f6 now i play either bishop h6 or
bishop f4 also is a move by the way to
consider
absolutely come yeah there's a
compensation
yeah and the evolver seems to like this
a lot i mean that bishop on ca
definitely has seen better days
and if if
johan gier is out of book here that
that's trouble because we know that max
warmer dom
isn't just some guy off the streets i
mean he has seconded
jordan van forest to himself is uh an
opening juggernaut
so pretty promising start here on the
fourth board for team netherlands
but then again how do you else respond
because why didn't waste the tempo for
either rookie one or queen e2 if he gets
to play d4 d5 by the way d4 d5 is a
major threat right now and one of the
most traditional ways for black response
against this is either cx on d4 or d5
right away you just have to stop this
but i mean with the king in the center
you need to watch out for a couple of
things you need to watch out for knight
e5 you need to watch out for e takes on
e5 and maybe there's c4d5 threats this
is not an easy decision to make
no and before we leave this game i will
point out that the main moves here are
e5 that's the old school move but rookie
one has been
what everybody plays automatically in
recent uh months and years so d4 it's
upon sacrifice i don't know if this is i
don't think i'm sure this is not a
novelty uh but it might have fallen
outside of
the uzbek player's uh preparation
purview so we'll see how vaquidav deals
with his opening challenges and this is
the match between the netherlands and
the leaders of the olympia team
uzbekistan are those four incredibly
exciting young gm's next up archers i'll
give you the choice we have armenia
against spain we have usa against india
we will look at both of them which one
would you like to start with i think we
have to go also with armenia probably
his next meeting
yeah they're one of the leaders of the
olympiad of course together with team
uzbekistan they are looking for the gold
um i mean daniel i'm i'm impressed
because again if you look at the
armenian players separately they're
very good players but not not quite
elite then they come together as a team
and this is entirely something else they
suddenly become incredibly strong team
on team armenia has been known for
performing very well in the past they
won the olympiad several times and this
year
they're very close to do it again
i think you're right i think team
armenia is perhaps the best illustration
that chemistry is incredibly important
in the olympiad and isn't just some
wishy-washy like oh you know everybody
says chemistry is important but at the
end of the day it's just about rating
like no you know the evidence proves
otherwise in armenia is i agree with you
the best illustration of that given
their track record with nobody over 2
700 feet a
right
absolutely stunning team and to mention
armenia is only a very small country of
3 million population they've been doing
so well in chess amazing chess tradition
and uh
just if they're gonna win this danya i'm
gonna be i don't know
it's super super exciting really so
always it always is yeah either way if
armenia or uzbekistan wins
i'm very happy for them but of course as
already discussed there's several other
scenarios possible because for example
team usa and the first team or the
second team of india they hope that the
leaders are gonna draw points
yeah they're they're hoping for a loss
by both armenia and uzbekistan
if possible that would indeed open the
doors for a uh crazy photo finish um now
we see alexis shuroff taking right
around 17 minutes and counting on a very
well known uh position this move queen
b3 it's far from the most common move i
don't have any slav experience with
black i'm a king's indian lifer but as
far as i know and queen b3 is not it's
not an unknown move archers yeah so
alexei is widely regarded as one of the
most uh one of the biggest walls experts
in the slav and semi slav setups for
example after knight c36 bishop g5 but
linux system i remember i mean uh some
discussions with alexa years ago uh when
he would go on and play the batwinnick
system up to move 40 and then he says no
listen oh there's been some major
discovery in batwinnick line move 40 no
you're gonna play this line anymore and
then somebody comes up in a new
condemnation okay no no it's still good
very deep prep obviously preparation for
alexei so i guess now he's trying to
figure out what was i analyzing this
line that was 15 years ago
yeah so i know that after queen this
there's a twin line queen c2 which is
similar i know that d takes e4 is a move
here so obviously by extension you could
play it here and by the transitive
property it transposes something like
this i've seen before takes takes bishop
f5
i mean i've also seen people
uh play g6
basically saying that you've developed
your queen to a slightly awkward square
i'm going to repurpose this into sort of
a grunfeld grunfeld-esque setup i know
garakomski who is another slav expert is
a big fan of playing g6
in these types of positions so
for alexi it's not that he's never seen
this before right he's probably just
deciding which setup to play yeah i
think i think you're right uh e6 is the
move ddx on c4 is the move g6 is a move
uh so yeah maybe he's just trying to
figure out where his opponent is taking
him he's trying to remember what did i
play there it's difficult it's difficult
to remember because usually when your
opponent plays something off beat he's
aiming at something and you try to
figure out what it is
but alexi i mean the time control we
talked about it we like it it's not too
extensive
he needs to put a move on this is
this is move four he's already spent 20
minutes so we'll keep a close eye on
alexis sheriff's time expenditure we
then have francisco vallejo one of the
most exciting 2700 plus players to watch
always comes to the table with uh with
exciting opening ideas and this game has
been no exception a fantasy variation
our tours uh which i always love to see
selfishly because it leads to such
interesting positions well blacklight e6
and i've been considering myself playing
carol with the black color and i figured
out against the fancy variation e6 is
the way to play because it's probably
one of the simplest approaches to black
has the idea is to play some sort of a
french spirit approach i mean you bring
out the bishop uh after knight c3 bishop
b4 there's queen h4 threats like d x f
takes queen h4 go after the opponent e4
and then conveniently at the right time
you want to play b6 bishop a6 and trade
off this supposedly terra bishop on
terrible bishop on c8 so looks quite
normal to me
yeah it's like a french with white
playing f3 it could be worse
um so the development continues bishop
d2 knight a7 tickle tickle bishop a5
bishop d3 and i remember on analyzing
this position that accepting the pawn
sacrifice here defv queen d4 is very
often
uh totally inadvisable it gives white
monster development
and that's the last thing that you want
to allow here is is monster development
so it violates the spirit of the
position black needs to keep this
stronghold in the center knight d7 and
now archer's f3 f4
advancing the pawn one more square and
opening up a more natural developing
square for the g1 knight and that's why
while yakov shows he is a top level
grommester because these players are
thinking ahead daniel right i mean it's
not like you're looking at the knight on
g1 it's not developed okay i need to
develop bonito make a shortcut so then
i'm going to figure it out well the echo
shows clearly that he needs to think
ahead and one of the best practices in
chess is i call it not to chain the
knights not to pin them together because
they taking away from each other squares
you put the knight on f3 you leave the
other knight on c3 so that they are
controlling more squares also
conveniently the pawn on the f4 opens
the d1 h5 diagonal for queen h5 long
castle ideas and suddenly white is quite
aggressive on the king side
i i have to say i like i like what uh
paco has brought to the table so far
of course once the move f4 is made
d-take c4 becomes a little bit more
appealing because white cannot recapture
with the pun so it remains to be seen
what how harant is going to fight this
will he castle will he do something more
drastic we will keep
a close eye on this game okay we have
two more boards in our armenia spain
match we have jaime santos latassa
another italian i think we should start
an italian counter how do you think
about this
daniel
i think i don't think i've made my uh
my views on it clear
okay but this one's a little bit
different from the sindara right because
white has a pawn on c3 rather than a
knight on c3 as the uzbek players uh
like to handle it so this is the more
traditional uh classic gioco piano
h3 bishop oh and again this line with
bishop b5 everybody's putting their pawn
on a5 now everybody
yeah this guy's become the modern stuff
and uh then usually either queen b8 or
knight e7 welcome to modern chess i mean
one of the
modern ideas in modern opening lines is
that both sides are aggressively pushing
forward those pawns on the king side or
queen side if y doesn't do it black does
it a4 b4 h5 ge5 altered i mean welcome
to the modern trends of the opening
theory space advantage now it's more
important than ever
yeah and a bishop trade on e3 with
robert going 97 very typical standard
fare i have a funny story on on the
topic of hobonistan
uh when i was in armenia for the uh 2016
world team championship
our team had a couple of days in yerevan
before we went off to the tournament
site
and i i saw robert havanissa on the
street in yerevan just randomly
and i was freaking out because how often
do you just see a random gm on the
street and our team captain john donald
says like daniel why are you what's the
big deal it's armenia the likelihood
that you encountered a gm on the street
is like one in three
i was like yeah that kind of makes sense
so
robert was roaming the streets of
yerevan okay so
c6 and h6 first thing to establish i
think some people might look at this and
say wait a second doesn't this hang a
pawn
and
it doesn't because if white gobbles up
on e5 i think there's this very very
nasty move rook d1 there's no way the
white allows this yeah that looks
incredibly risky all the respect for
having the pawn but allowing such a
deadly pin is extremely uncomfortable
knight f3 rookie one maybe allows to get
rid of the pin but it probably drops the
pawn on e4 so uh correctly uh mentioned
dania the pawn on e5 cannot be taken and
now what is what it's supposed to do
after that so i guess just normally
casually develop the pieces knight b2 d2
et cetera
yeah i mean instead of this isn't i was
distracted actually by somebody in the
chat saying that the australian board
one is already minus tall but i think
that's an error in transmission anyways
we'll get to that later what do i think
white's gonna do yeah knight bd2
probably knight bd2 um
i don't know bishop d3 knight f1 knight
g3
yeah knight p82 is on the board can i
play c4 knight c3 try to set up some
sort of hamarazzi bind or kings in
position i'm not sure really without
having the dark soul bishop on the board
is this really such a good idea because
black has a pretty good control to dark
squares
yeah i agree it was worth exploring but
uh santos sticking with a more
conventional
method of development i think we're
going to see 97 to g6
uh you know standard standard italian
position
uh so i've played my fair share of
italian games in my career italian games
for lopez i already feel i'm at the m at
the level uh at the moment where i don't
want to play them anymore right it's so
equalish so peaceful pretty much the
same in games all over again but i i
understand why it's becoming popular i
think for partly for the reason uh why
we have to thank uh for that is uh
vladimir kramnik who beat gary kasparov
in the 2000 world championship match he
made berlin as a possibility in the ryan
lopez and that's why everybody's
exploring italian
i see i see so this is this could be
traced back to volodya
i i understand i'll have to he has to
take some responsibility there yeah no
he needs to appear on this show and
claim you know yeah like you said take
responsibility issue a formal apology
um and speaking of formal apologies
another london system
so maybe why are manual patrocion can uh
can join in
and
and oh another lineup your trade on f4
yes right on f4 we've got
i never really understood it what's
what's the big deal how do you decide
these things i mean allowed to take on
f4 play bishop g3 play bishop takes on
v6
what's the thing which uh gives you the
hint that now this is the time to play
it or it's just three different setups
really
yeah i i have tried to play this
particular pawn structure with white i
do play the london from time to time i
must confess and i never had any success
with this and the reason why is because
first i've always found this to be
incredibly annoying bishop basics
uh forcing forcing the bishop trade and
this structure has never been has never
jibed for me like yes yes white gets
this square like congratulations you get
the e5 square
but i've always had a hard time uh
keeping my ponds well defended so
personally when i played the london
i've almost always played it with bishop
g3
um but i think it's largely a matter of
preference archers i think everything is
around equal
um it's largely a matter of like what
what structure you're more comfortable
with i suppose
all right
all right uh sounds good
nihal by the way has the same has almost
exactly the same structure he's got that
pawn on f4
well either this is a preparation dania
or you sometimes get ideas looking over
at your shoulder i mean right you see
something interesting going on i've done
this before actually you know i'm
running out for idea as well to play my
opponent plays something else i have a
peek left and right i see oh look at
that i've never tried this before but of
course in a such competitive moment like
the last round of the olympian going for
the gold medals i don't think they're
gonna do it
yeah i mean you you come to the board of
preparation you play it but there have
been some famous stories of uh two two
pairs of boards following each other's
moves for
an absurd amount of time
um okay so in our uh closing out our
marquee uh potential gold medal deciding
matches uh for today we have of course
uh india against
team usa and let's delve into that match
we have a very interesting position in
hari krishna karawana that's board one
uh
indian
this
smells smells of preparation
it does it does because if you play
something like whatever was some trade
on e4 and push d5 going after the
opponent e4 allowing a lot of um uh
trades to happen clearly hare krishna
has something prepared the big question
is should i take on f3 should i take on
beetle
what's what's the right way to start
well it's i guess the first question is
for white should white take on e4
it's white to move oh my goodness yeah i
thought it's i thought it's black to
move oh my goodness then it's totally
unclear whose move it is actually like
it would be impossible to say if you
didn't know the previous moves right if
it was black to my guess black would
take on b2
okay
queen c1 is not clear that black is
better
um so the two games in the database both
continued knight d2 arthur is kind of
interesting
i guess the idea is that queen takes
some beat is impossible now that there's
rugby one you just drop a piece that i
understand
so clearly 92 deals with this idea so
you have to play i guess something like
95 queen e4 and play gambit right bishop
f5 and claim that you have a super
compensation for it probably well that's
scary for white
it is it is right i mean i see already
scary ideas like uh whatever queen d4
can i play stuff like c5 i mean it's
easy to sacrifice this is not my game
right
yeah but open everything up i love the
move c5 either open the default or open
the c file i i was also seeing a scary
idea with the rook fv8
and and the knight d3 check nice bishop
d3 queen d4 wins the queen very nice
it's always fun to win other players as
queens
as well so c5 rook fv8 i don't think
that hari is is gonna go for i think in
this position uh hari krishna would
probably
okay taking on c7 should be seriously oh
but there's also knight takes e4
this might be a better way to capture
the pawn
now probably black is gonna play
something like
queen g6 queen of five maybe queen g6
yeah i still go for this compensation
queen d4 most likely centralizing the
queen
and now you need a big move rookie yet
yeah there's that i don't i wouldn't
necessarily call that a big move but no
it's just a good it's a move it's a move
all right you can't play bishop to the
point of jito is dropping so what is
having some problems
so harry is more like a positional
player and especially when you're
jumping under a preparation you smell
it's a preparation daniel what's your
approach what do you do here for example
you feel you're playing against a
well-prepared opponent he offers you a
pawn what do you do are you a principal
player do you take the pawn do you test
his preparation or you try to steer the
game to more
uh positional path well i'm always
annoyed when i'm in a situation where i
can sense that my opponent is uh is
still in his preparation is blitzing out
moves and the sharper the position
becomes the more scared i am uh because
the higher the probability that i'm
going to make a mistake so
if i'm hurry christian and i'm out of
prep my first priority is to get a
position or i know i'm gonna have
chances and i know that one slight
inaccuracy is not going to decide the
game in my opponent's favor
i don't know if you can get such a
position
um and and we still don't know if this
is totally out of hari krishna's prep it
might be the case that he is just trying
to remember his file
or he's trying to choose between two
candidate moves uh but but his priority
here should be to get a position that uh
you know either gets fabby out of prep
or uh you know or a position that's as
risk-free as possible because imagine
the kinds of positions that we analyzed
our tours
you can't go into a position like that
just blind
right i mean if you don't take the point
then what right i mean let's try to
picture that so let's say we don't take
the pawn we play something like 92 95
and whatever i mean uh i don't i don't
want your pawns like queen c3 queen c3
so black plays bishop f5 queen g6 and
now the question is what exactly do you
have right because black still has this
initiative maybe rookie had got to
blunder the knight but suddenly you know
you feel like you're obliged to take the
pawn and he did he played queen takes e4
so he took it straight away without any
negotiations or delay
the negotiations were the negotiations
were short as they say right right
exactly exactly
all right so wait queen takes b2 what
exactly
is he cooking up here
i guess uh rook b1 queen c3
yes has to be played 92 probably to his
majesty
and something like 95
looks good looks really good for black i
mean the knight's safely protected the
queen can't really be attacked
uh
this can't be what harry is
you know but what else could he can do
because
queen vito is like forcing matters now
unless i'm uh
wait uh there's no bishop deeds for you
yeah i was literally thinking of exactly
the same thing but no it doesn't work
yeah bishop
a1 king ito would be a very nice attack
on the queen threatening mate but
there's queen bee to check in the end so
yeah beautiful but as they say it
doesn't work
maybe rook d1 but in any case
it's going to be a position
like that and uh
could there be some sort of a perpetual
check after queen c3
rook d2 queen a1
could we see an early draw here
all right dania imagine yourself in the
pentalase position and you're playing
this final match against team usa you
know this is one of your biggest matches
of your career you're playing home
olympiad board one everybody expects
from your team at least get the bronze
medal do you
try to take a way out but then again i
mean uh
the risk is to lose or maybe yeah if you
lose with white i mean you you do
tremendous damage to your team's chances
that i i feel like the important
important thing for hari is to not lose
so i think faced with a situation like
this where he's out of prep and he
senses that either he makes a draw or he
goes to a into a speculative position
that fabi probably knows
no question in my mind that he makes the
draw and i actually think this
particular perpetual is not unlikely to
be on the board in the next couple of
minutes yeah it might happen might
happen and you know
it's impossible to say whether it's a
good decision again it all depends on
the other boards
and uh speaking of the other boards
wesley uh
uh another italian wesley against vidit
mostly against
what
knight sitting on b5
this is a really weird position or am i
hallucinating no you're not
hallucinating is this terror white
knight on b5 i think there is
how did they get there uh
i don't know but uh bishop f7 is a big
threat
also black's of threat of c6b5 has to be
dealt with i guess rook of fate
should follow
and now c6 is a very serious threat
right a4
can i play for i think
and then everything falls back very
quickly
it goes back where it came from
right back from back to a3
okay let's say i go knight g6
well i'm happy with black i mean i don't
slightly understand this setup in nb5
uh black looks very comfortable
whatever
wesley was aiming for
i don't see
yeah no i mean knight on a3 is out of
the game
yeah you have a battery against the f7
pawn but it's safely defended i'm really
curious what
first of all vetted is thinking here
wesley has an hour and ten minutes
so a clear sign to me that he's probably
out of his prep maybe he wants to go
d4 in response to rook f8 could this be
what he plans
oh and if i play c6 you have oh you
can't have dx on e5
a knight e6
can i do that
yeah c6
getting away with it
very nice queen d6 dx on e5 wins
something
and uh
yeah block just lose material impossible
so maybe it is maybe it is d4 that
wesley is hoping will
will be the panacea
all right if you can do it to me i can
do it to you as well so can i play 9x on
e4 and d5 yeah 94. no but i think at a
minimum i can play rook takes e5 and
claim that i have an extra pawn probably
yeah dx squeak c4 bishop p6
should probably start with c6 c6 then
hpc but i mean white is up upon so
definitely not a great choice for black
right so if that's not possible then how
exactly is black going to fight
the movie now you could play knight g6
you don't have to like do anything
drastic
uh maybe just knight g6 and black is
totally fine
yeah but then i can take on e5 dx takes
rook d1 and suddenly this knight on b5
is there to stay because black cannot
easily play c6 the knight can always
jump to b6 maybe it's actually not so
bad you know it looks weird but dania i
just can't help but remember this
particular quote by vishy anand and he
claims somebody else says it because i
had a chance to ask him a couple of
weeks ago i mean i don't care if it's
weird if it works it works right so it
works if it works it works no and wesley
doesn't do stuff like that unless he has
a very specific idea he's not just gonna
like bring all his pieces back
uh and say well you know i tried it
didn't work
uh so so vivid understands that and he's
taking his time after queen v3 maybe
also considering the move d5
and uh we have two more boards to get to
in the u.s match there's also a
fascinating game unfolding in the top
india 2 board seduani against nisipiana
i want to get to that
in just a moment so real quickly
we have dominguez
on the black side of a nimzo indian
against arjun this is another line which
uh has pretty been pretty popular ever
since i think the caruana alexenko game
in uh the previous candidates
which karana won right if i remember
which marijuana just destroyed him
completely like against the same so
indian
uh
i think everybody in this position used
to automatically play e5 this was all
the rage at some point but then people
started playing c5 and it turns out that
this is a
totally full-fledged normal line
so
it's quite interesting that white gets
uh by uh by force now uh now it's not an
outside but protect the past pawn in the
center but black heavily relies on the
control of the dark squares in the
center he has a healthy development so
what white is playing for is the
perspective right i mean i'm playing for
the perspective meaning i have the bish
the pawn on d5 well protected so we
remove every single piece off the board
most likely white is just very close to
winning the pawn end game and black
instead relies on the control of the
dark squares right your king is weak i
see knight e5 i see queen c7 so black
heavily relies on the counter play
yeah i mean as long as the bishop
remains on d6 as you're saying uh
you can admire this pawn uh you know
this pawn is pretty but what is it
actually giving white and white has a
lot of ideas that revolve around trying
to get this bishop off of d6 and that
knight h4 knight f5 is a classic one
uh arjun's last move was a4 discouraging
linear from ever playing b5 uh which
could be a really nasty move that breaks
up white's main pawn chain
so i would say that the position is
probably dynamically equal archers it's
very hard to say as of yet who has won
the opening battle it's just a position
just to know just the position
to be seen right we're gonna definitely
kind of come back to this game and also
i think it's important to mention that
team usa is slowly climbing back to the
top again i'm not sure dania how do you
rate team usa's chances because after
the shock lost the second team of india
they dropped to ninth place can they
still make it to the medals right
they're very very close in the end it
might just not be enough because they
rely on the very lucky coincidence
what's going to happen in the matches of
team armenia and uzbekistan well they're
hoping that armenia and uzbekistan both
lose uh it's unlikely but it all starts
with team usa winning the match so i'm
sure that the captain you know john
donaldson
probably emphasized in yesterday's team
meeting the importance of just focusing
on their boards and letting the cards
fall as they may which can be really
really hard when you get excited about
uh the prospect of
of meddling
um we have one more board by the way we
have sam shankland on the white side of
a nimzo indian against s l
narayanan
is kid
tactician extraordinaire unbelievably
tricky player i've played him so many
times in blitz and i like what sam is
doing he's taking this straight into an
end game
and he's saying i'm putting my you know
my soviet schoolboy hat on and i'm gonna
squeeze you
yeah
and uh one of the one of the typical
ideas here for white is white tries to
blood pressure to see if i'll put the
rook on c1 and the question is at which
moment black plays c5 because let's say
somehow magically black managed to
remove the net from c6 i don't know
where it goes knight e7 knight a5 other
c5 and now the big point is after d
takes b takes you wish you had a paw not
on hv but on a2 because black always has
a counter play at a b file uh remove the
bishop from f4 with knight e5 and knight
g6 then you play rook b8 dark the pawn
on b2 and because of the pawn on a3
white cannot play b3 if not for this
what will be just solely better this is
what i think
something
very close at least to this is most
likely going to happen in the game
yeah but
i guess logistically black has to figure
out a way first and foremost to defend
the pawn white wants to snap it off the
board
uh although i have seen in similar
positions moves like knight a5 uh
actually sacking the pawn and trying to
get control of the c file and this could
get nasty for white because sam you know
yes the queens are off the board but
that doesn't mean that you can't you can
abandon your kingside development if sam
has to get some stuff out on the king
side
yeah that's actually knight five looks
very good neither five rooks here truck
seat as you ready daniel you mentioned
is the very common pawn sacrifice
um again
well in the spirits of the modern chess
so
get a very good compensation i like that
yeah knight a5 we're probably going to
see that or maybe knight d5
it's going to be one of those moves it's
probably a slight edge for sam shanklin
and we will keep a close eye on this
game but we need to get back to the uh
uh sedwani nisipiano game because this
is being discussed right now in the chat
and the uh romanian german player is in
very very serious trouble early on in
this game archers something has gone
this year horribly wrong
let's take a look well this was that
karo khan this was the short variation
totally normal stuff right
right
okay bishop e3 knight d7 capsules 97
i've seen this a million times
c4
also not you know not a crazy idea you
see this type of move
dc bishop takes c4 a6 preparing
preparing b5 i suppose knight c3
and now knight c6 walking into this move
d5
and maybe this was the mistake
sacrificing the pawn on e5 calmly
dropping the bishop back but this pawn
archer is such a problem for black
right and also it's quite important to
mention that black is behind the
development you look at the bishop and
effect you look king on the e8 you still
need two tempe to finish development
so bishop e7 is gonna run into some uh
what it's gonna run into maybe some d6
ideas the pawn on c5 could be an under
attack so what black played he played
knight f3 and 95 right putting the other
knight on e5 and roundup bishop f4 this
is the move that has gotten olivier
uh into a a monumentally long think
now let's understand why this is even
dangerous to be gonna so first of all if
you take the bishop
and you just say i'm gonna ignore
everything i'm just going to develop my
pieces how bad is this
probably really really bad
there's already very nice juicy choice
for
white danya because i can play d6 i can
take on e6 let's say if i take on e6 i
snatch the pawn on b7 maybe it's not
enough right okay because i allow your
king to castle so clearly despite the
fact i have the better pawn structure
maybe not ideal but maybe d6 could be a
major issue d6 again the same idea of
queen b7 the deep one is very strong
this is what i would consider or just
start something more conventional
yes exactly rook b1 this i think is what
the evol bar is screaming at us to do
because if the queen moves away from the
x-ray then we played d6 i think
then we played d6 and then d7
and black and resigned i mean this is
that spells trouble definitely i mean uh
this pawn on the e7 it's not only all
about being a past pawn it's the king
right the black king is in danger remove
the queens maybe black is doing fine
with the queens on the board black is
toast
yeah this is uh
this is bonkers i mean it's move 14
uh black has 50 minutes on his clock
the position is
wildly dangerous he's nowhere near
developing his king's side look at rook
and roanoke's clock i mean one hour and
two for 33 minutes
clearly a prep this is not working oh
man he's in roanoke's kitchen he's in
his laboratory and he's stuck there and
he's lost he's cooked
right now
this is bad bad for team germany this is
not a game that they can afford just to
give away in 20 moves
looks bad so again now he i guess he's
looking for a way out
uh how do you drop the pawn because i
think uh what i would do here in this
situation dania i would try to you know
maybe sell a pawn for the right price
just don't
just don't burn me right away here allow
me to cause allow me to live for a while
let me live for a couple more moves take
my pawns i don't care
but
don't do that right don't get my king
okay if i take on f3 and play bishop d6
am i immediately losing
take take i'm sure
so i want to castle very quickly uh
d e d e and r d1
all right it's so simple and if i take
on f4 i enter mezzo check on f7 it's bad
this is so bad do we even see him i mean
bishop d6 immediately maybe
but then
then again d takes e6 i'm castle i run
away run for my life at least say what
you will about the position but at least
you have managed to castle
right now
but at least you take the pawn on b7
right at least so white has a very very
pleasant uh situation here just grab the
part on b7
and uh if nothing else happens you have
a free pawn
yeah you have this pawn you have the
free c5 pawn
no and and combined with that is the
fact that the entire center is wide open
and white is the only one who stands to
benefit from that bringing this rook to
d1 a lot faster than black and do the
same
wow this is an incredible bit of opening
preparation by ronald sedwani we will
see if he can follow this up and score
the first victory for
uh for team india by the way is knight
t3 last thing is knight d3 a possibility
here
um
okay we we have to obviously calculate
at some point some queen a4 checks right
this is also something we didn't mention
there might be a moment when there's
queen a4 and some sacrifice some b5 i
mean vitto lays the cochlea danya maybe
you could say
uh
there could be a queen a4b5 sacrifice or
take on e6 then queen a49b5 you know
exactly take faker
yeah no there's it's clear that no
matter what black does he's in he's in
very serious trouble okay
so so this is uh board one in india
against
uh germany we can go back to some of the
earlier matches we were looking at of
course the uzbekistan match is the one
that we will probably spend
the most amount of time on
and
very interesting game here
in uh venforce yakuboyev
where jordan and forest has just played
the move h2h4 so this game continues to
get more and more bizarre and black's
clock continues to dwindle
and h4 is not a mouse slip really right
because normally when the bishop is on
g4 you want to play h3 because the
point g4 is annoying you want to trade
it no h4 clearly the idea is to play h5
open the h file
bring the bring away the queen from the
way of the white king castle long and
somehow checkmate black at the age file
wow
jordan is not hiding his intentions this
game wait how did the knight land on b6
oh he played knight f6 to d7 to b6 that
is strange no
i mean you're never going to get to the
c4 bomb obviously bishop takes f3 will
be automatically met with g takes f3 and
this makes things even worse for black
on the king side because now f4 f5
becomes a serious possibility
in case black plays h5
this is bad this is really really really
bad
i'm starting puzzle dania by the movie
knight d6 which is not a very common
move i think in some closed setups after
black plays
e5 d5 sometimes not b6 appears under the
horizon but here i have a feeling that
snot on b6 is um
not doing much really i don't understand
maybe the idea is a bit deeper he wants
to play knight c6 next threaten to take
on f3 push e5 and after d5 he plays
either knight a5 or take on f3 knight e5
go after the pawn on c4 i mean this this
has got to be the idea
yeah so you mean wait you mean knight c6
here right knight c6 so white plays h4
knight c6 i want to take on f3 push e5
which is uh one of the common themes of
the king's indian fight for the d4
square and now if i push d5 try to
punish you
yeah then you play something like 95 and
the pawn on c4 is difficult to defend
because the pawn g7 conveniently
is pinning the knight on c3
right
so i suppose you could go knight d2 here
for example
yeah that's
and then h5 will become a problem
yeah that's a very valid point of course
i mean i that's why i don't understand
knight b6 i think this is the idea but
it looks a bit fishy to me to be honest
i agree i feel like uzbekistan is in is
in a good amount of trouble on this
board and and also on the clock so this
is the game between van forest
and notre back yakuboyev and of course
we have a fascinating game brewing
between abducator and gary what what
games catch your eye
shall we stay on this match or
is there something else that you would
rather check maybe let's make another
overview how still of the of all the
boards because clearly timos baxter now
is
uh the main favorite to win the olympia
because again to remind you the overall
standings uzbekistan is leading the
tournament together with team armenia
they have the same amount of points
there you go there you seed 17 points so
if uzbekistan clinched the victory i
think this is pretty much it i mean
they've got it they've got the best
hybrid x in the tournament team india
too maybe could try to catch them up in
case if uzbekistan draws it could be
very close but i think if it's because
then wins that's it
yeah and and a lot of course hinges on
their white games that's how they're
going to have to be doing their heavy
lifting uh with notre back abductor
fresh off of that miracle win against
kukesh
yesterday
facing anishigiri in that rook g1 night
or that has sort of turned into a dragon
and it continues to get more and more
complex anish geary's knight is on h5
it's heading for f4
and i
i'm not making heads or any heads or
tails of this position i don't know
what's going on queen d2 looks tempting
to me
maybe go after these puns who knows
right
i mean structurally wise i like black
but i think this queen d2 like you
already pointed out dania asks a very
direct question how do you defend your
pawns hello
yeah
uh
i don't know maybe you have to sacrifice
one of the things of the modern openings
is that you can always sacrifice the
pawns and then claim you have a
compensation
well we'll see but you know you're
talking about the team uzbekistan i
think we also have to mention that uh i
think it was yesterday when it was
announced that uzbekistan is going to
host a 2026 world chess olympiad they've
gotten the rights and i i think this is
a major victory also for uzbekistan
chess because they've been
growing a number of amazing chess
talents chess is booming in the country
and now the chance to cause the olympia
i think for them it will be just dream
come true if they could clinch this
olympiad and then take it home in 2026.
that would be nuts and and this is just
the first generation i mean rustam
kazanjanov of course is sort of the
patriarch
of uzbek chess but uh in terms of the
young generation you know we have these
four or five gm's there are untold
numbers of talented juniors i mean
sometimes i look at these tournament
listings and there are these untitled
2400s from uzbekistan who are
undoubtedly going to grow up to
uh join their slightly older
uh compatriots on future editions of the
uzbek olympic team so uh what an
incredible year this has been for uh
captain ivan sokolov and his
uh young unbelievably talented team of
grand masters so queen d2
seems to be
seems to be the way to test to test
black's setup
knight might come to f4 at any moment
i was thinking of going king b1
in b1 and now i'm going to make a
fascial expression um i'm going to have
a very strong counter play on the pawn
on c2 i just need a strong move here
maybe castles
yeah
castles looks good get out of there get
out of the center now the point is queen
d6 or queen e4 is queen c2 i'm a happy
person i guess
i'm not really clear about that to be
honest i mean though queen c2 i don't
know i mean already i started to have
doubts really so king a11 i see ideas
rook c1 suddenly what's very active this
reminds me some of the typical positions
in the night or where white is suddenly
dominating at a queen side first games
that jump to my mind are fabi karanas
two victories here in this olympiad
first against maxwell whichever round it
was then yesterday against um
he played not yesterday but day before
yesterday two very impressive victories
with the white collar in the night or so
very often white is just dominating the
queen side and neglects what is
happening inside
yeah and this concept of giving up upon
a check i think is very instructive a
lot of players probably wouldn't
consider
uh moving the queen away from d2 but
when your king's on b1 like this it's
queen take c2 is often not quite as
scary as it appears because the king and
a1 is
is perfectly safe in many cases so
critical moment here notre back is
taking his time
anish has taken approximately 30 minutes
they're obviously out of prep it's move
and uh very very complex position
right
wow so many interesting games ahead this
is again a morning round 10 a.m in uh
india final round of the olympiad uh
everybody's still cough asleep usually
daddy i want to do myself i just tried
to survive the first two hours
yeah those are the those are the tough
hours you know once you get into the
groove uh it gets a little bit easier so
speaking of uh surviving i think it's
time for us to take our first
uh coverage break it will not be a long
one so rest assured because we will not
leave you hanging uh here at the final
round of the 44th chess olympiad for
long so
we will be back with more final round
olympian action in just a couple of
moments
see you soon
okay we're ready for a small press
conference it is something that has
never happened anywhere in the world
before to have correctional facilities
all around the world playing at once in
a chess tournament arne is very proud to
participate in this tremendous event it
will be an honor for us to be part of
any of your future undertakings
last year we organized the first
international um intercontinental online
championship for for for prisoners it
was 31 country participating
40 teams five female teams i know
without name in the country
that some maximum security facilities
where prisoners
could not be
more than one in a room before i met him
i would never like that people do that
i think yeah it's chess competitions but
all over the world online throughout the
jails playing against each other that's
a whole different
thing like he opened that up
there was a
incredible
level of anxiousness that was neat that
reminded you of how athletes would be
before the big game before the kickoff
[Music]
do
the host nation india also happens to be
the top seed in this year's women's
olympiad
surprisingly india has never meddled in
this event but the time to do so is now
with her top women's squad
2011 world championship finalist humpy
canero leads this team
she's the highest rated player in the
entire women's event because canero will
be favored in every matchup team india's
success likely depends on a great result
for her on board one
but india's chances by no means end with
humpy
india has one of the strongest second
boards in the event as well harika
dronovalli a three-time third-place
finisher in the women's world
championship journal volley is likely to
be a key contributor to success in
chennai
vaishali rameshbabu is the third board
for india and is by far the youngest
member of india's top women's team
playing board 3 vaishali takes on a
similar responsibility as her brother
pragnanda who plays for three for
india's second open team
on this team the fourth board belongs to
commentator extraordinaire tanya sachdev
in fact sachdev has represented her
country in every olympiad since 2008.
in 2012 she even won the individual
bronze medal for her board
the experienced bhakti kulkarni
completes the tournament's highest rated
roster
a medal may be unprecedented but with a
squad this strong gold is clearly the
goal for india's leading women's team
and we are back here at the 44th feeder
chess olympiad this is the final round
we will know after today
which teams take away the
gold silver and bronze in the women's in
the open sections and speaking of the
women's section let's check in and see
how the ladies are doing
our top match of course is team india
against team usa and the position in
front of us belongs to the game of tatev
abrahamian with the white pieces against
i am bhakti kulkarni for black and a
clear fried liver
uh variation archers that seems to have
gone pretty good for black
yeah i like black's position because
black has a healthy development as usual
the knight is stranded on a5 but black
has healthy development good pawn center
he's thinking about at some point to
play c5 bishop b7 position the last
bishop on the long diagonal one of the
common ideas in the position knight then
the knight goes to c6 and d4 but talking
about the team usa i think it's quite
important to mention they have been
fighting back and they had a pretty
dismal start uh at uh the south of the
olympia they lost couple of uh
first uh matches uh then they were
struggling to get back in the fourth and
now team usa already has won the last
two matches uh at least i think it's
quite important for the team spirit
no losses last two rounds they're
climbing back and maybe just maybe this
is still a chance for team usa to get
medals also in the women's competition
indeed and uh the one very important
thing that's going to determine that is
of course irena crush's game she's got
the white pieces on board one against
uh pragnanda's sister vaishali
who's had a pretty up and down olympiad
losing a painful end game
uh to the polish player kilbasa
so vaishali looking to avenge that loss
and for irena very very important with
the white pieces to try to put as much
pressure as possible
is she succeeding in doing that it's
hard to say we have a very very sharp
grunfeld here
well uh it's difficult to tell
immediately dania because i i have a
feeling if the white pawn was on b5 and
uh what would be allowed to play c4
clearly what would be better right i
mean you have this beautiful knight on
e4 the bishop e3 but having the deep one
so far it won't i'm not so sure because
black and play moves like bishop f5
bring the queen on c6 rook d a double
the rooks just snatch the pawn on e4
i have a feeling that white will be
forced to show something what what she
has for the pawn because if the d-pawn
falls what exactly do you cap maybe it's
the chance to go after the exposed black
king some ideas like windy too i the
opponent h6 somehow i'm just guessing
here
yeah i mean i
i feel like white just got the uh you
know the the better end of this complex
position it just seems more exciting uh
to play white here with that pawn on d6
it's also important yeah bishop a6
there's c4
uh so the skewer isn't really effective
and it's not entirely clear where
shelley should park
her light squared bishop i mean should
she blockade the pawn should she develop
it more aggressively to b7
i feel like i would prefer white here of
course if irena loses this pawn then
everything changes
yeah
probably yeah probably uh uh the next
couple of moves are gonna be really
really important to show us where the
game is going to be uh hitting us uh do
we move on to the next board maybe
what's going on there yes and we have a
big another big game of course humpty
canero uh has the white pieces on board
one against uh tahir jonova
and another grunfeld
let's talk about dr jonova right i mean
she has suffered no losses so far i mean
look at jonova clearly not the highest
rated player in the team usa she was put
on board one clearly the captain knew
what he's doing and he's right right so
tokyo genre is doing a fantastic
tournament so far six and a half out of
nine so she is the only player in the
team usa who has not suffered a single
loss
that's an incredibly impressive stat
um and you know she
has a monumental challenge to hold off
humpy canero the highest rated player in
the entire field with the black pieces
uh in what seems like a a pretty
dangerous position she's currently up a
pawn
as humpy shifting her rook from f1
to e1 now my question what if black just
takes on d4 here what exactly
has the indian player cooked up because
the knight from d7 can come out to c5
and once that happens
i don't really envision black being
worse i mean black is still up a pawn
right and then the big question dania
what do you do do you trade the queens
and try to somehow snatch the pawn back
which you already lost or you go all in
don't try the queens and somehow do try
to get to the black ink well my guess is
something wants something like queen b2
but after knight c5 you can't really
take on d4 because of rook d8 uh
well skewering
the bishop on d3
so you'd have to play a move like bishop
c4 in order to pin the e6 pawn and then
take d4 on the next move
b6 and bishop b7 i mean i feel like
black is very close to consolidating
here
yeah black is feeling fine the the black
king is slightly weakened but you can
always play queen g7 to cover the dark
squares and i think that white is just
not having enough pieces to make white
suffer if white had the dark square
bishop obviously it would be a different
story i think you're right daniel yeah
queen beetle keeping the queens on the
board would allow humpy provide more
pressure but actually uh conor campi has
not been having uh a very
uh solid tournament for so far i mean
she's sort of doing all right but she
has got some rough games she suffered
one loss so far in round 7 against team
azerbaijan
and uh
very very important game obviously for
her as well i mean to bring home the
olympia for the home olympia the gold
medal i think the entire nation is just
waiting for this to happen yeah i mean
everybody's holding their breaths and
uh
there is one other game in this match
uh the the ladies match between india
and usa and that is tanya sachdev
against carissa yep and karissa is a is
a king's indian player and she has
played her favorite opening
in this game once more
oh and interesting
action on the on the queen side the
knight on
a4 so
for the last two moves how would you
explain daniel i mean how do you make
this decision so that to average viewers
so why did you trade the knight on b3
why do you play not a4 why do you think
that this knight is necessary to be
traded for the nylon c3 and not on the
knight on b3 what's the thought process
here yeah i mean first of all i will say
i don't love black's position i feel
like the inclusion of the moves h4h5
definitely favors white white's got the
same-ish same
structure going on the king's side uh so
so or or you know first it should be
established that i think black is
playing defensively here but if you play
knight takes b3 and you allow a takes b3
then despite the fact that white's pawns
are doubled you're making it a little
bit easier for white to push b4 and the
problem is that even after white pushes
b4 white's gonna have another beep on
that could later land on before as well
and eventually white is trying to push
through the move c4 c5 so by playing
knight a4 i think carissa is trying to
make it a little bit more difficult for
white
uh to push c5 in favorable circumstances
of course uh white could take on a4 and
push c5 here but it's not quite the same
when you don't have a pawn on b4 i think
c5 here archers i think you'll back me
up on this would be way premature
uh i'm asking for something like c6 to
be played you know i don't know i have a
feeling that the white king is in the
center for slightly too long
maybe there's a way immediately to
punish that the bar slaughter doesn't
like it but this is something that both
players definitely have to evaluate
because normally like already daniel
said c5 the idea one of the typical
ideas in the king's xenian is to take on
d6 establish a weakness on these six and
you have clear targets to attend to at
the queen side thinking about maybe
landing some minor pieces on b6 or 92
knight c4 at some point later while
black is supposed to go for the check
met the king side but how do you do that
now coming h4h5 included
no it's going to be hard
and very very strategically complex
position another
thing that worries me for tanya is the
fact that she's spent almost half of her
time and it's only moved 14.
and
eight of those moves were theory
right time management again it's one of
the most important topics i guess in
chess i mean are you by the way down
yourself you're a fast player i mean
obviously i know you're very fast player
widely regarded for your uh amazing
bullet skills but what about the time
management i mean how do you
manage your time are you more like a
gracious person would like to think
every every uh 99 of the time for the
first and most then you figure it out in
the increment or you still try to think
about the big picture that you need to
allocate time for the decisive moments
of the game i think my time management
is pretty good overall i'm definitely
not like a fast player i in the last
tournament that i just played i had a
moment where i spent i think the most i
spent on one move was 48 minutes
so you know i'm capable of spending like
an hour to think about a line what i try
to do is leave myself always with enough
time uh to take you know 15 or 20
minutes at a minimum in critical moments
so i try to play on the fast side when
i'm playing confidently and i'm playing
simple moves and then i try to slow
myself down in critical moments when
there's a lot of stuff to calculate but
i really don't like uh playing in time
pressure i feel like my time pressure
play is worse than my blitz play which
is
pretty common by the way just because
you're a good blitz player doesn't
always mean that you're the greatest
time pressure player and i always get
really really nervous when i've got like
10 minutes for 15 moves i i can't do the
grishock
right right so that's actually i think
only grisha can really do it to be
honest i mean how do you play
30 seconds on the clock i mean
yeah either way white's time management
is not ideal having spent half of the
time in a simple position
i guess we'll see
we will see and that is our
india usa matchup in the women's section
uh shall we move back to the to the open
section and see how
those matches are doing let's do it
okay
back we go
and
we want to oh my god the sedwani
nisipiano game has uh another series of
updates let's see how
olivia dieter has tried to deal with
this incredible preparation from roundup
so he did play knight d3
d-e-f-e bishop takes b7 snapping off
that pawn
and i think nissipiano has actually
found a pretty decent way
uh to try to survive this
this is ugly but it's but it's a game
and his knight on d3 is pretty safely
protected by a bunch of different pieces
and you also have ideas like to keep the
knight on d3 because if you are allowed
to play c4 bishop c5 suddenly black is
incredibly active so i would expect that
dwight is going to position the bishop
on e3 iii
i have a feeling that none of the
players really care about about the pawn
on v2 it's all about the harmony of the
pieces right so you want to expose the
black king you want to throw everything
you've got towards the black ink bishop
e3 queen f3 with g4 ids that would be my
thought process while black is thinking
about how do i secure the knight on d3
and
yeah bring the remaining arsenal into
the game
yeah i mean it's okay plus 1.6 it that
doesn't give us too much information i i
think this game could go
either way in the next couple of moves i
could see this being a win for raunch
and in five more moves or i could see
black sort of stabilizing the situation
more or less but he has spent over half
his time and you know he still has a
very difficult defensive task
ahead of him
right um
now
it's been a while since we've looked at
some of the other germany india games so
maybe we can
okay first of all kaimer against gukesh
is
i'm pretty sure just going to be a quick
draw
uh huh
so uh after the excellency five actually
this is good news for good cash you know
because
uh after suffering such a painful loss
yesterday i think uh he is now quite
vulnerable
i don't know his psychology state i mean
how well he uh handles defeats clearly
yesterday he was heartbroken you could
see it in the live feed
and he had little time to recover so
having a quick draw it's i guess
fine i'm slightly surprised that winston
was not able to put up a greater fight
because he's doing well so far he had
won the last two games he leads the team
germany in the final round they're
trying to
not really sure fighting for the medals
maybe not but going for a higher result
still
i mean all right yeah probably it's
gonna be a draw you're right oh by the
way uh hari krishna and karwana did
indeed draw in exactly the method that
we discussed in that perpetual check so
we already have one result
in the uh india usa match
so you did predict that right queen
beetle queen c3 queen c1 that was indeed
repeated right all right yep okay so
that doesn't
isn't necessarily that great for either
team it just offloads all the pressure
onto the other boards yeah so this game
is hurtling tour to draw it's equal
material
uh balanced material and this will
finish pretty quickly we have spain
against pragnanda
in a pretty exciting position it's going
to be two bishops against two knights
wow i mean and and the material balance
is equal right so
95 wait what white 95 why do you play 95
there something was traded on d5 right
yeah oh he took a pawn yeah because i
was wondering
why didn't he move the bishop away from
c3 all right all right 95 and clearly
white is i'm sorry black is having a lot
of dark sword weaknesses at the king
side so bx on c3
could happen most likely i i don't see
bishop d5 to be played uh because white
parts ways of his powerful lifespan
bishop and now the big question
who has the better position i think
already answer is quite obvious it's
wide but if you look in the perspective
if the trains get traded off the board
then black is simply having maybe the
better pawn structure because white
spawns are shattered
white has more porn islands which is
three islands against blacks yeah still
the three three points but some kind of
technically yeah but it feels like
white's pawn structure is a million
times worse yeah but of course white is
not going to destroy queens
no no white's going to keep the queen on
h3 that's a really nice square it's out
of the way it's aiming at e6 and it's
tying down its counterpart on e7
it's also setting up tactical ideas
along the lines of bishop a3
which could be could be annoying for
black
and lastly the queen is defending the c3
pawn so it's doing a lot of things at
the same time
um rookie one is also a nasty idea just
going after the e61 i i actually really
don't like black's position at all
could i play f5 or it's too much i'm not
really sure f5
uh oh well
i'll wait it was black tomorrow because
let's say we make some random of rookie
five i think it's a defensive mode let's
say let's just make some quiet move like
a6 or rookie f5 you see the knight on d5
is under attack you take on f5 rookie
five g takes
uh page six oh this is asking for
trouble oh this is a disaster the rooks
coming into e1 no this is was absolutely
a threat
and absolutely a reason that prague uh
sticks his rook on f5
but obviously this does potentially walk
into bishop b4 i don't know if white
should play it immediately uh there's
also the move c4 in the mix and the good
thing about c4 is that it opens up the
long diagonal and
it potentially sets up the move bishop
a3 because it actually links the queen
and the a3 square
a very double-edged game so far so which
can easily go either way uh still i like
white chances slightly more yeah this is
a big game too for uh svane uh to win
because nissipiano is likely to lose
that game against zedwani so this would
counterbalance that game
and offload the result onto the
remaining two boards
speaking of the remaining two boards
well we have that draw that's coming in
uh very likely to happen soon in kaimur
gukesh and finally we have nihal sarin
who was playing that london system
against matthias bluebama has he managed
to get an edge i think he has i think
nihal sarin has exactly
the kind of position in the kind of time
situation that he wants what do you
think yeah absolutely daniel i agree
this is one of the dream positions for
white uh i i have a feeling that the
black did push e5 early at some point to
establish some contemplate because the
last thing you want to do is
quietly watch yeah i think about here
black did push e5 voluntarily seeking
counter play
and now the big question the big
question i think which is in everybody's
mind is it enough you know i'm not sure
because usually when strong dramaster
center such position they see obviously
black has an isolated pawn on d5 we have
a beautiful blockade on d4 awesome
bishop on d3 so we're gonna trade queens
we're gonna enter the endgame but of
course the big question in the mind is
this enough all right because as uh the
famous dr zigbertarr said good pieces
uh good positions don't win games good
pieces don't win games good moves
win games that was totally butchered but
you get the point
um because black you know the d5 pawn is
is so well defended it you have a knight
you have a queen white's not winning
this pawn anytime soon
and uh you also could get a bunch of
trades down the e file now who are those
trades going to favor like big question
of course for matthias should he take on
e2 my instinct is yes because if he
takes on e2 and white takes back with a
queen then you get control of the e-file
i don't know if that's important but at
least it's something
yeah i'm also thinking this about from
the wise perspective i played quite many
quite a few games uh in exactly the same
position so having the queens removed
off the board usually favors wide so you
have this weakness on d5 and what i
usually do in these positions i keep at
least one pair of rooks on the board so
that i can create more targets
and after the queens are traded moves
like f3 g4 try to grab more space at the
king side so i think it's quite natural
that black keeps the queens on the board
because if you look at the position more
closely you see that viking is slightly
vulnerable the light squares around the
white king are
not ideal right you need to put a bishop
on g to protect them and that's what
blue bomb is doing here queen f6 pretty
aggressive move as he keeps the tension
on the board and rook a to e1
would be the
uh you know incredibly natural
continuation for
for knee hall rook e1 here
and i don't know exactly what matthias
is intending in response i don't see any
tactics on the king's side can i play
knight e5 here i mean keeping more
tension maybe
thinking guy h5 h4 ideas you know and if
you play something like f4
is this a move you want to make because
i mean the one thing about the pawns
they never go back if you play four
that's it this pawn is never gonna go to
f3
and you've you've uh thoroughly weakened
a lot of the light squares in the center
but on the other hand it's very hard to
exploit them if black takes on d3 that
knight on d4 is such a hero you would
love to stake a bishop on e4 but you
can't quite get it there there are no
direct flights
uh to e4
indeed so i i feel like nihal would be
pretty happy with a position like this i
still think the likeliest outcome here
though is a draw because matthias is
such a solid player right i've seen him
defend these kinds of positions time in
and time out
right
yep probably but nicole also is one of
the best scorers in the team second team
of india so far extremely solid uh
player so far let me pull up
his
card i think he was performing at
uh just the second where he is
performing a 2737
rating in this tournament no losses by
the way again wow he is the only player
in second team of india with no losses
so far
incredible that's like an anchor after
and of course he was joined by gukesh
until the last round
but nihal is just so consistent he is uh
wise beyond his years in terms of his
playing style uh he plays like a
seasoned positional wizard
and uh that's such a good player to have
on an olympia team like he's only what
17 18 years old he's just incredible
right it's incredible i mean he's one of
my favorite players to watch both in
blit of course he's a phenomenal blitz
player
but but also in classical he's over
26.50
and i think it's only a question of when
we'll see him in the in the 2700 club
daniel i have to ask you this question i
mean there's a a little bit funny story
since what age the players consider to
be a veteran
that's a great question
because i guess it all depends on like
how long you've been at a certain level
i would almost consider nihal a veteran
but then i can come up with another 17
year old who's just very recently made
his way uh to you know the 2600s
and then he's basically a baby
so i guess it's all in the eye of the
beholder
i just i just remember this interview by
one of the i mean back then about 10
years ago leading uh chinese grandmaster
suani who did say once i'm a veteran i
mean 30 years 30 years old because
there's the younger generation of 14 15
years old hard professionals already at
age 30 already a veteran i don't know
the justice just becoming younger
younger and younger by every year that's
crazy yeah now 20 25 is basically i'm
i'm older than than than most of my
opponents in any particular tournament
most of the time
so that's a pretty scary thought
uh but anyways let's not dwell
let's not dwell on that it just makes me
you know
realize how old i am let's instead dwell
on the armenia spain match it's been a
while since we've checked into our
top ports our dcn against
the noted slav expert alexey shiravan
shurov
44 minutes after only 13 moves and he
did end up taking on c4
after an extensive
extensive uh think
and they got this structure
and then alexi decided to take on f3 so
very very sharp stuff by sure of what a
surprise
fire on board
so
white is quite happy with the structure
because white gets a pawn center and two
bishops
black claims i always will have a
counter play against your center so
again it's a clash of styles
um
clearly
white is having the slightly better
position right now yeah but you can't
underestimate the counter play that
black will have in the future g6 bishop
g7 maybe target opponent e4 double the
rooks at the d file this starts to be
quite serious counter play
so i would
argue and you can correct me
that ideally black would want to castle
king side black would want to go g6
bishop g7 and then castle kingside but
it may be the case that shirov does not
have enough time and he's got a castle
somewhere and if he's pressed for time
then he's going to castle queenside
but i think that's an important question
i'm not sure if castling long is
actually so bad because this is also
where the white king is positioned and i
imagine if the white king was positioned
at the king side castling along would be
risky choice because of the potential
queen side pawn assault with b4 b5 etc
but here is the white king obviously no
i think you're right i mean castling
long is um definitely an option here
so could white consider
for some reason the move rook g1
appeals to me i mean it is it does set a
very simple trap if black castles then
there's bishop even this is not the end
of the story i mean black can take on h2
black has a million ways to deal with
this from queen takes h2 immediately uh
to a move like h6 so
i don't think rook g1 really changes
anything
all right yeah rook g1 also drops the
pawn on h2 something to consider yeah
because black can just take it play
queen d6
and just
you know try to hold it and the white
has to prove what he has
not very easy i mean not very easy i
definitely see the potential of
black's defensive set up yeah the chance
to overtake the game and i think
actually maybe daniel you're gonna agree
or disagree with me i'm not so sure but
i have a feeling that sometimes uh very
good players they on purpose go to they
know it's actually slightly worse
position but they
understand the potential of this
position of the counter play that they
can take over the game at some point
later
no i 100 agree and and this is one of
those positions where you look at it for
five seconds out white's much better
white's got the center two bishops
uh the knight's passive but then you
know you look at it a little bit longer
you say well wait a second black's got
control over the d5 square the d4 pawn
could become a liability white's king's
side structure is a little bit deficient
and uh you're absolutely right i think
the potential energy in black's position
is immense
and this could be exactly what alexi was
was was aiming for and it's very clear
that he's playing for a win and whatever
happens we are in for a very very
exciting middle game
and so
has taken so many sculpts in this
tournament i mean he didn't have a great
start he was having minus one after
six rounds
then listen to the people he beat fabian
um
krishna
last round shakuriyama medyarov i mean
these are all called
i'm kidding that's a wait what he let me
get that straight he beat fabiano hari
krishna and mom and yara three rounds in
a row
pretty much yeah there was a drawing
between without the satoru who is also
the future of grandmaster
three and a half out of four just
average open tournaments right i mean
it's i believe that that's crazy
i mean if i beat uh
hari krishna mamidyarov in one
tournament just that i would go around
telling my grandkids for the rest of my
life
wow he's amazing and he plays bishop e3
which is the totally understand i think
that's probably the best move
uh defending the pawn on f2 and
repositioning the bishop
into a slightly more juicy square
nebucha is also trying to discourage
black from castling long because after
long cast you need to watch out for d5
the pawn on a7 like you said summer is
under attack maybe not immediately at
some point later it's just a good
centralizing move
but definitely uh yeah it definitely
makes it scarier for alexia to castle
queen side and a big decision now for
black how is he going to arrange
where is he going to put his dark
squared bishop which way is he going to
castle lots of questions we will see how
alexi answers them and he's already
answered one of them as he castles
queenside without further delay but okay
we've got a bunch of other games
in this match to look at and one of them
of course is our
valejo milk wait
17 minutes
no wow no this can't be right
wait but let's think about the math if
if paco has an hour 19 then i actually
believe it
but this is
nuts
17 minutes after 10 moves
somebody wake up crunch because i mean
this is the final round obviously it's
10 a.m in india now it's maybe slightly
more than that what is it actually it's
something like uh
11 30 it's clearly too much time spent
on a theoretical position which has now
led to some sort of a french defense
position with this a weird fancy
variation in the carrick and now this is
a french and uh
wow not number at all
far from it and uh
it does seem like a very pleasant
position for mr
vallejo
and we will try to get uh confirmation
of this but
you know regardless of what the position
is this would be the most concerning
aspect of it if frank indeed had 16
minutes and it's his move
right maybe he's just not happy entering
such french setups because
i think it's all about feeling those
positions so if you play the character
not necessarily you feel the positions
that arise in the french so that was
pretty smart choice by paco going into
this and now
after the last moves um again we have
the french set up black is suffering uh
with this uh la square bishop on c yet
which is not doing anything
i definitely prefer white so ideally
what i want to do here is at some point
i'm not saying do i have to do it right
away at some point i want to take on c5
and establish a very nice outpost on d4
and then slowly grind it in a very nice
long positional game
and if like try c takes d4 are you going
to play knight e2 or will you take on d4
straight away
i i don't know both of the moves look
pretty good maybe 92 maybe you're right
yeah maybe 92 not x on d4 keeping the
knot on f3 then again it weakens the e4
square
you have to evaluate
how does it how does it feel not sure
knight c594 could be an issue
yeah even immediately knight c5
um
interesting so apparently if we look at
if we look carefully at the camera and
we see
the spain armenia match in front of us
you can see a knight on a4 so a couple
of moves have been played we will wait
for the relay to update so
don't uh take the clock transmissions
word for this front probably has more
than 14 minutes but it's clear that he's
made a couple of moves that haven't been
updated just yet
but he's got a night that's you're
probably right i think he has played
like knight c5 and knight a4 we will
bring you those updates the moment that
we get them but in the meantime we can
move on to
the other boards we've got patron
against anton guiharro
um a game that we have not
checked out yet
how is the sequel daniel because i'm
seeing that black is having some
problems with the pawn on c5 yet the bar
is uh announcing that this is equalish
uh i don't see how to protect it maybe
it's something to do with the
some sort of a to play against the
pawn on e5 but how do you do it still
positive
queen g5 maybe
yeah
queen g5
and if i play even
queen e2 yeah
i suppose i can go knight d4 to save the
pawn but i agree that black is worse in
the resulting position
right because not the popularity yeah by
the way not even not queen e2 but g3 is
also a move tactically solving the
problem of 95
i'm not convinced this is equal at all
definitely why this pushing
no and no question about it and again
dividend tone down to 40 minutes after
only 15 and this i believe because
it's it is very difficult to figure out
a way
the black and i a save the pawn and if
he decides to sacrifice it like how do
you get the most amount of compensation
for it queen b8 came to my mind as well
but i actually think it fails tactically
knight
on knight c5 maybe queen takes b2
actually it is a wonderful move
ah so maybe it does hold everything
together and if i somehow protect the
now the pawn on e
five or the f4 whatever how do you keep
the balance something like a5 queen b6
maybe
ah or tactically tactically somehow
holds together but i mean this looks um
quite unclear how black is going to keep
the pawn yeah maybe queen b6 right away
if i take with the knight the pawn on b2
is under attack and if you play rook c5
a5 could be an issue
oh a5 is a huge issue because
you actually yeah you can't stop a4 and
white's position collapses
wow really interesting stuff but
major problems to solve for dividend so
like if he loses c5 with no compensation
i mean
that's going to be a huge problem why
it's just going to have a free
two-on-one on the queen side as well as
excellent excellently placed pieces so
a little bit of trouble here for for
spain uh in david anton's game
right on uh manuel petruccion hasn't
really played so many games because he
did play the first three rounds then he
had like uh
one week
of uh rest in chennai because the entire
team uh i mean with the reserve player
of khaf kanician was doing really so
good that the team captain didn't see
any reason to change it i'm not sure how
did it affect him because i think it's
tough to sit there and not to play for a
week right i mean obviously it's a team
event all you care is the team result
but still i mean you want to go water
you want to play you want to show that
i'm capable of so i mean it's stuff for
petrarcian also to come back after not
playing for such a long time
yeah you're right i think some some
people might think that oh you know the
the players like to not play because you
get a day off you get to watch your
teammates play
but you're absolutely right i mean
nobody comes to the olympiad
you know
and and and and looks for a vacation
like if you want a vacation you're not
going to go to the olympia all these
players want to play they want to
represent their country and chess
players generally embrace pressure yes
they feel nervous
yes you know they appreciate the rest
sometimes
but uh in the critical moments everybody
wants to step up to their plate for
their country that's what makes the
olympiad so magical well this reminds me
daniel every single time when i've had a
wrestling olympia do you think i'm
relaxing no i'm sick sitting in the
hotel room and i'm watching the team's
games
getting very nervous i mean why do you
play this why do you go there what are
you doing i mean it's so difficult
because you wish you were there i mean
and trying actually to do something good
for the team so
that's 100 true and that was my
experience in the 2016 world team
championship as well let's switch back
to the usa
india match
we have this wesley game that uh kind of
started pretty bizarrely now it looks a
lot more normal and it looks like
wesley's gotten himself a pretty
handsome advantage
out of the opening
so this entire maneuver of 95 odd jump
did work
it worked i mean he did end up going
okay so we saw the position after queen
b3 he did end up going rook f8 and d4
was indeed
was indeed wesley so's ideas his knight
manages to evacuate back toward the
center amazing
and wesley with uh
you know total control over the e file
difficult for black to develop his
bishop because the b pawn will hang but
how exactly does wesley accumulate the
pressure that's always a problem in
these types of positions right
right and wesley wesley has been one of
the best performing players so far for
team usa he's again the only player who
hasn't suffered the single loss i mean
still despite the fact that team usa
was highly regarded as
a huge favorites pre-tournament right
more than 70 points average higher than
everybody else uh
still in then it turned out
to be a slightly different story but
wesley has a good tournament so far i
mean every single player unfortunately
is losing rating but wesley is
at least very close to performing at his
rating
indeed and
what do you think about the idea of
going knight h4 here and swinging the
knight to f5 looks very good
i mean i love it i mean 95 is a major
threat having the knight so close to the
king looks
very very good
yeah looks like wesley's got a sizeable
advantage before we switch to the next
game let's take a quick listen at the
usa team profile
with a couple of powerhouse countries on
the sidelines team usa is the popular
choice to take gold at the 44th olympiad
blessed with a talented roster led by
fabiano caruana the top-seeded americans
are looking to secure gold as they did
four olympiads ago back in 2016.
that gold medal was historic for the
united states as it was the first gold
for team usa since 1976
a drought that spanned across five
decades
loaded with olympiad experience caruana
and wesley so were both key contributors
to the gold medal team in 2016.
even one of the newest members to team
usa levon aronian is no stranger to
competing at the olympiad ironian bagged
gold while representing armenia during a
stretch in which that country won three
gold medals across four straight
olympiad appearances
also making his team usa debut in
chennai is lanier dominguez considered
to be one of the strongest players ever
to come out of cuba dominguez rounds out
a team usa roster with few weaknesses
coached by chess.com commentator robert
hess team usa's roster is so deep that
reserve sam shankland would likely play
first board for most countries in this
year's events
as expected caruana leads team usa as
the first board but even with a gold
medal already under his belt fabi heads
into this olympiad with plenty of
motivation
coming off his clunky finish at the
candidates tournament fabby will need to
find his game for the us to realize its
potential as the favorites
carrying three of the top-ranked players
at the 44th olympiad while facing a
significantly weakened field of
countries the united states is well
positioned to come away from india with
just its third gold medal since 1937.
the time for team usa is now
and one of the strongest olympiad teams
ever assembled is team usa but a couple
of disappointing matches and here they
are
needing a couple of miracle results in
order to have a shot for gold but a win
gives them a definite shot for
at the very least
a bronze medal so we already have a
result with fabiano carolina drawing
hari krishna in the opening
and the other big game of course is
argenti's game against linear dominguez
right so here the struggle is going on
we had this discussion earlier that what
he has himself a protected passport in
the center black is relying on the
counter play
rookie one i guess the fight is going on
for the center i
like white really because i have a
feeling that what has achieved slightly
more i mean maybe it's still slightly
too early to tell
no i agree
so this dark squared bishop is it i
guess it's coming out to be two but you
of course always have to be very careful
about queen d6 as lanier takes on e1 i
think eric i see is not developing the
dark soul bishop with a purpose and
maybe the idea is to also leave rookie
to rookie to idea as a possibility so
this bishop on c1 actually does a
wonderful job it controls the c1 h6
diagonal conveniently looking at the
pawn on h6 controlling the diagonal and
also not blocking the rook's fastest way
to join the game and take over the e
file right because the conventional way
of course is whatever i mean bishop b2
queen f2 rookie one then you double
rooks but why do all of that when you
can do it a lot faster
no i the more i look at this the more
i'm starting to like white's chances
quite a bit in the evo bar
seems to concur now lanier played this
move knight d7 f8 earlier in the game my
guess was that he was trying to get his
knight kind of italian style to g6 but
the problem is okay you do that
congratulations
where are you going from here are you
really going to f4
probably i mean maybe this is like some
only active idea i don't know
um yeah and it stops rookie though
because after rook a2 one thing is quite
clear 94 what is not going to give up
the dark sweat bishop it's too precious
because you need to control the dark
squares which perform i guess
and the other question now what because
rook on a2 suddenly doesn't make a lot
of sense unless you want to position
tonight and target the knight on the f4
not very easy but leniergo is queen d6
first so he keeps the knight on f8 for
the time being it might be the case that
he was actually just trying to open up
his lightscore bishop
and queen d6 setting up the battery and
setting up potential threats on the h2
square should the knight on f3 move away
right i think that's better let's
altercate though to be honest it looks
so normal
it's your rookie two white has very very
clear ways to improve his position and
you could still play bishop b2 after all
of that happens
i'm starting to get a little bit
concerned for uh for lanier's position
this seems to be the most trouble that
team usa is in on any of the three
remaining boards right sam is better and
and uh it's pretty clear that wesley is
much better so
uh this is a you know big game for india
to try to deliver
a victory and again i think for team usa
they're really modified fundamentalism
it may be it's not even enough to score
the victory they need to score a big
victory because again to remind you the
tie breaks very heavily rely on those
small pawn or small points it's not just
the small points it's actually slightly
more complex but you need to score
victories you need to score them big
you do indeed and of course uh they need
they need team
uzbekistan to lose and they need armenia
to lose and we can check back into the
uzbekistan uh netherlands match
we've got our headline game anish geary
with the black pieces against notre dame
abdusatorav and the position remains
incredibly complex i feel like every
time we check into the game our turrets
it's like moves have been made but the
position doesn't really change
it's this weird feeling i get you know
what i mean
right i i do do understand that and i
actually find it puzzling that
black didn't take the pawn on c2 if i
see it correctly we had this position uh
in on our analysis board before right
just couple of moves before
black had a chance to take the pawn on
c2 right here we go queen b4 look at
that i mean anisha is not taking the
pawn on c2 yeah how often do you see
that there's a pawn on c2 hanging with
chuck nope i'm going to strike in the
center with d5
and wow
if white would have taken on d5 then and
only then i think was black planning to
take on c2 and then e4 i guess king a1
e4 and suddenly conveniently there's a
very nice checkmate on beto hanging
indeed there is and this is like total
chaos knight t4
of course the evol bar is giving zeros i
mean what else right
uh but notre back deciding against
against that can you really blame him
and he plays the prophylactic move c3 he
says hey uh you had your chance to take
on c2 uh i'm not giving you any more
chances to do that i'm keeping my kings
safe
this game is blowing up daniel i mean
very difficult to predict how it's going
to continue because black has sacrificed
the pawn he's made the typical counter
strike in the center d6b5 he has healthy
pieces however also his own king is
exposed
oh
could be very interesting
i guess we switched another game
yeah let's uh take a look at some of the
other games in this match and i know
there's stuff going on in tuts of
abrahamians game in the women's usa
india match so we'll go to that next uh
we promise
uh but another big game where uzbekistan
has been in trouble for a long time is
the van forest uh yakubu game that weird
king's indian and i actually don't
dislike the direction that this is
moving in uh for the used background
master i feel like he's managed to
create uh you know
as as good of counter play as you can
create in a position as dubious as it
was
i can't help but feel that black has
created some weaknesses at the king side
upon an e6 the pawn on g6 is weak right
so you wish you had the opponent f7
guarding those weaknesses but you don't
knight c4 very aggressive mode you know
daniel i look at this it kind of
resembles me the alekka and defense
because this is one of the common themes
knight b6 d5 c59 c4 now the question
what happens next you protect upon e6 i
guess you do you have to if you don't
let's say if i play
something else you might wonder uh jump
under queen e6 and knight g5 threats
because the rook on h1
yeah
is causing a lot of trouble king h7
knight g5 and suddenly there's a mate
in fact yeah any time your king is on
the h for all knight g5 becomes right a
serious problem now the question then is
how do you defend
the e6 pawn i think the most natural
move is something to the effect of queen
d7
uh perhaps with the follow-up idea of
bringing the rook into a fade and
preventing light from pushing the g not
the g4 g4 is really not that dangerous
no i'm telling you i think black's
position is improving
i i know exposition is looks a lot
better than it did 10 moves ago
or well maybe that's weird yeah i kind
of didn't like it maybe it wasn't really
so bad
another thing to point out that b3 does
not trap the knight because the knight
always has a retreating square on a5
it's not the greatest square but at
least the knight stays alive and then
black and played b6 to chip away
at uh white's pawnshin and maybe create
some chances of his own against white's
king which is not entirely safe on the
queen side
is it now
yeah this is weird
crazy all right
okay yeah
um what else catches our eye we have
sindara against buck that isn't too
interesting of a position it's just sort
of a normal italian we can skip that one
for now
you know
you can see my bias
my bias is uh i'm not able to hide it my
anti-italian bias
but on the final board we have warmer
dime against vaquitav and
the evo bar seems to believe that jihan
gear has survived max romerdom's
preparation
and uh he's more than survived it he
might be simply better in this position
well clearly things have been going well
for black because if he gets the bishop
on b7 i mean just look at visually of
his position right black has amazing
bishop on g7 which is uncontested the
bishop on g5 for white is just targeting
pawn on e7 once black puts the other
bishop on b7 white is simply left with
the weak pawn on d5 and he clearly has
to show something for it i guess it has
to be queen c6 i mean what else right
otherwise white is just a lot worse
yeah you got to take the plunge queen c6
and then
what should black do bishop d no bishop
d7
i think queen c6 is not very good right
because you create this monster on c6
you might regret later
yeah i know i i i can't see black going
i mean maybe i can take and go something
like rookie eight
and and i can try to surround this pawn
but i agree that it's quite scary to go
for something like this
i agree that it's quite
scary um
not sure exactly what black should do
here it's it's actually quite hard to to
make a decision here
so if i play bishop d7 still take on
uh queen d6 might be an issue like queen
d6 eta x and bishop b7 is still a trap
so you need to watch out for this and
then bishop takes d6 hits the knight on
c7 no this should still not be a big
problem from like at a minimum black can
play rook fca bishop d6 then bishop
takes c3 but
clearly vaquita is going for more than
just uh liquidation
so
big moment here for white he's got to
decide where to put the queen he's up on
time
but uh
despite some good opening preparation it
looks like warmer dom hasn't followed up
in the most accurate way and he is worse
right and i'm thinking also some queen
h4 ideas but i think in general black is
just happy to trade the pawn on d5 for
the pawn on e7 as long as it opens the
position between h4 not e5 is that the
avoidable is that even possible because
95 is rook d1 you need to again
evaluate which at which point oh queen
h4 knight takes d5 yeah and now rook d1
is that the moment and after e6 you can
take and go bishop e7
yeah that's that's the idea something
like this could be played and i i
thought maybe this is how it could
continue because it would ask black to
play bishop c3 very responsible move
because if you keep the pawn but you'll
leave your king highly vulnerable
yeah and i think this is one of those
moves that a computer will not hesitate
to make and you can see that the evolver
seems to believe that black is
very much in charge here but for a human
to give up a bishop like this is always
painful essentially regardless of the
other circumstances
so it would be a very gutsy call indeed
if akira
uh gives that bishop up at some point
for the knight on c3 i can easily see
what i'm going here because anything
else is just worse than here he has at
least some counter attacking chances
bishop removes knight g5 so black will
have to play f6 to cover the dark
squares which further weakens the king
all right
okay so
[Music]
we'll keep an eye on this one and by the
way david anton giharo did indeed find a
way to save that pawn against manuel
petrossi and we don't have to go to that
game right now uh but it looks like he
has managed to stabilize the situation
that game is pretty likely to head
toward a draw
all right
so we have a couple of interesting
developments in the uh women's
uh top matchup between the us and india
we had
uh some crazy developments in the tatev
abrahamian game shall we have a look at
that one yeah let's have a look
there's uh i get the word that something
is going on i'm sorry daniel uh
something is going on in uh sheriff's
game i'm not sure if we jump to there
right now or a moment later apparently
sheriff has blundered something our chat
is going crazy i think he sacrificed an
exchange let's maybe spend like a minute
on totip's game and then we'll switch
back to sherlock's game is that right
let's do a compromise
okay so in tatev's game
it it just seems like white has made a
lot more moves than black has
and first of all black is thinking
instead of taking back the rook which i
don't really understand
so what happens here after bishop takes
h4 why is white so much better
i guess because of the more harmonious
peace coordination because
uh white give up the gave up the pawn
and we had a discussion about this
position earlier that uh black had the
perfect position after the opening now
suddenly white is having a very good uh
harmonious play
maybe the fact that the black king is
still in the center and the pawn on e5
as you are showing there with rookie one
could be an issue so the opponent e5
difficult to defend bishop f6 i'm
looking at uh some knight h550es or f4
ideas all of them look very good for
white oh and there's another really cool
idea if black castles and i admit the
use of a certain silicon friend to
figure this line out knight back to d1
now you say no problem black plays e4
and all of a sudden whoop queen c3 and
there's a work on the knight in the pawn
on g7 this uh is like a deja vu watching
yesterday's game of good cash blundering
a piece against
pretty much the same idea yeah hopefully
he's not listening to the commentary
he would uh bring back some bad memories
and tata indeed playing rookie one so a
huge game if the us can score a victory
here that would be an upset uh tata is a
really really dangerous player of the
white pieces and uh
we'll keep a close eye on this game as
it unfolds but i know we want to look at
the sheriff game so without any further
ado we switch back to the open section
and we take a look at alexis shuroff's
position against gabriel sergician what
is he doing
we know he's fine
what
he played
i thought he sacked and i thought he
sacked it we have to look at his facial
expression we have to figure out a way
let's get him on camera
let's see if we can get him on camera
you don't launder bishop ge5 i mean
there's got to be
this has to be a sacrifice win h5 bishop
d8 bishop h6 is that the idea
no but then f4 bishop maybe maybe black
is claiming he has enough counterplay
against the pin pawn on the f4 and
center but my worry is that
gabriel is not going to take the rook on
d8 i feel like there's a way probably to
trap the queen
oh
i don't believe this
or h4 f4
f4 or h4 both look incred
incredibly scary to me
i mean clearly h4 is
not real i mean it's like plus two
but apparently the best move is to start
with bishop e2
just start just bishop b2 let me just
have a look at what happens if let's say
i'm just not comprehending what's
happening there i just snatched exchange
i mean i love material i'll take the
material if i can so if i just take the
rook on the e8 where's the big idea
where's sheriff's idea so i'll play the
ship h6 and rook takes the in and i'll
basically say that you have uh problems
with your center pawns all of which are
weak
queen h4 is a move the pawn on the f4
falls you have a great control to dark
squares i absolutely agree this looks
great and like you said
white is not obliged to take
right and maybe that is what sure of in
his mind didn't uh
invest enough thought into the question
what if white just develops a piece and
actually goes after the queen because
the problem if black tries to force this
bishop off of g5 right then you no
longer have the h6 square for your
bishop and that's huge that changes
the whole landscape of the situation and
gabriel sergion has played bishop e2
he has played bishop e2 it's on the
board i think by now sheriff already
realized what he has done because the
queen on h5 is uh a prison that he
created for his own queen he sacrificed
the exchange g6
tried to get the counter play
some hallucinations happen how do you
deal with this i think actually big
threat is h4 because if you play h6 i'm
not gonna move the bishop at all i'm
gonna play h4 and keep the
bishop g5 it's just over no
yeah i just made a couple random moves
to illustrate that this is indeed a
queen trap
and these two
uh three-headed demons the fact that the
rook on d8 is hanging let's not forget
that and the fact that the queen as you
said perfectly is in a self-made prison
uh which it really can't get out of i
mean maybe you can play queen h3
uh trying to get out of it that way what
do you think about that
uh yeah but then you just take the
exchange of the year for free right
because after bishop h6 i have bishop g5
and no longer it works so this is this
is not the same
i mean i'm i'm looking at sergio's
performance again uh in the last round
so i have to remind he did beat players
like karana harikrishna mamidyarov
pretty much in raw and
sheriff on top of that
wow this is this is basically resignable
and on top of everything else alexi with
26 minutes
for 23 moves
this is all i mean you never say the
word over in in olympiads you know we're
both experienced we've seen crazier
things happen but just if you look at
the body language devastated alexis sure
of this is not what he was looking for
on move 17 of an opening that he has
played for his entire chess career a
disaster disaster on board one for spain
and that forces players like paco
vallejo
to deliver on their boards
and also this is a major result
possibility for team armenia because
they are one of the leaders in the
rankings and this win could be a huge
result to make a historic another gold
medal for armenia i think they won it
three times if i'm not terribly mistaken
in the past so team armenia has been
doing wonderful so far and what kind of
news it would make i mean uh of course
level leaving armenia for usa and
armenia still clinches it as a team
it would be an incredibly powerful
statement and as we already discussed a
powerful statement to the effect that
team chemistry matters experience
uh of the players matters so it's not
just the number of players over 2 700
uh that that makes a difference and
armenia has shown that time and time
again more good news for armenia is that
robert hovanissian i think is going to
hold a draw with the black pieces i want
to say against taimei santos latassa is
there anything white can do to squeeze
something out of this position
um
well i can definitely see this game
being played on for quite a while
because black does have the pawn on g5
which is a minor problem and if you want
to protect it with something like f6 uh
all the light squares suddenly around
the king get pretty weak
so i think black is uh thinking about
training queens and white doesn't want
to trade queens because if we trade the
queens you start to see that a lot of
white's pawns are on the collar as his
bishop so then definitely black is just
doing fine but still i mean the final
verdict is that the position is just
balanced
so if you play queen h5 i think the very
important idea is knight f6
or is there something ah maybe actually
knight b6 is even
more clinical knight b6 attacking the
bishop and that gives you a tempo which
you use to bring the queen to e7 and
defend the pawn yeah that looks pretty
solid yeah maybe maybe not f6 also is uh
good but
right this is that's definitely i i
would consider maybe bishop e3 play
immediately
um do we move on to the another board
maybe this looks quite george yeah this
looks this looks very josh as does the
petrossian anton guiharro game
okay so that's the armenia match it
looks like we're pretty much up to date
on all of the games there
um
we have several options we can move back
to the uh women's to the to the other
boards on the usa versus india match uh
we can look at uzbekistan what what
catches here i'll toss the ball back
into your quarters since we since they
started to talk about the women's
tournament and then we were caught back
with the sheriff's game maybe daniel i
have a suggestion to go back to the
women's tournament let's have a look at
what's going on there still a great idea
very very uh tough fun around despite
the fact that team india is leading the
overall rankings by one point nothing is
taken for granted there's a very narrow
race in the final round there's four
teams uh behind team india with uh one
point match point less so something like
five teams potentially could become the
gold medalist in the end
indeed and we have been focusing on the
uh
the match between america and india
obviously it's not the only important
match in the women's section we also
have ukraine and poland which we can
update you on but uh really quickly uh
we have irina crush on the top board
against our vaishali on the second board
i suppose
and this game seems to be heading toward
a draw despite the fact that irena is
very likely to lose the pawn on d6
yeah i think here white already is uh
already playing for a draw because
there's nothing to be done about this
pawn on d6 there was no attack so as i
sort of predicted the opponent d6 might
fall but
what how do you play this for the win
because let's say
uh gtx gtx king e6
i'll just shove the pawn to d7 right and
keep the thing maybe i can even just
take on d7 play a4 and just say try to
crush through me
yeah no totally i think that's exactly
what you do so black's only idea is to
play a6 and b5 but
what white can do is play king e2 a6
king d3 and after b5 i think i can just
ignore you
right right bishop d2 for example
actually
or maybe
yeah bishop d2 by the way is good i
think even just one stake also allow
black to push b4 if you look at this
position i'm not confident that black
can break through but maybe no i don't
think you can break through
yeah like this black plays b4 you can
just offer a drug you can see two king
b3 everything's on a light square
right there's no way to crash through
the only square i see it's the g5 square
we have our dark bishop
targeting that square so i put a bishop
on e3 and if you try to escape crash
through with something like bring the
king towards the king side uh whatever
king h7 bishop f6 bishop g5 the pawn on
c5 is under attack you can't do that
right
by the time you do that white's going to
take all of the kingside pawns exactly
right this is going to be a draw and a a
pretty solid result for team usa and it
appears that carissa yip has a pretty
big advantage both on the clock and on
the board against tanya sachdev
ooh
she has made
lemonade out of lemons a position that
looks quite dubious out of the opening
has turned into a
phenomenal king's indian initiative
well no matter how you look at this
position dania i i have a feeling that
white's position has gone completely
wrong because
oh f4 f4 making things even worse for
white i think right so i mean what's the
spirit of the king's inner for white go
uh target queen side where's your queen
style play there is nothing there where
is your queen side at all
where's your queen it's just
non-existent all right and where do you
put your king
ah you can't yeah just be my guest i
mean i don't know
well
yeah i mean
in the event of a trade the knight i
mean it's a tale of two minor pieces you
can't castle king side simply because if
queen takes h4
that pawn sticks out like a sore thumb
and if you don't castle then your king
is eventually going to be torn apart in
the center
queen b6 eventually e4
white's position is borderline lost here
looks like that yeah incredibly
unpleasant incredible pleasure this
could be a major chance for team usa
women's team who have been struggling in
the first half of the tournament they're
fighting back they're finding their pace
getting uh the rhythm and
well we might just see that
they might do it actually
they might get it done and carissa she
has been struggling mightily she's lost
to a couple of players lower rated than
her but
uh you know players with the best
olympiad careers they don't have great
olympiads every time but they deliver
when it matters most and carissa is
trying to do
just that and we have canero and tokyo
jonova on our final board
very complicated position very similar
to what we looked at last
and this is i think where india has
their big chance they need humpy canary
to deliver on this board
definitely need and also black wants to
play some play b6 bishop b7 which was
your suggestion the last time we looked
at this to bring the bishop in the game
so that apparently black has solved all
case problems but always see is that at
the moment white is down two pawns right
that's that's the fact and of course the
pawn on d3 is gonna fall but it means
more trades how do you avoid more trades
than your capital so queen g7 very nice
move because black says okay i mean you
can snatch the pawn on d3 but it's going
to cost you a couple of trades so bishop
to e3 or 93 let's trade the queens there
you go i'm never going to lose this
absolutely not doubt up upon is black
well placed pieces and as we were
discussing earlier queen trade basically
kills off all of white's winning chances
and humpy
with a a difficult decision here about
where she's going to put her queen in
order to avoid this uh unpleasant
standoff
good chances here good situation for
team usa
maybe you know daniel maybe something
like f4 queen f2
yeah do it like this queen h4 g4 g5 or
knight g4 this is the only thing i can
think of uh anything else queens
disappear so though so does humpty's
chances to
and hopes up in the game
exactly and b6 is very likely to happen
by
black okay things heating up big time in
usa against india
all right so as we swing back to the
uh open section the next time we check
into the women's section we will update
you on the ukraine poland match uh there
was a draw by the way
uh on one of the boards in that match
but before we do any of that it is time
for us to take our second
break of the day we are two hours and
change into the final round of the 44th
chess olympiad we hope you're enjoying
the coverage ladies and gentlemen we
will be back with more action from the
final round in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
hundreds of thousands of people playing
at any moment you'll quickly find a game
with someone at your level whether
you're a total beginner or a grandmaster
you can play games at any pace against
friends
other members or one of our many
computer personalities
chess.com makes improving fun and easy
sharpen your game with tactics puzzles
and enhance your strategy with our
videos and lessons by top masters learn
from your own games with chess.com's
easy to use analysis tool
regardless of your skill level chess.com
has all you need to take your game to
the next level chess.com is your go-to
source for chess news
live coverage of tournaments events and
everything in between
experiencechess.com anytime and anywhere
whether you're at home on your computer
or on the go with our mobile apps
signing up is free and easy so what are
you waiting for join chess.com today
[Music]
welcome to india
the game of chess was born here
thousands of years later many of the
world's best players have made the trek
to represent their countries at the 44th
chess olympiad
the most prestigious team chess event on
the planet
in chennai the chess capital of india
circumstance has cleared the way for
perhaps more countries than ever to set
their sights on gold
india has high hopes for keeping the
hardware at home
with three top teams competing in the
open and the top seed in the women's
section the host country has legitimate
reasons to believe it can sweep gold and
more
entering as the favorites
team usa has suffered multiple dramatic
disappointments so far
will they have what it takes to finish
strong and keep their metal hopes alive
while medals count some accomplishments
won't be measured in gold
the women's team from ukraine has
overcome adversity just to make it here
now they hope to honor their nation with
a memorable performance
namaste dosto
in one place for the first time in four
years these olympians are together again
the 44th olympiad has brought the
world's best to the place the game of
chess began
and with that let today's games begin
welcome back to the 44th feed 8 chess
olympiad in front of you you see team
netherlands and team uzbekistan hard at
work contesting an absolutely critical
match grandmaster daniel nereditskiy and
grandmaster archers naxons bringing you
coverage of this all-important final
round and before we delve into the
pivotal games of the pivotal matchups
let's have a look at what all of the top
teams are playing for as we review the
standings in the open section going to
the final round our tours uzbekistan and
armenia they have been the stories of
the olympiad because neither player has
a single player over 2700 how crazy is
that it's absolutely insane and also i
have to mention that both of these teams
are among the youngest teams in the open
section because the entire team i mean
not armenia but i was talking about uh
india uh uzbekistan and india they are a
very very
young talented team lineup and teamer
mina is showing what it means that you
have to get this great team spirit and
so far it's working for them
it is working for them indeed but
netherlands
and the us none of those teams are out
of contention both of them can still
meddle uh obviously a lot of cards have
to fall their way but we've seen crazier
things happen in the olympiad as we look
at the matchups we have germany india
too we've got of course uzbekistan
netherlands armenia spain in the us
contesting a big match against india's
main team
okay
back we go into our pivotal match with
the leaders team uzbekistan trying to
hold off a hungry netherlands team with
anish geary
uh on board one and a crazy development
in jordan manfores's game against
notrebek yakuboya with an exchange
sacrifice
by the uzbek youngster he's gotten two
monster knights on d4 and c4 archers
what do you make of this sacrifice does
he have enough compensation here
um my first impression
something is not right you know because
i definitely
uh feel that this is a interesting idea
in the black is
allowed to put the knife on c6 so knight
c4 knight a5 knight c6 the strength
strengthen the knight on d4 which
protects uh the pawn on e6 then things
are good but somehow i'm not so sure you
know because
black has sacrificed exchange for a pawn
and you see this pawn on f3 is a target
the pawn on f4 here you go as you're
showing it this exchange shack fights on
d4 but so is the pawn on e6 so if i play
here something like b3
i mean uh is this really good i mean b3
bishop f4 i'm not sure how to actually
but properly played out all right you're
saying if rook takes if knight takes f3
then there's rook takes e6 well i just
blundered that of course the knight on
c3 is under attack but yeah now that's
all you're winning
yeah
you totally you're just testing my
tactic so b3 i suppose
i suppose i have to move the knight back
what was the evol bar seeing here can i
play
after
what is there knight e5 sorry to
interrupt you
i think that might be 95
okay wow rook d49 f3 are you kidding me
is this incredible
and black is double rook and yet it's
equal because if you play rook d1 you
take an e1 there's the knight ganging on
c3 this can be easily missed because you
played b3 clearly with the thought in
your mind okay 95 is impossible because
it hangs you can't miss that yeah you
can't play 95 come on rook takes d4 it's
over but no the line continues and if
i mean the appeal of b3 is that if you
can force the knight to a5 then that
completely justifies the move b3
i think so yeah a major dangerous moment
for jordan forest big chance of a
blunder here of course i think he will
see it he's been taking
quite a while on this position so if you
don't play b3 what do you play do you
play rook d1 to d3 you don't really even
need to defend the f3 pawn black isn't
threatening to capture it because black
cannot afford to lose the e6 pawn can i
play
bishop f4 you know i'm not sure if i
need this move but um
uh i want to target the pawn on c7
somehow no the bar says i cannot do that
the idea was to provoke e5 which
maybe i don't need even to provoke at
all because black is going to play c6
anyway yeah this is not great this is
not great i immediately see that
but my idea was daniel be very careful
my idea was to push away the knight from
d4 somehow i want to trade it
and get to the pawn on e6 but i mean how
do you do it
ah so maybe then it is worth starting
with rook d3 but not in order to defend
the f3 pawn but in order rather to play
a move like knight e2
but again i it just doesn't seem all
that
all that dangerous because even if you
play knight e2 black can step away to f5
i mean i don't think this is all that
bad for black
maybe this is a hard position to play
and that's why that's why i think he
sacrificed this exchange right i mean uh
to going for a fight and he feels that
his team is in danger and
he's trying to take over the game looks
oh by the way somebody in chat thank you
to ad
favelas for the astute tactical vision
there is the move bishop takes h6 but i
don't think it works tactically again
because of this pesky knight takes f3
move the rook is attacked if you move
the rook you drop the bishop if you take
the bishop black takes the rook and
either you let the knight evacuate or
you allow black to take the bishop on g7
good idea but doesn't seem to do the
trick yeah that is a nice idea
all right but what do you do yeah what
do you know about f4 i got f4
and if i play
if i play something like what do i play
here i mean
i think i need to protect the pawn on
e6 can i play king f7 and k95 then
king f7
hmm
yeah i don't see exactly how white
improves his position because
surprisingly these pawns are controlling
a lot of very important squares
and the knight controls b5 i don't have
knight b5
uh maybe b3 now
maybe b3 not a5 probably
let's say i go bishop b2
and my idea was to play knight five h5 i
mean maybe even start okay now i cannot
play h5 first because the knight on d4
is under attack but 95 h5 i want to fix
that weakness on h4 and the 95 is a
monster how do you get rid of this
knight at all i mean that is a huge
night that is a huge night
no this i can see this actually turning
in black's favor i mean i can see white
being a little bit sloppy and all of a
sudden
you've got a ton of pawn weaknesses
black as a pawn for the exchange already
and if black can get a second pawn for
the exchange then we could potentially
start talking about black taking over
the initiative this game a very
interesting practical decision by
yokuboyev
one thing i'm daniel really puzzled is
why the bar likes it so much because
it's an exchange sacrifice for a pawn
and this means it's the most minimal
material advantage that one can get and
the white spawn structure obviously is
shattered this means there is something
tactical probably i mean somehow white
wins the pawn another pawn i mean where
is it
i don't see it it's
it's hard to say i mean we'll we'll wait
for jordan uh to make a decision because
i think white's next move is going to
dictate the course of the game but in
the meantime let's have a look at the
other games
in this match uh abdul satorov and gary
have gone into an end game
an endgame in which only one side can
win no rebecca busatoro is a monster
that is official the official word from
chennai he's a monster he is a monster
right
confirmed
and uh he's about to keep his pawns on
ish uh his gambling in the neither of
seems to have backfired again he
sacrificed the spawn he didn't take the
pawn on c2 he was going for a sharp gun
to play earlier in the opening and now
and now he's just down a pawn i mean if
you think pawns don't matter well you're
wrong bones matter
and by the way
uh van forest played b3 so he missed
knight e5 and we will keep an eye out on
whether yakubu if spots knight c4 to e5
fascinating stuff going on
wow can we yeah i guess we're gonna jump
back to that uh game later
i mean when he makes a move we'll we'll
update you on on what decision uh
whether jacob
spots the right move but
one little subtlety here if white plays
knight takes f4 prematurely i actually
think there's a devilish trick black
plays okay maybe actually maybe rook b6
instead of rook b8 and
actually rook takes b2 and bishop takes
c3 so king c2 seems to solve all the
problems no actually drop something
there yeah and actually black is the one
who will be up upon at the end of the
line
racing
and there's nothing white can do because
bishop takes c3 on top of it all is also
a threat
all right all right there's a word
something is going on in linear
dominguez's game uh maybe let's move on
to that game and check it out so in
conclusion uh just a a a slow move like
rook e1 to g1 is actually what the
engine wants the problem for black is
that eventually he's going to lose the
pawn on f4 it's like dead weight and
white has a big pawn majority on the
queen side so a sizeable advantage for
notre back but we go to the dominguez
game because
uh the american grand master is in
serious trouble in this end game against
argenti
all right now the big question is uh
how black is going to defend this so
obviously one of his ideas is try to put
one of the pieces on d6 something like
knight e6 and knights are widely
regarded as one of the best blockades
right you put the knight on d6 it blocks
the past pawn but one thing i'm really
concerned in lanier's position the
biggest concern is the pawn on c5
because if the white pawn was not
standing on a5 black would be allowed to
fix the weakness on c5 by playing b6
here this is not the case knight a4 is a
major threat
yeah and
you know if black's knight ever leaves
d7 the net a4 will become an even bigger
problem so with that in mind i think
lanier is trying to get his king to d6
it's not the same as blockading with a
knight but at the very least he will
blend uh some reinforcements toward the
pawn on c5 and arjun he does the same he
brings this king up to f2
yeah so far definitely what has achieved
more because his pawn on d5 has become
much more stronger than after the
opening black's king side control attack
has failed as you see obviously there's
no queens on the board the darkspawn
bishops are gone so definitely black
needs to be super careful so let's say
the black place king e7
is white well i assume that white's not
going to trade rooks but
that's not a given maybe he will there
is the very nasty move ricky one track
oh
and you actually cannot play king d6
or actually maybe you can but
for some reason i hallucinated the 94
check wins upon but
all right i guess there is bishop f5 and
this does threaten 94 check
and if i play knight e to f6
but the position is not ideal right i
mean you are you're not on d7 the vision
once yet is slightly stuck it looks ugly
but i want to play g6 next i mean maybe
there's
uh if i play knight f3 to d2 that could
be a problem i was thinking that too
knight e4 check is coming
oh
that's a big
likely to lose that pawn on c5 and if
you do
well we know what happens then
yeah oh it's curtains
so you can't do that you can't do that
so i think in general you write what you
said i mean white normally wants to keep
the rook alive because that's i think
the general strategy from the stronger
side you don't trade off pieces you are
not sure that you might not need later
so rookie one after king e7 rookie one
might happen if indeed king d6 is not a
possibility
maybe
one check on king d8 something but still
the pawn on c5 is weak
king e7 rookie one checking d8 yeah
probably the placement of the king on d8
is better than on d6
uh but linear is walking on thin ice
here he is
he is going to have to be perfect if he
wants to save this game and a loss here
would be pretty disastrous for the
americans chances because sam shankland
we won't go to his game right now but it
looks like his opponent is holding the
position together
and that game i think is very likely to
end in a draw
um
there's also wesley's game against vidit
and that's another game uh archers in
which
i'm not too impressed by by the way that
wesley has put pressure and maybe this
is just because of it it's excellent
defense but i don't see wesley winning
this game either
well at least we can agree on this that
the wesley is going to push this for
forever because
i think he wants to keep the queens on
the board if you trade the queens you
have this very nice isolate the opponent
d5 beautiful outpost on d4 but in
professional language we have this term
it's just not enough so you need more
targets you need according to our nymphs
of hs keep postulated more than 100
years ago you need a second weakness and
black is not going to give it to you so
i think wesley what he's going to do
he's going to manoeuvre he's maneuver
his opponent to total boredom i don't
know queen d190 for 93 90 for g3 or
whatever i mean keep the queens on the
board and try to get that second
weakness on the board
i think it wouldn't be too much of an
exaggeration to say that this is almost
a must-win game for team usa because
lanier is not winning sam shanklin is
unlikely to win his game and uh i mean
if
if lanier loses then uh it's basically
all over uh but okay so we will keep an
eye on wesley's attempts to squeeze
something out of this slight advantage
in the end game
um apparently tatev is about to win her
game over in the women's section
uh and that would be an absolutely huge
game
so
what shall we turn i don't know what to
turn to we've got so many interesting
games outdoors i always have a hard time
deciding there's the sarkeesian sure-off
game as well what catches your eye
um i don't know maybe we continue since
you're watching team usa's matches maybe
we do uh jump now to the women's section
and see how the women's team is doing
because they are making a comeback
so far i mean they were struggling in
the first half as we discussed and now
they have very very important match in
their account for the medals also for
team india
one of the most important matches of
their careers so far i guess the first
ever olympiad in india chennai
right and they just uh dream about this
gold medal so team india is looking
towards at least a draw in this match
and i'm not sure if that's gonna
guarantee the first place victory for
sure because they are leading the
overall rankings by one point so what do
we have here
first of all irena crush has officially
drawn her game against vaishali in
exactly the way that we discussed so
that is the first result of the day but
this position this is the big game it
appears that tatev can take the pawn on
e5 and she will be winning if she does
that
the point of course is that bishop takes
d2 check looks scary but after the
simple queen takes d2 white emerges out
of the complications up a full piece
because if you take the rook then
white's king takes black stroke
that's not possible i'm slightly afraid
daniel about rook takes on d2 you know i
start to see ghosts i mean is there a
mate or something so rook d2 rook e6 i
mean probably there's no mate i mean i
was thinking about retreating with the
rook and give you a check on the first
rank
oh i have this move
uh oh you have rookie three okay that's
important otherwise you know king b1
rook d1 check uh
looks scary
it does and i'll tell you what scares me
what scares me is actually the move
queen e6 to d6
because this reinforces that now bishop
takes d2 is a huge threat how exactly
does white deal with that while keeping
the attack on the night can i make the
move here
yeah rookie yet is looking nice
i totally saw that yes good tactics
archers you really did your puzzle rush
this morning thank you yeah okay let me
amend that a little bit to queen d7
let me amend that a little bit to queen
dc yeah
but still i mean
i mean knight f1 even what's the problem
i guess right
and maybe that's not even the best move
either way it's quite clear that what is
calling the shots because not only white
has the pawn what has the compensation
for it great position when you look at
this knight on a5 one of the problems in
the opening for black the national a5 is
still there it's not doing anything
probably it's not going to do anytime
soon as well no and the only thing you
can do is move back to b7 an even more
miserable square so tatev she is close
to delivering a critical victory for
team usa and the second player who has
to deliver is karissa yip who is nursing
a big big advantage against tanya
sachdev who's down to eight minutes on
the clock for 14 moves
and carissa
this is huge because at the moment team
usa in the women's section is
cruising towards the victory like at
least i see two victories possible for
team usa and that means
a heartbreaker for the first team of
india because they were leading the
tournament confidently
uh for majority of the uh course they
lost this very not lost but no they did
lose to poland right this very painful
droid rocking game olivia calvassa
against by charlie and now the final
round
they would lose this oh my goodness this
is going to work
this is huge and they might not even
need uh begin to hurt jonova to hold her
own against somebody canero but i think
she might be so it's clear that karissa
is still much better she's going to play
e4 at some point this is a nasty
position so
for india to salvage this match it all
starts with humpy canaro she absolutely
has to win her game but she's now lower
on the clock and it's a wild position
and there's still the standoff between
the queens and i'm not sure that i would
even prefer white here uh artsaurus it's
a super double-edged position i mean why
does still down to pawns that i see
right of course conor is trying to
conjure something at the king side
i think
we might see something along the way of
h6
queen h6 knight g4 rook h3 ids uh but
this is really working you have to call
play that yeah what is this really so
queen
g6 i can maybe play king f7 oh you're
cold you're not even caring about my big
attractor well that bishop's so huge
it's covering the f3 square because
white would kill
uh what white wouldn't give to play the
move rook f3 here but that's not
possible just bishop takes f3
oh my gosh
maybe maybe okay maybe not knight f6 or
maybe not either knight g4 first i start
with rook h3 something like this h6 i'll
play h6
no no no no i play h6 queen h6 then rook
h3 oh oh oh my god now i'm claiming i
have some very big compensation for now
three missing pawns which is exactly
where again
right a looking looking buffering
compensation not found and this pawn on
d3 is a bone is a bone in white's throat
any time you move the rook away d2
becomes a problem 20 minutes and ticking
is humpy's canary humpy canarro's clock
big big problems here for team india
this is shocking archers i mean the
match isn't over uh right now the score
is half half
but
they are in trouble on every board it
appears they are in trouble definitely i
mean they definitely even have a chance
to lose this big it's it's not even just
a lost it's looking just just
bad for people this might be a crusher
you say you're right this this might be
a crusher and that opens up the way for
usa it also opens up the way for uh the
winner of team ukraine and team poland
uh to make a bid at the very least for a
a silver medal we've got poland and
ukraine facing off against each other uh
with a couple of crazy games
in that matchup as well we don't have to
spend too much time on and i want to
come back to the uzbekistan uh
netherlands match as well but we've got
maria malichika against natalia buxa
with a ridiculous tactical position not
sure what to make of this one
no total equal of course i mean what is
it uh
no
he takes c3
pretty balanced position yeah
i mean
pretty balanced yeah yeah i mean
there's bishop f5 maybe
can i do that simplify the position some
car
no foundation but okay
looks normal to me to be honest i mean
i'm scared of this bishop in h7 i'm
scared of queen h4 ideas i mean
ah just queen d4 okay you're very fine
seven
and what is just up above just like that
yeah white is up upon i actually didn't
realize that yeah
i mean i was scared to play knight to
check i mean to be honest 92 i saw some
ghosts by sacrificing the exchange you
need to boom boom
uh queen h4 you know i saw this i
thought ah i just don't want to go there
this is yuck you know but i think
there's nothing yeah there's a squishy
for something you know
yeah
maybe maybe this holds holds together
for black and it's a big game
uh for natalya books and not so it's
important for natalia books and not to
lose this um monika sochko and anna
muzichuk have already made a draw and b
takes c392 track is indeed on the board
so it looks like natalya is up to the
task
and the position
remains incredibly sharp so this match
is totally undecided with complicated
positions on the other two boards of the
ukraine match as well but i propose that
we move back to the open section
if that's okay with you
sure and
first of all uh something that we have
not updated you on in a while is that
sedwani messipiano game from
germany's match against india looks like
olivia dieter
has put together a very very impressive
defensive effort
which is
this is everybody's game now daniel
it's not very clear because what
appeared to be a major win for raunak
after the opening now black is up upon
he has a beautiful monster on d3 and
there's no mate
there's no may and now the knight has
appeared on e6
but the rook has moved into f7 lending
its defensive services to the black king
look at the defensive cocoon
the black has put together around his
game and the king is as safe as it's
been
the entire game
right
can white play a move like queen d5 here
ah but then maybe there's like queen b5
even
i don't know 95 queen b5
probably this is somehow going to
liquidate into some droish
obstacle bishop and game as usually does
you know daniel you play some traces and
of course i mean couple of boom boom
boom it's a dead draw that's how it
works that's always how it works that's
modern chess for you something like
queen d8 queen d7
and then trade trade offer draw and this
is how exactly how the game is gonna go
i mean it always ends in zeros always
right and black is very comfortable with
this bishop on d3 keeping the pawn on c4
alive i could easily see black iman
slider pushing at some point later he
made the queens that's a strong pawn on
c4 right there
and i know you'll second me on this
arthur's but that that the psychological
difficulty
of facing a position like this when
you're basically hoping to win right out
of the opening now all of a sudden the
position is complicated and it almost
feels like black is better even though
objectively he isn't
right yeah of course once you get the
feeling that the game is slipping out of
your hand out of your grasp it's
difficult to gather the thoughts
together you've been there daniel i've
been there you know you feel that it's
not going your way it i think this is
actually what happened exactly yesterday
in gokeshi's game right he had this
absolutely stunning winning position
against of the satoru mining
inaccuracies one after another one after
another you missed a win then you're in
a drawing position but you feel the game
is slipping away
right and you can misplay that i mean
here rahunak definitely should feel that
whatever he did before i mean he could
have played
there yeah no question about it now
kymer and gukesh continues to head
toward a draw it's a dead run rook end
game
um and a game that we haven't checked
out in a while is niholsarin's battle
against matthias blue bomb which seems
to be going uh in nepal's favor knight
has jumped out to b5 and can potentially
move into c7
and
this looks like problems for black queen
c5 there's also b4 it looks like a free
ball to be honest i mean how do you
protect the pawn i mean queen goes away
queen c5 b4 thank you yum yum i'm gonna
take it
oh and actually here
i think there might be even more than
upon i think knight d6 might be totally
devastating
nice
gosh rick takes c1 rook takes f7 check
and then i don't give
a care about that rook i'm gonna go in
for the kill with queen h6
says rook if one king of fawn gives
nothing right there there's no way for
the black queen to join the defenses
right the queen on b6 is safely put away
to defend the king so to speak
for black zippo zilch yeah and uh if you
don't play queen v6 well where do you go
that only leaves you with one square the
miserable miserable square on f eight
this is like this is not gonna happen
guys this is not how you equalize the
game you put the queen on the face
that is terrible
oh look at that stare that niho sarin is
giving his opponent
he has one of the greatest stares to be
honest you know
like gary kasparov just looks this crazy
stare towards you you know
a lot of intimidation right there
this is why i like
watching nihal's game so much i mean he
takes a position that looks pretty
colorless
you think it's going to be a 70 move
grind and then five moves later he's
already winning the center pawn and he's
converted it into a position where he
has a huge attack incredible and big big
trouble here for matias blue bomb the
german i find actually dania i find it
quite interesting that there's quite a
few games with icelandic uh pawn
structure i think we saw this in uh
wesley saw's game against uh with it
right here we again have the same
structure so it seems to be like a
common understanding that black is sort
of holding i mean i think some time
before it was
i mean at least a conventional
understanding was that iceland reported
e5 black is suffering but uh you know
engines are not really impressed and uh
they're not impressed right not at all
it's nothing it's nothing i mean who
cares about isolate pawn on d5 engines
definitely don't
yeah no that's totally i actually have
observed the same thing engines always
give equality in a situation where even
if you control the square in front of
the pawn which is supposed to be you
know the dream of playing against an iqp
oftentimes you just see zeros
by the engine because the side that has
the iqp often has that additional peace
activity
uh that can compensate for the weakness
of the pawn but this is not exactly a
uh you know a worthy advertisement for
playing with the iqp and nihal sarin
will continue
to try to convert what is about to be
his first material advantage of the game
uh in the meantime we have that armenia
spain match which is continuing to heat
up let's quickly check into the sure-off
game
yeah this is
wow okay this is totally over i mean
black is down in exchange i think he did
play queen h3 before
i just suggested so he self-trapped the
queen some total brain meltdown happened
for the top spanish board and now it's
just an exchange technical position if
the king gets to d3 very quickly to
protect the pawn on e3 this is curtains
bishop c5 just play rook d3 the is
restricted completely by the pawns and
one minute for alexi for
16 moves nah this is over
i think that's the cause
right i mean this is a morning round you
definitely gotta feel that because uh
again to remind you the viewers the
their last rounds start at 10 a.m
uh in local time in chennai india right
it's it's tough it's tough to play the
morning rod your brain is still sleeping
you start to see things which are not
even there and this is apparently what
happened to the sheriff's game
no chess players hate the morning rounds
have you ever overslept around
at a tournament oh no i have missed the
round but for a different reason though
not oversleeping no
have you
i have well i uh taught at a chess camp
i teach at a chess camp in atlanta every
year and there's a tournament after the
camp now the camp is grueling it's you
teach all day every day so the last
night the tournament starts the day
after camp ends it's about 7 p.m and at
7 30 p.m i totally crash i i'm exhausted
and of course i don't set an alarm it's
7 30 p.m the game is the following
morning at 10.
yes when i wake up
9 55. i look at my which i'm like oh
it's 9 55 p.m then i look outside it's
light outside i'm like oh my goodness
the game starts in five minutes it's
like a game in 45. throw clothes on rush
to the playing hall and it was just a
miracle that uh i slept 14 hours
uh so it actually happened that was the
closest i ever came believe it or not
all right how do you play the game
uh i won i won it was round one so i was
uh i outraged my opponent but i was
falling asleep at the board it was
terrible sometimes when you sleep that
amount it's actually counterproductive
you sleep you feel even more sleepy than
if you had slept like 9 or 10 hours
right right well there's that definitely
so either way sheriff is going down in
this game major result for our team
armenia sergician is becoming a true
leader i mean um we always thought he is
a very very solid player uh but not like
uh the top elite still what he's doing
here in the last five rounds four and a
half out of five against the absolute
top-notch players is just
just incredible i i don't even have the
word right words in my vocabulary for
that
yeah it's it's it's incredible he's very
underrated he's been around 2700 for so
many years and he is about to deliver a
huge win
for team
armenia okay back we go for a second
perhaps to the um
to the uzbekistan match that anish geary
game might actually be the match
deciding game
because this end game
this end game in which notre back
abductor of
seemed to hold the only one
the evil bar
believes otherwise wait how did they not
win the pawn on f4 again yeah that's
what i'm wondering too
rook g1 rook b6
king c2 rook c4
oh i think he missed a tactic here i
think he had to move rook f5
which he should have played
okay this is how you win the pawn either
you see this move or you don't i mean
rookie five can escape your vision right
because obviously the square is under
attack but the rook and g1 conveniently
pins the black king
can be missed it can be missed right i
mean i also wouldn't spot it on
immediately yeah
neither would i and there are two types
of people those who see rock five and
those who don't yeah i'm also one of
them i guess yeah in the second part
but here the pawn cannot be defended
even if you go g5 it doesn't actually
help because of the pin so this would
have given white excellent winning
chances
instead notre back
moves his rook from g1 to e1 and wait
the rook was there before no i mean the
rook was yeah
it was it was he just wasted to tempe
just like that he played rook g1 rookie
one there you go
he got discouraged he didn't see a way
to win the pawn and he moves his rook
back but he got discouraged prematurely
and that's why he played rookie one he's
trying to force a trade of rooks and his
gary says okay fine
bishop h4 g5 and now it's completely
anybody's game i mean this is a three
result game i think totally i mean i
don't think it's uh even droish because
black wants to play f3 g4 maybe at some
point even stack the bishop on f to push
forward those pawns while white
obviously is trying to push c5 b4 a4 b5
it's a race i mean
i don't want to be in that those
situations daniel usually i pray i never
get there because it it really feels
like uh
flopping a coin
oh totally these end games are
impossible to calculate how do you know
do you go c5 first you go b4 if you're
black do you go king f5 do you go f3
there's like usually three or four
candidate moves on every move and it is
simply impossible to calculate these
types of end games accurately so you
basically end up trusting your intuition
both sides have plenty of time this has
already moved 37 uh so they're about to
make time control and notre beck
without further ado
he sets his own pawns in motion we are
in for a fascinating endgame here with
all three results possible
oh
yeah and uh this is gonna be a drama i
think because
um they they desperately need this
victories so if uh again if team armenia
doesn't win and if team uzbekistan
doesn't win
oh my goodness danya i mean this is wide
open i mean there's
like i don't know how many candidates
take the gold i mean we might actually
see a huge tie for the first place and
then just
whatever happens happens
now i think there will be a result very
shortly in the jordan run forest notre
back echo boy of games so that exchange
sacrifice it turned out to be a money
move
because
as we discussed it's your fault archers
you put this into jordan's mind he
played the move b3 and knight e5 found
immediately immediately by the use
background master rook d4 knight f3 and
jordan was uh forced basically to
liquidate uh into an end game where i
actually think he is the one who had to
exercise caution
and he did exercise caution he wins the
pawn on d5 notre back or uh yeah oh yeah
notre back
wait
okay i was like
yes exactly good i'm not hallucinating
and i think that we are about to see a
repetition of moves king e6 rook g4 no
need for black
well actually black could maybe consider
going rook g8 here what do you think or
is this just a dead
the pawn on h6 is under attack but so is
the white pawn on f2 maybe this is just
gonna liquidate you know
rook g8 bishop h6 uh bishop f2 h5 trade
many things on g6 black has this pawn on
b5 extra pawn but
it it's of no use really so oh wait you
also
f5
yeah that's actually a problem you know
it could happen like this danny will
bring this situation before it's like
okay i mean let's make a draw okay i
agree to a draw i apply kingdom five and
boom you miss rookie four i've been
there i've done that totally happens
right you you go at this from a distance
and you think oh we just liquidate on g6
and then you fail to check for these
these other tactical resources so my
guess
is that uh notre back will
will uh cooler heads will prevail and we
will see a repetition and a draw
and on the last board we have this crazy
game between maxwell madame and vaqira
which continues
uh to go downhill for max
wow the bottom beater is missing i guess
at some point black did snatch spot on
b2 for free positioned it on c3
yeah
and supported it with a pawn and here's
the problem bishop f4 looked very
tempting but there's this move e5
beautiful yeah that's a mood killer
pretty much i mean e5 is the movie you
don't want to get because d x is queen d
one background kisha's the rook on d1 is
not protected and if you have to play
bishop g3 well your pieces are never
gonna come back to life and even maybe
uh f5 f4 you're showing daniel there is
just costing quite a piece not good
choice for white but what do right
f6
i guess you have to go bishop h4 then
but black can actually still go e5 like
this that's actually a valid point very
annoying
very annoying because now this bishop
and h4 is disconnected from action so is
the knight of three
it's just bad i think it's just bad for
whites right because suddenly there's no
counter play and i think white was
hoping for some counterplay that king
said and now these pawns on f6 and e5
they secure everything e5 is a major
resource
this is a major resource i mean uh i
think black should already
uh have it under keys radar
yeah this is black looks
boring
i think this is borderline winning and
uh it does appear that karissa yip is on
the path to delivering checkmate we will
go to her game in just a second uh
before we do we have sindarov against
benjamin block they are locked in a very
very complex position not much to say
here i like white's position but i know
people in chat are going crazy we need
to go to the carissa game right now
is there checkmate in that game
let's see or was that fake
news um
[Music]
it definitely feels something
checkmatish you know uh having the open
g file
queen on h4 queen f2 i think this game
is going to be over pretty quick to be
honest but wait i don't i don't see the
psac though and then what exactly where
exactly is the mate
queen h4 actually is queen bee too
annoying annoying idea wait can we
continue this like maybe to king h7 and
i thought i'm very proud to discovered
rook takes on c5 exchange sacrifice and
of course that i missed
[Music]
but one second i think white has the
move queen takes d6 here this might also
be quite annoying
oh so you're saying there's no mate
because queen of two kings to queen f1
white delivers a shocker on h6 a mate
checkmate of her oh no not like that but
a checkmate of her own on h6
and uh i don't actually see exactly how
carissa delivers the crushing blow now
she's got 30 minutes to figure it out
and tanya with two minutes for 10 moves
if she pulls out this game with white
that would be unbelievable that is
highly unlikely so i would still say
that the white is still
doing great but the way rook takes on c5
also is a threat not to be missed right
because the queen on f6 is currently
pinned so you're going to play dx on c5
so so that is a threat which asks me a
question why rook takes on c5 was not
possible immediately
i guess there was some kind of a check
on a1 or something i'm not sure by the
way check on a1 i go king h2 and maybe
queen e1
wow that's deep
no wait that lit oh that blunders queen
b2 that blunders queen b2 and roxy and
bishop d3 so that's what i'm not sure
why this rook c5 was not possible i mean
maybe something like queen g6 or queen
g7 oh queen g7 beautiful and it
threatens checkmate and it covers the h6
square
that's the line
yeah maybe even without the check on a1
i was thinking like queen g6 or queen g7
right away but either way yeah it didn't
work it didn't work
okay so i just wanted to make sure that
this game was not imminently over now
that i have assured myself of that we
can move on to
uh back to the to the open section
um
okay so
yeah so did you have any thoughts on the
uh sindara bach game before we go on
another break
um yeah let's maybe check it this is
what was started as a quiet italian game
and we discussed how we don't really
like italian game i think we share the
same feeling there
uh but suddenly hawaii's position seems
to be preferable because um
there's some targets at the queensland
however the pawn on e4 is weak
so i wonder if why the double the rooks
that they filed with the idea to
sacrifice the exchange in f6 i'm not
sure really i mean is it is that the
idea nice i think it might be van forest
by the way signing his score sheet uh he
makes the first
draw
as we were discussing but after knight
g5 yeah i think rook takes f6 is
definitely in the cards
i i actually think that is his idea and
then you know and then you go h4
yeah the grand petrossian the former
world champion would definitely approve
he is of course historically wise widely
regarded as one of the greatest players
ever to make make some of the most
beautiful exchange sacrifices we've seen
quite a few of them here in the olympiad
so far many of them by the way by niche
geary so it's fun to watch yeah nish uh
continues to sharpen his playing style
as benjamin bach shifts his knight from
f6 to d7 clearly worried about that
exchange sacrifice he's got seven
minutes on his clock for 15 moves
netherlands is in trouble they're in
trouble on this board they're in trouble
on the last board with max warmer dom in
a really bad situation and uh aneesh
geary is the netherlands main hope he's
going to have to try to pull out a win
out of that end game against notre dame
will any of that happen who will take
gold today
the climax is beginning to be approached
as as the netherlands tries to stop team
uzbekistan's cinderella run and spain
trying to do the same to team armenia
and we will continue to monitor this
fascinating final round of the 44th
chess olympia and we'll be back with
more olympiad action in just a couple of
moments stay tuned
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Applause]
back we are at the 44th feed a chess
olympiad and a beautiful wide-angle view
of that playing hall the reviews
from the tournament have been excellent
the organization up to the highest
standards the playing conditions
excellent as well and the games the
games have left nothing to be desired
and uh final round included we are three
hours and counting into this pivotal
final round
of the chess olympia daniel meredith
arthur's naked sons bringing you the
coverage of this all-important final
round we start in the india versus us
match and bad news for fans of team usa
it appears that lenie dominguez is about
to lose his game against our generic ic
yeah that looks incredibly
nice domination from the wise
perspective although we have a material
balance on the board you you got to see
that white he's controlling more space
his pawns on c5 and d6
are very close the queen
so i don't even know what black's
supposed to do here king d8 you need to
watch out for ideas like c6 knight c6
not b6 everything just starts fly
towards the black king
i mean this looks just yeah like you
said daniel just
yeah it's over
it's over it's this is not even chloe i
mean linear
zero counter play on the king side he's
hasn't managed to produce anything and
ordinary guys see archers i don't know
how much you've seen his games
uh but but he is just he is something
else
so defeat lanier like this on demand
making him seem like he doesn't
understand the positions is is crazy
yeah he's one of the super talents one
of the super talents coming out of the
indian chess which guys produce so many
of them right it's not ordinary guys
here not only kim of course it's the
mirage gupta
it's pragananda it's ronix advani and
there's there's like huge list of the
currently i mean already elite players
and more players are coming that we
simply don't even know about yet right
so here
definitely um arjun is going to be a
high level top level player in the next
few years for sure if he's not already
with fabby's game having ended in a draw
early that basically means that sam
shankland
is going to have to squeeze something
out of a better end game against
narayanan and this actually starts to
look pretty promising for sam
if he's trying to go for redemption
after that devastating loss that he
suffered at the hands of robert
hovanissan this will be the way
to do it does he have serious wedding
chances in the sand game i think the
answer is yes
so the very big question is do we take
on d4 or not because if it does allow
black to create two past pawns in the
center and the queen side but it also
opens way for white spawns at a king
side so i'm thinking exactly as you're
saying there f4 e5 next so rook d4 i
want to do it i really want to do it
because those queens and pawns for black
are not doing anything if i get to play
like you're showing there keen d3 f4 e5
i like white johnson this looks pretty
juicy but sam going for a different
approach he went knight c4 to e3
potentially aiming for the f5 score just
kind of keeping the status quo we have a
trade of rooks and a check on d6 three
moves away from time control so time
pressure is not going to play a role
this game
um
and sam sort of keeps the pawn structure
as it currently is that doesn't mean he
abandons hopes of playing f4 i mean this
still
is a is a serious idea that black will
have to reckon with if he moves his
knight away from g6
right and also 95 i think is an issue at
some point and black will have to
reposition the rook to the pass of e6
square so my best guess black has to
play 97 and it's on the board right it
is on the board and that
tosses the ball back into sam shanklin's
court will he play f4 will he kind of
nurse his advantage until move 40 and
then decide on the most appropriate
moment to play the move f4 right and
again that's what distinguishes really
great players uh to
just good players because they feel this
moment right daniel i mean when do you
have to go for this because again i i
felt that i want to take rootcase on d4
establish the spawn majority kingside
because i see the team is not doing
really so well i have to step up but i
mean they just feel it right okay maybe
this is not the right time to do it
because you don't want to make very big
decisions right at the end of the first
time control this is ready
you want to get more time then you have
more time to think about it
and at the same time you don't want to
procrastinate too much because your
opponent could then prevent you from
playing the moves you wanted to make so
a move like g7 g5 needs to be seriously
evaluated by white now of course that
creates a gaping hole on f5 so
i don't think sam is particularly afraid
of that move happening but nonetheless
he's going to have to find the most
appropriate moment to try to make
progress and in the other game
we have wesley so
and wesley
with
obviously no risk and advantage and he's
about to win a pawn
so that's a pawn right there on d5 which
is impossible defend
and in fact it can be captured it's way
to move wait but is it gonna trans is
there a chance daniel for this again to
reach an end game with uh both people
and somehow getting traded and what has
a d4 pawn
i think that would be the ideal scenario
for black but i don't see a way for
black to actually get to white's b-pawn
that's a good point yeah i was thinking
f6 bishop f7 but then i saw knight on b4
obviously is an issue right there's
conveniently the second pawn at some at
some point under attack so if you play
b3
after f6 or before f6
i'm not sure at some point i guess we're
going to have to play b3 because the
pawn on b4 is simply under attack
well i guess white's going to drop the
knight back to e3 to prevent your knight
from jumping into c4
so for example even i can play it maybe
here
wesley might just as well do it so team
usa right now is on the verge to become
uh trailing the kind of match because
lanier dominguez is losing but here
wesley so and samuel shanklin could
still pull off a victory for team usa
absolutely both of them have uh you know
sizable winning chances and uh they're
both gonna have to deliver they're both
gonna have to win their game if the us
is to have any chance
of uh of meddling today
okay so we will keep a very close eye as
sam and uh wesley try to nurse and
nurture and expand their endgame
advantages
okay what do you say um
netherlands or netherlands uzbekistan or
armenia germany what
where do you want to start first this
time you choose daniel i mean i've been
choosing quite a few times before i
agree i agree um
i i love making decisions as you know
let's let's do a little compromise let's
quickly go through the yeah let's start
with the uh india
uh germany games
and then we'll move to the uzbekistan
match because this match we haven't
looked at in a while and this game
between round x and honey and isipiano
both of the players have under seven
minutes for 14 moves until time control
in a position this complicated can you
believe that
right i know
i i feel definitely the potential for
black to take over the game because uh
if black is again
simplifying the position uh somehow
training trending of the queens and put
the bishop on f6
i mean this is just two bishops and a
past pawn because suddenly you start to
see white has those three pawns against
two for black and the king side they
don't matter at all on all black has
this past pawn so i can easily see nisi
piano taking over the game and i'm
wondering if uh
sadwani is keeping the queens on the
board with that he has to sacrifice the
exchange on d3 and somehow trying to
bother the black king with some queenie
for czech ideas as soon as it goes to h7
ah so maybe even the immediate sacrifice
should deserves attention but nah
probably not
because if you check me here and then
you check me back on e4 black always
says the move g6 but i agree that
the
the general idea of the exchange
sacrifice exists
right
but roundax seems to have been losing
the threat for a large portion of the
game and the time situation has
officially equalized as round knight
drops now to below five minutes so this
is a big game and if nisipiano can turn
this around and even win it then that
gives germany every shot at at the very
least tying the match if
uh nihal saren can convert that extra
pawn against matthias blue bomb
right good cash against camera because
they're still playing but it's a dead
draw yeah it's a dead draw all right
they're still playing with the dread
draft petrossian and anton guiharro have
officially drawn their game that's in
the armenia spain match
and let's take a look at some of the
uzbekistan games back we go to the top
board
with notre beck abdusatorav and anish
geary having just made the time control
what do we make of this is this just
going to peter out into a draw
i think it is
i think it very likely is
so rook takes only one i think it's
quite important to note you can't take
with the night right so you would love
to take for the knight then snatch the
pawn on f3 after rookie 1 91 is oopsie
moment f2 c daisy f2 and the pawn cannot
be stopped or you have to give up the
knight
right so you have to take with the king
and then you play bishop g3 get the king
to king e6 king d5 and like you said uh
without the king white cannot push for
those queen side pawns they don't have
the support and black is also not
threatening to win this game so
yeah
knight knight is going to get to the
pawn in f3 some con then we shake hands
and happily go home
yeah looks like a pretty balanced game i
mean this was always double-edged
abductor off had that brief chance to
win gary's pawn
and a win in this game would have
basically clinched the match for
uzbekistan uh but a draw is not a bad
result either given the situation on the
uh the other two boards starting with
the warmer dom game which is now
transitioned into an end game
where black is up
him three pawns
three
it should be enough it has to be a win
for one this should be enough i mean
okay i can misplay one extra pawn two
extra pawns but three
three has got to be enough so i mean the
usual strategy here is to drop one pawn
and uh simplify the position so rook e6
if you gain one point back two more are
to go this simply is going to be too
much for white to handle
now we might recall that vaquita did
have that crazy game against sam
shanklin where he failed to win a
winning rook end game but i would argue
that this is a much easier conversion
because there you had to be precise
there was no material advantage here
all you really have to do
is get your knight around to c3
and uh the rest the position basically
plays itself would you agree with that
yeah absolutely so if the nand gets to
c3 that might be just lights out for
white and this would also mean that the
score could be
uh if the other game is drawn to one of
who is the fourth port in the team in
netherlands against um uzbekistan
the fourth board and the final board is
the sendarov bulk game
which does seem to be heading toward
perhaps a draw i don't think sindarov is
really risking here
and if he sees that uh if he sees that
vaquita has clinched the victory then he
might even offer a draw no i don't know
right again he'll feel pressed to
continue
that's that's how it goes
yeah i think this is uh
i think this is just this is just a
clincher for us pakistan because
uh abdusto torov is not going to lose
the game we know that
he's he's not risking it all
so that's a draw this game i cannot
possibly imagine benjamin bach winning
and
i cannot possibly imagine max warmer
dumb drawing on board four
right it looks like that and also yeah
it reminds me you know daniel reminds me
yesterday's story when second team of
india was cruising for a three month
victor over uzbekistan and gukesh was
winning and prague was i guess winning
and i think it was like they're like
staring at each other at some point i
mean who's going to do it who is going
to do it right and uh so that i can
secure the master of victory and i think
that gukesh just was not sure that uh
prague is gonna win and that's why he
then overpressed and i think we might
see something i'm not saying the same
scenario but you are looking towards
your teammates you're trying to gather
information i think also sindarov maybe
is let's look at his game he's trying to
figure out what do i need to do in this
game i mean do i need to press it for
the victory probably it's going to be
difficult thing to do do i need to play
for the draw i think right now he should
already have some ideas that but the
thing is
our armenia is very likely to win their
match because petrossian and tongiharo
is a draw santos latassa against hoffa
nissan is a draw
um we know that sargeant amazingly alexi
shrove is still playing but uh but it's
still completely winning for white
um if armenia wins and uzbekistan draws
does armenia get gold medal
yeah they uh they do get uh because they
have the same amount match points 17
after around 10. so whoever wins the
other team draws this means
automatically the winner team is getting
gold medals however if they get the same
amount of points
i think it's pretty sure that uzbekistan
is going to be higher because they have
scored bigger victories in the previous
thrones they have swept away their
opposition after round playing around
indicate the greater tie breaks it's a
bit more complicated than just a small
uh small points but they are doing it
better
yeah so for
team netherlands their only chance might
actually be benjamin bach trying to win
this position are there any chances
that this turns around in black's favor
because i am looking at white's
incredibly weak pawns on the e file
black already has
a pawn for the exchange i've seen
crazier things happen
you know what then i'll look at at this
from a different perspective i mean
imagine yourself you you look at the
team match and you see you need to make
a draw i have a simple question how do
you liquidate this into a draw
it's not easy i don't see a direct way
to do it yeah that's the point right
because i mean when you feel that
you are maybe slightly better but you
need to make a draw you look for the
simple way to make a draw i don't see a
simple way to make a draw here because
if i sacrifice the exchange in f6 and
maybe trade off that point on b2 for the
pawn on a5 you're still down a pawn and
this is not where you want to go
no i i agree completely and what i will
say
is that i was considering the move rook
a7
uh just going after the a5 pawn and you
could get a very unbalanced type of
position takes
takes takes
and this is anybody's game i mean black
has a big big pawn majority
uh in the center and rook k7 by the way
is on the board
it is on the board wow we'll get this
kind of position
no wait this is this is no longer indeed
a controlled game this can easily turn
either way the line you show daniel rook
e3 k5 for key four
of course both sides have the trumps
white he has an outside passport at the
b file the best practices say that you
want to put the rook behind the pawn
push forward a b pawn oh wait this is
the idea a rook c2 he's going for the
activity and he wants to double on the
seventh rank
oh that actually is a lot scarier
that's a phenomenal idea by centaurov
and benjamin has a minute to make his
40th move
or maybe rook city check and play rook
f7 also he's in the car also also very
much in the cards yeah winning that pawn
and then maybe re-doubling on the
seventh rank
yeah i think this is the key to the
kingdom
i think this is the key to the kingdom
all right that being said probably
uh black is not gonna get that pawn uh
storm and then wait what happens after
knight e4 so you can't really play rook
c7 i'm gonna give you a check on e1 and
play rook f1
right
that's a cool defensive idea so i guess
here i have to give you a check on c8
right
and now either you can have seven or
double the rooks i don't know what
should i take on f7
all right
i think yeah i think white's gonna do
this because here i i find it very hard
to believe that black is going to win
the game are you sure i'm not so sure
because imagine yourself i'm going to
drop the pawn on g7 i'm thinking about
something like king g6 rook uh c to c7
and let's say
and
by the way before we go any further in
this game we have a result we see the
handshake we see anishgiri and no
rebecca dusatara of exchanging smiles
that result is official
all right exchanging smiles exchanging
uh point in halfs uh
that was to be expected but if you go
back to this position i was thinking
something like i'm gonna drop the pawn
on g7 i mean maybe it's a double-edged
decision if i play something like knight
f6 rook g7 k5
maybe maybe it's not much you know but i
have a feeling
that if those uh central pawns are going
to match forward this could be at some
point dangerous for white of course i
mean the bar is laughing at me as usual
i'm used to that already but i i can see
the potential of these bones
yeah aren't we all no i i agree i mean
all benjamin buck can try to do
is get some sort of an unbalanced
position even if he's losing a a draw is
basically equivalent to a loss for the
netherlands because
uh checking in on the max warmer dumb
game it's over i think warmer dawn is
just going to resign
within a couple of moments here
i mean just like oh yeah he's losing
another pawn
it's minus seven
this is a game to forget rook hv also is
a problem knight g3 rook g3 is a problem
some final loss cheap tricks i mean
maybe get the king on g5 king h6 try to
scare the opponent of a checkmate which
is of course
not gonna happen
yeah but a loss of the white pieces is
is is
against uzbekistan is
the worst thing that you can possibly
allow and despite some pretty impressive
opening preparation
um the dutch grand master just failing
to uh
to keep up the pressure and allowing
vaquitav to get active and win a bunch
of his pawns
yeah
pretty official daniel that uzbekistan
secures a medal
at least
yes because they've basically secured at
least a draw in this match with a win by
vaquita but let's not let's not shovel
dirt on max warmer dom just yet because
again
i have seen crazier things happen and
that last move knight g7
uh archers might have been an inaccuracy
all right
so what do we what do we continue from
here
so if black takes on g3 with check what
concerns me slightly about vaquitav's
position is some sort of
crazy attack
which might lead to a perpetual like if
you go back to a3 i start checking you
and already i'm not sure that this is so
easy to win
yeah king of six fights runs into a
conveniently a mate
boom
yes so you can try to zigzag your way
out of it to be fair king e5 that's your
idea that is my idea king e5 knight e6
king f6 i'm not even sure that that
threatens anything but it's scary
it's absolutely scary i think oh wait
it's it looks incredibly scary because
uh with the knight on e6 king on f6 you
have some direct frontal checkmate ideas
like rookie seven okay here the knight
on five conveniently defends the
defender e7 square but maybe there's
definitely a scenario like this i like
that
i feel like
that move knight g7 that might have been
inaccurate and you can see that this is
giving vaquitav some pause
he's taking his time
and he's got plenty of it four minutes
for two moves
but
it's not quite over just yet maybe wax
warmer damn clinging to a little glimmer
of hope
do you think vaquitav is feeling nervous
right now or
do you think that might play a role in
this end game he knows
the fate of his country is in his hands
right now assuming he is a human being
he's a monster okay but i i think he's
got to be slightly nervous you know i
would be just uh sweating there to be
honest uh feelings
such pressure i mean it's not just a
game you're not playing for yourself
you're playing for your entire team
you're playing for the entire country
while we talk about that i hear there's
a major development in roanoke's
advantage game do we jump to that there
is a massive time scramble with eight
moves to be made for in a minute for
both players but it looks like uh the
german grand master has started to lose
the threat of the game this is the
position on the board currently
i have no clue what's going on i am
still trying to wrap my
brain
around what tank has a better cluster
right
yeah there's there's like a lot of
things in the center and uh whatever
happened in the last couple of months
you can't help but feel that things went
wrong for black despite his heroic
efforts right after the opening when he
was almost busted right at the gate here
suddenly white managed to activate his
pieces and get a second chance back of
the game oh and it looks like rook takes
f5 is the crushing move
g takes f5 and bishop e5 i think ends
the game oh is it crushing queen g6
rogue g3 oh wait he's a queen trap no
queen
queen h5 knight f4 what a beautiful idea
is literally dominated look at this
position
look at this position this is that's
beautiful and bishop g5 i guess the
bishop is trapped somehow f4h4 the
bishop is gone well at a minimum i can
play uh knight five and rook g5 this has
to be totally winning
i mean
queen f7 queen e6
that's beautiful yeah the rook on c8 is
also under attack and this seals the
deal for white
let's see if round x eduani with one
minute remaining on his clock can find
rook he takes f5 no he does not but he
finds a different crushing move bishop
h4
wow on what's the idea queen h4 is it
the knight
g5
but after knight g5 bishop takes g5 i
saw that idea i had a hard time figuring
out the crusher there
i guess we're about to find out queen
takes h4 is gonna happen
you have to because g5 rookie 5 is
killing and queen goes away you still
get the knight g5 so roanoke definitely
has seen already the winning idea of
knight g5 check the rook and f7 is under
attack and maybe you know maybe page 4
is just good but sometimes i know this
from my personal experience you see one
idea in time scramble you simply don't
have time for anything else you get
fixated on one idea and everything else
is just
not visible but this page looks good
queen takes h4 no he plays
okay no he he played uh
bishop takes c6 rook takes c6 and queen
takes f3 giving up an entire queen
and this has got to be
oh and actually even queen takes f3
might be the most clinical move for
roanoke
wow
don't even take with the pawn
this is nice because gene x and f3
clearly uh
black's idea has to play with page four
build up some kind of a fortress and
there is a chance to do that i can feel
that queen of three lovely rook three
seven
and that's it yeah like why why bother
with the past pawn on c3 i think gf3 and
queen e4 might also be winning
but in the interest of uh playing in
time pressure i think queen takes f3
will lead to immediate resignation
because at the end of the line the white
rook is able to stop the pawn from c1
and ronaldo taking his time very patient
it's amazing raj he's still so young
right and
you know doesn't even feel that this is
such a critical moment for him i mean
huge pressure he's very cool calculating
the lines i mean it's
great to see
it's incredible and he didn't playing g
takes f3 a little bit surprising but if
he follows it up accurately then all's
well that ends well for ronak i think
queen e4 is what he is banking on for
king the pawn on g6 and the bishop on h4
and the beautiful detail is that bishop
takes f6 runs into rook takes f6
followed by queen e7 checkpicking of the
rook
nice
so what is that yeah it's winning of
course i mean i was still trying to rely
on my c pawn but of course it's not
going anywhere
right right of course it's easily
winning
so queen e4
i think this is actually what's going to
happen bishop f6 it's easy to miss rook
of 6 27 in time scramble
and with gucash drawing his game against
kymer it's still going but
i would imagine that that game must end
in a draw although we'll check into it
in a second
how saren can only win his game
against uh blue bomb but it doesn't
matter because uh rasmus spain and
pragnanda have a dead draw that means
india too is going to win their match
assuming that nothing crazy happens here
right and that means also a great news
for the indian fans if indeed india 2 is
going to do it because if india 2 wins
this this again means
almost like
automatic uh
medals right because they were in the
third place with a great tie break
so winning this match they should at
least secure a bronze that's according
to my calculations but of course i don't
want to jinx it and it's been the
narrative all olympiad long the fact
that india two might actually be a
stronger team than india one stronger
not in the pure chess sense obviously
but in the sense of how hungry they are
and how on form they are and they have
displayed
absolutely incredible performances all
around as india too
and the youngsters on that team deliver
yet again rookie one rook c1 i think
just ends it
there was a piece sacrifice by the way
so clearly uh
nisi piano understood that things are
bad that he sacrificed bishop on h4 now
his idea is play c3 c2 rook d7 and rogue
d1 which probably doesn't hold
because rookie one rook c1 queen of four
i protect my rook on c1 and then it's
gonna be just
a slow technique
yeah and again i i think taking on f
through the queen
was a lot more efficient
but
this is perfectly good enough i'm pretty
sure
right so the one is gonna do it i think
he's not gonna miss it
so do we go gesh's game check how
drawing his position actually is yeah i
mean that guy it's crazy that that game
is still going
and they continue to sort of repeat
moves i think kymer is the one who is
trying to
press
amazingly but i don't think that he's
going to be able to come up with
anything here maybe maybe his coach has
prohibited him to make drawings right
whatever you must keep the game going
yeah he's coached by peter lecko of
course one of the uh former world's best
players and maybe that's the goal right
the vincent don't come back before
playing until move 60.
that's what he's doing here
exactly
huh
um
so if you go
king f6 here which looks very tempting
indeed
the problem i think is that black
returns to d7
and
black is okay giving up one of those
pawns as long as his king can get the f7
square
so king d6 by the way is played yeah
that also looked my v6 choice so black
is definitely up a pawn but i don't
really think it's so important because
those are double pawns
vincent is pressing here i mean despite
the fact it was quite drawish
there are some problems i mean i'm
thinking like king c6 rook b3 rook a d6
d7 i can easily see this being misplayed
amazing that vincent has produced these
kinds of chances given
the end game that they started with so
how exactly should black draw this in
the most clinical way is it even
possible to force a draw here
can i imagine if gooch loses this game
no that would be total nightmare of
course
can i play something like i mean g4
rookie four maybe it's too much because
it drops the pawn on a7 can i play rook
up seven
rook f7 here yeah yeah that looks pretty
good not spoiling again
c6
i know
wait what this is tricky right rook f6
is no good d6
yeah 66 oh my god and i'm already
playing d6 on the next move now i would
totally ignore the evil bar here the
evil bar is going to give equal
everywhere obviously it's still a draw
but we're trying to figure out how white
can cause the most amount of practical
problems to black and it's clear that
here black is already encountering
tremendous practical problems oh i think
i understand what black should do here
maybe king d8
and if d6 i think you go
oh no no you don't go g4 because right
b3
yeah it's easy to misplay i saw your
idea rook f1 rook c1 you wanted to give
some checks right
i wanted the philidor method but you
can't do it like that you probably have
to go
rook f4
not an easy move to make by the way
rook a7 rook c4 king d5 and then you
play
rook c3
f4 because of king e6 yeah some
technique is required here
incredible and goo cash is
50 minutes on his clock so
he should take his time he should be
patient but
sometimes when you're frustrated with
yourself to begin with
it can be hard to keep your composure he
plays king d8 very quickly
ah he just wants to give the side checks
or d7 or q7 is that what we're looking
at
no
but that looks pretty good it might be
the most accurate actually all right
in any case
what should we check out should we look
at uh
whether vaquita has managed to convert
that end game against warmer dam yeah
let's do that looks a good choice and
then maybe we can check into the usa
india match on the women's side
what do you make of this it's a two pawn
advantage on the king side
but it certainly doesn't look that easy
to me
well i start to think you're right
daniel because uh you said let's not
jump the gun right then
not completely right off warmer dam's
chances
it's getting tricky because white has
pretty active pieces despite the fact
that black has two connected past pawns
at the king side we see rook a8 rook a7
check threats
um the king is very close to in case the
black rook disappears from e3 king e5
king of six i can easily see this
misplaying and also let's not completely
write down that possibility at some
point white might actually sacrifice
tonight for those two king side pawns
and maybe just maybe that is some kind
of drawing i was thinking that as well
imagine how nervous the team captain
ivan sokolov is right now because
a draw in this game would be a disaster
especially if benjamin buck that
basically will mean that benjamin uh
would be okay with the draw himself in
terms of spoiling uzbekistan chances for
gold so
he must be thinking about that game
against shankland that must be spinning
around in his mind
and uh when you when you botch a game
like that it always interferes with your
ability to
win subsequent winning positions
yeah definitely so converting material
advantage is uh something that even the
best players in the world
uh from time to time fail it's very
tricky
dominguez has officially lost so
arjunara guyse
scoring a victory
for team india
and putting the ball into sam shankland
and wesley so's court they will have to
deliver for team usa we also have word
that norway has officially lost
to the philippines what a disastrous
performance and magnus was not playing
today but what on earth uh what happened
to team norway they were third seeded
and they lost
so many matches the moldova to the
philippines um
that was the last
feroda orchid all losing his game
against ironberry samina and three draws
christensen john ludwig hammer and
orientary none of them could surmount
their much lower rated opposition a
hearty congratulations to team
philippines
for finishing strong and speaking of
finishing strong
let's go back to the uh us women's team
and it looks like carissa yip is about
to deliver a huge win against tanya
sachdev this looks totally crushing that
is totally over the white king is
exposed it's not even about those pawns
i think there's going to be a decisive
checkmate threat incoming gtx and f3
queen h3 um or queen f3 queen and the
rook are very powerful combination to
haunted white king so
pretty safe that's what oh my god
and a huge huge result to her jonova has
held a draw against hampi canaro and
that's wow
in that position
and this is the position of tatev
abrahamian against cool kearney tatev is
not losing this i mean this is totally
winning as well he's like winning in
couple of moves and this means team usa
the woman see them taking down the
leaders india and that means there's no
gold medal for woman teen india team
what a heartbreaker for the local heroes
but unfortunately that's how it looks
like maybe for team usa this is a chance
to get the medal because i think
actually daniel if they win team india
they actually surpassed them in the
rankings i'm not totally sure about that
but
that's what it looks like
an unbelievable match here
and what that that means is that team
ukraine is knocking on the door of a
gold medal natalia buxa drawing her game
against malichika monika sochiko and
anamusi chook drawing maria music has
defeated alina kashlinskaya and that
leaves the final game in the ukraine
poland match which is ushenina against
kilbasa and this is a dead draw i know
shenanigan is up upon she's obviously
not going to lose that it looks like
team ukraine is about to secure a gold
medal
wow
wow what a result and um
that will be really fantastic of course
uh well deserved by team ukraine given
the fact what's happening their country
i mean how do you even concentrate on
chess and i know
right now they would totally deserve
that if anybody but them absolutely
it's such a feel-good story and i think
everybody can come together and just
celebrate
like you said the the strength of mind
uh that these players had to demonstrate
not only getting to india which itself
was a monumental challenge but
uh many of them most of them all of them
still have family all of their family in
ukraine
what a heartwarming story with anno
shenan going to secure the draw here and
maria music winning her game against
kashlinskaya
she is the hero of today's match and
they are going to be thanking team usa
from the bottom of their hearts that's
it carissa yip has officially won
all right
and don't say
you say it's taking the lead and about
to secure the victory
style too
tatev is just going to win this is
resignable for cool carney she in fact i
think she's going to resign right here
and right now
so rookie 796 uh that looks like a
killing threat maybe h3 final trick
something rely on that pawn is there
even a forced mate
h3 i would just even take that pawn yeah
maybe just take it right i mean the mate
is not going anywhere the pawn maybe is
that's it it's over it's over the us
wins and gives themselves a serious
chance to meddle to secure bronze which
would be a huge performance for the
ladies from the united states
and uh as we swing back to the open
section
amazing comeback what can i say there's
still to go incredible incredible and
what what a devastating final for india
this one's gonna burn for a long time
especially on their home home court i
mean it was the yesterday's painful
performance by gokesh i mean slipping
the victory for second team of india now
today heartbreaker for the woman team
but
in the end that sport that sport of
course everybody and understands that uh
india india woman team had their chances
everything was in their hands they
didn't use it so
well played so far by usa
yeah it's the beauty of chess that you
know if everything was predictable from
the very beginning we wouldn't watch and
the olympiad wouldn't be as fascinating
of an event as it is something crazy
always happens
in the final round and
this year is clearly
no exception
okay well what should we turn to now we
haven't checked into the armenia match
in a bit of a bit of a while let's do
that so let's just make sure that
gabriel sarguson is indeed
okay
lexi shuroff has extended this game to
46 moves and counting but he can
basically resign on any of these moves
right right five i mean he's still
trying to test his opponent because um i
mean nobody has made points by resigning
early but still i don't think this is
the opponent who is going to mess it up
and the sargassian has been playing very
uh
secure chess i mean he's never going to
rush he's too experienced to let this go
so it's more like uh being discussed
with his own play and that's why sheriff
is not yet resigning because this is it
i mean this is the final round this is
the final game there's no need to rush
to the hotel there's no
morning i mean there's no game tomorrow
right i mean that's why i guess he's
still here sticking together with the
team
yeah there are only flights flights back
to these players as homes
i think the simplest win in this
position is to go f5
and then king takes f5 and then just get
the rook around to like g7
right
that looks that might be convincing to
me
pretty efficient and gabriel notice how
patient he is he's got 30 minutes on his
clock and plenty of time i mean he's
just enjoying this too much you know
situation you just enjoy the position
too much oh my goodness this is winning
that is winning i have so much time on
the clock i mean let some people take
pictures of me while i speak exactly
exactly yeah let me just take a sip of
my coffee here
let's make some more tea
i think you might even play rook a3
first then force the bishop back to a5
and now play f5 this might be even more
clinical
that looks awesome
because the rook's coming back around to
g3 now this game is totally finished uh
so in any other board so this means
armenia is going to take the lead what's
happening in the second board of vallejo
against mokomian and milkumian has taken
over the initiative in this game
unbelievable
and it looks like armenia is going to be
hot on uzbekistan's tale
if haram milkumian can avoid losing this
game
so daniel your prediction are we gonna
see a drama
in the final end or it's gonna be
a normal result in that let's say team
uzbekistan confidently secures topic
three whatever
i feel like
is is very very close to screwing up
that uh two pawn advantage against
warmer dumb so what i feel is going to
happen is that warmer dam is going to
pull out a draw against vaquitav but i
feel like jungle here sindarov has good
chances to win that end game against
benjamin bach
so it would be crazier than crazy if
benjamin can hold a draw there
warmer dom can hold a draw in his game
and armenia surpasses uzbekistan for
gold that would be the ultimate crazy
finish but for that to happen first and
foremost from kumian has to make three
more moves until time control and keep
the status quo alive if both of these
trading the chat is praying for drama
everybody wants a drama daniel wants a
drama i want a drama a chat wants a
drama maybe we are gonna get it right we
very well might and if both armenia and
uzbekistan win their matches which is
looking like a pretty likely possibility
we will not know the tie breaks until
all of the matches end because olympia
tie breaks because of the team element
are incredibly complicated and we will
not be able to make any conclusions
until all of the matches are over but it
appears that uzbekistan will be more
likely to have the higher tie breaks
right looking at this position actually
one little thing i noticed that uh white
is up a pawn
but it's the
uh king which really bothers white right
i mean um
it's exposed
right oh white is up upon yeah that's
yeah what is up upon that's why i'm
slightly
you know i started to think about this
position why exactly black is better i
mean i i don't understand it because
black monster white once played rook b4
will b3
solidify
but the exposed king should be black
enough counterplay maybe something like
rook g7h5 rook g4
and then the rook is somehow
disconnected at the queens i mean i
don't know
is there them move rook takes f4 here
whoa
would this lead to a draw we look at
four and where's your idea
there's rook f4
nice
ah but okay but i don't think he's gonna
go for this just because like
black holds the draw here but why
why do something like this
maybe he's calculating it but you win
back the pawn right maybe again danny
daniel he's looking at the team
and uh seeing what's happening maybe i
need a draw
no a draw would be ideal here because we
know for a fact that sargeant is going
to win and santos latassa and hawaii
have agreed to a draw so that's official
so we have simply two more games
remaining and queen e7 with his final
seconds
goes front mokumen
so he's ambitious or he wasn't really
sure about this entire sequence as you
said
right
okay tough
okay so i guess white is going to try to
bring the rook in from b5 somehow back
to defense rook b to b3 would be my best
guess
rook b to b3 connecting linking up the
rooks and trying to keep these two pawns
intact your idea of rook g7 h5 and rook
g4
is definitely something that white has
to be
vigilant about
yeah
so something like this could happen and
uh what is their fourth ward
doing right now
by the way round x edwani has won his
game
so india two takes the lead right
against germany
yeah and that match is basically
assuming that gukesh does not lose that
end game against kaima
then nihal saren is guaranteed not to
lose india 2 is going to win their match
all right looks at least some sort of
good news for team india i mean the
entire nation who of course is now
closely following also what's going on
in the women's section where the first
team of india is about to lose their
gold medals but at least this would be
something
a desk
and with a smile alexis leans back in
his chair and resigns his game against
gabriel sergio and that means that team
armenia is within one game
of holding a final round victory against
team spain and putting the ball squarely
in uzbekistan's court what a fascinating
finish we are moving toward
okay
it all comes down to this warmer damn
game insane sargistan goes four and a
half out of five in the last five games
against some of the best players in the
world beating fabi karana beating
mamidyarov shirov and
again fantastic performance
well done incredible performance indeed
and uh he is going to be well over 2 700
after this tournament he's probably
going to be 27 15 27 20 maybe even at
his peak sergio has had such a long and
illustrious career and yet another
phenomenal performance notched among his
many tournament victories and
sensational results
okay so
this end game this is the big one
is black making forward progress or
backward progress is the question
i can easily see this ending i draw to
be honest like you said yeah
so something like knight e4
94 rook a7
or that no not e4 i want to centralize
the knight oh knight
f3 which looks a little bit weird to me
i agree with you completely i thought 94
was more natural
right some some check threads on f6 i
mean it goes to f6 square so i was
thinking knight e4 rook a7 play those
pawns and then they bothered the king
i'm not so sure this is still winning
rook b4 rk2 rook b7 check where the king
goes king e5 knight f6 etc yeah and the
bar of course confirms what they're
saying there
which is is that at this point it's
already a draw because i think here
white can simply continue harassing the
black king or maybe even go
knight f6 something to that effect no i
don't think that black will win
this type of position yeah this looks
already quite
closer to a draw i don't want to say
droish because maybe it's a heresy to
say such a thing being down to pawns but
definitely great chances
and your point earlier is very very
important which is that if these pawns
are traded on the queen side then white
is more than happy to give his night up
for black's last two pawns rook versus
rook and knight is a much easier draw to
make than rook versus rook and bishop
yeah which we actually saw earlier in
the olympia jordan when forest a couple
of fronts ago playing rook and rook
against rook and bishop he showed it so
flawlessly
i think at this level at the highest
level you should easily make it of
course rook and knight is much easier
all you need to do is not allow being
checkmated or just blunder the rook by a
fork
yeah and you can keep your king on the
back rank that's totally fine as long as
your rook is giving checks from behind
okay so we have this game and of course
we have cindaro of
against benjamin buck who are currently
in this position of benjamin bach having
taken 15 minutes in this position and
he's entering time trouble for the
second time his clock is down to 14
minutes
i mean he has to win does he ah
well at this point i don't think he does
because if he believes in warmer dom's
ability to draw that game so what's
fascinating let's say that cinderella
offered him a draw would bach accept it
is the question
you know it's quite amazing how the
situation can change imagine yourself
you're looking at your opponent uh i
mean at your teammate you see that okay
my teammate is gonna do it he's not
gonna lose okay i don't need to risk it
so you don't charge forward a couple of
months later your teammate blunders he's
losing and now your chance might be gone
because your rate is very committal
decision couple of months ago so it's
really really i mean it's not only you
playing but you also need to have an eye
open what's going on on your teammates
game and maybe try to postpone making
big decisions if that's even possible at
some point later
now by the way this is the reason why in
team tournaments and you can correct me
if i'm wrong but at least in the world
team championship we were allowed to
consult with our team captain
if a draw offer was made i was allowed
to ask john
uh whether he would advise me to accept
the draw of course the decision is
ultimately yours and yours alone
uh but you know there were times when
john felt very strongly about whether a
draw should be accepted or declined so
there's an entire
strategy
to be hashed out
in
the realm of accepting and declining
draws and making committal decisions
i'm not sure what is uh the current uh
rules in in this olympiad i read summer
that something has changed that the
captain uh apparently has less to say
during the matches but i don't really
know i mean there used to be olympiads
when even the captains could have
offered to draw and i think
this is something what definitely ramesh
rb would have done yesterday because you
could see his pain in the face i mean i
even still remember the picture it was
ramesh rb and even soccer ball sitting i
mean their cans are uh grabbing the head
and just praying this this match second
theme of being against us backstage is
gonna go their way but they would love
to offer a draw instead of their
opponent instead of their players but
apparently they just can't do it i mean
of course they can't do it but i think
this rule did exist some time ago
yeah that's that that would be nuts um
but we'll keep an eye on these two
matches the third big match in the open
section is of course team usa with uh
lanier dominguez losing his game in in
decisive fashion to arjun arigaisi the
phenom
leaving wesley so and sam shankland two
better end games both of them must
convert into a full point if the us is
to beat india in this final round
looks like sam shanklin is very close to
doing just that so the ball on c5 falls
and that means white is enjoying just an
extra pawn
um
yeah that being said by the way black
did play g5 daniel as you said
leaving a gaping hole on the f5 and once
the white knight is going to jump to f5
the pawn on h6 also will be bothered
this looks technical win
this does look like the technical one i
think the eval bar is bearing that out
and narayanan trying to find
some ways
wesley is he gonna do it is wesley going
to convert
the following position against vidit oh
it doesn't seem that way
you called it
i called it has the pass deep on but
it's the worst extra bond to have
yeah i know i feel responsible i mean
the b-bones are gone and the white is
left in the deep one and the question is
is this actually possible to win
well
i think what white wants to do is trade
those knights so with the knights gone i
have a feeling this is going to be very
close to winning because let's say we
remove the knights from c2 and b3
now i position the pawns on the dark
squares f4 h4 bring the king on c4 and
push d5
that should be winning
but i think that black is going to
object to that
i'm not going to comply
and if if that doesn't happen
how do you make progress and uh i think
what we have to mention here the general
strategy the stronger side usually wants
to trade pieces
so i mean white wants to trade the
knights uh leaving him a winning pawn
end game the weaker side which is black
here wants to trade pawns i mean how to
do that i mean obviously white wants to
get rid of all the king side pawns trade
the knight on d4 and
finish the day with a draw
right i mean i guess the big question
for black that he has to solve
that he has to answer in the next couple
of moves is a where do you actually park
the bishop and b
if white plays the move h4 trying to
provoke weaknesses on the kingside do
you play the move h5 which has the
obvious drawback of fixing the g6 pawn
on a weak square and precluding you from
ever being able to play g5
or do you find some other way to to hold
your king's side together
uh
right
i don't really know
i don't really know but you know maybe
it's also
important to look at the psychological
perspective of this match because if
shankland wins
on team india uh is now tied with usa i
think for first team of india this means
no medals either way
because they were right now in the
fourth place
uh behind the second team of india which
is going to take the medal so maybe this
could play a role for vidit it's not
only like he has to secure a draw i mean
draw sure fine it's nice he saved the
save the game saves the match but
it means it there's no medals so maybe
there's something like fifth place which
is still a very nice result but of
course they were hoping for some sort of
medals
open section without question and on
your camera there you saw the disgusted
facial expression of matthias blue bomb
who is going to lose his game
uh to nihal sorry he's got his head in
his hands he is upset and a resounding
positional masterpiece
put together
by nihal saran as he delivers the final
moves of this game we will see
resignation here
very very shortly and uh india 2 what a
win what a win without a single loss
they will win the match three can we see
it against germany
i i don't see it yet yeah this is the
position
all right
so i think it's just over
or if i take
h takes on g3
just still is on the board rook c1
because g2 was a threat by the way nice
trick h6 and g3 that threat has to push
g2
yeah indeed if you go when a5 then there
would be g2
right
so this is necessary and now
g2 a g2 route g1 rg3 a5
yeah that's a game or should be game
over
i mean
this is a slightly uneven race
right maybe rook 83 king d6 rook a2 rook
takes on g2 is the final blow
rook to hd2 classic idea distracting the
rook
and promoting
the pawn this is all over and nihal
sarin is going to deliver the final blow
putting india 2 in metal position but
we still have
a lot of action remaining in particular
we have the warmer dam end game against
uh johan girvajirov if uzbekistan wins
this game they come within an inch of
securing gold medal will jahon
girvajirov
does he have what it takes to convert
this end game that remains to be seen
you're watching the 44th chess olympiad
we will take one more short break and
when we come back
our pivotal matches between uzbekistan
and their netherlands and spain and
armenia will continue stay tuned
[Music]
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that stains a lot
you okay do the more game review okay
yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks
i gotta stop playing chess on tuesday oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
[Laughter]
i'll probably need to work on these ones
yep every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pass
rook there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
[Music]
welcome to india
the game of chess was born here
thousands of years later many of the
world's best players have made the trek
to represent their countries at the 44th
chess olympiad the most prestigious team
chess event on the planet
in chennai
the chess capital of india
circumstance has cleared the way for
perhaps more countries than ever to set
their sights on gold
india has high hopes for keeping the
hardware at home
with three top teams competing in the
open and the top seed in the women's
section the host country has legitimate
reasons to believe it can sweep gold and
more
entering as the favorites
team usa has suffered multiple dramatic
disappointments so far will they have
what it takes to finish strong and keep
their metal hopes alive
while medals count some accomplishments
won't be measured in gold
the women's team from ukraine has
overcome adversity just to make it here
now they hope to honor their nation with
a memorable performance
namaste
in one place for the first time in four
years these olympians are together again
the 44th olympiad has brought the
world's best to the place the game of
chess began
and with that let today's games begin
and it is the final round of the 44th
chess olympiad 2022 and the big question
who is going to take home gold medal
uzbekistan leading the tournament before
the start of the round they are on the
cusp of winning their match
against uh against the netherlands but
there is still work to be done and
armenia is even closer than uzbekistan
to winning their match against team
spain archers we could not have possibly
asked for a more exciting round than
we've had so far today
absolutely daniel i mean i don't even
think it's absolutely clear so far who's
gonna gonna take down the gold at the
moment it looks like tiruma media might
win the match the same applies for
uzbekistan but then there's the tie
breaks and of course one small slip from
either the teams out of the players
there's a draw which again could train
change
everything dramatically so even in the
fifth hour of the games of the final
round we still don't know who is going
to win this
indeed we do not just to recap the
situation at the top if if both
uzbekistan and armenia win their matches
then we will not know
which one of them wins gold medal until
all of the results are in and then we
will be able to calculate the very
complicated tie breaks
if uzbekistan wins and armenia draws or
loses or vice versa then the team that
wins earns gold medal that is for
certain
and it seems to me that armenia
basically has it in the back we have one
more game remaining
and it's haunt milk modbumian's game
against vallejo opponents i just don't
see black losing this do you
well there's that i mean uh black still
has uh
um is missing a pawn right so at the
moment armenia is leading against spain
to against one final game so this is
also a signal for vallejo tried to push
for the win
so with the king and h3 maybe his idea
is to position rookie three rookie five
if i was a if i was a melcomian i would
probably be thinking about queen of five
frog g4
uh get to the pawns on f4 and h4 but you
know
daniel i'm not sure what is in
melcomian's mind right now is it just
securing the victory for the team or is
it thinking about
tie breaks does he really think about
that because again there might be a tie
between team uzbekistan and armenia and
in order to secure a better tie you need
a better score
probably not i mean he's just thinking
about how to bring this at least a
victory for the team what do you what do
you think about that i agree i i
honestly think that he's thinking about
how to make a draw
like he's thinking about the victory for
the team and i feel like if a situation
arises where armenia doesn't get lucky
on the tie breaks so be it but
i think he senses that
you know that that i draw in this game
and they win in the in the matches is by
far
uh the most important thing because if
he loses then armenia loses all chances
of getting gold medal
right and here we are actually we can
have a look at the tiebreakers uh in
case there's going to be a time
you can check the
we'll talk about that a little bit later
we'll we'll fill you in on the tie
breaks when uh a proper opportunity
arises but again it is entirely possible
that uh
that we won't even need to talk about
the tie breaks if
armenia and uzbekistan do not have the
same results
okay so haran mokumen trying to hold
this position together against
paco vallejo
and of course the other big game max
warmer dom against vaquirov and javakir
sindarov against benjamin black
and this is the current position
in the vekirav game
well things have slightly deteriorated
for
white if i dare to say so because he is
not
closer to trade the a pawn for for the b
pawn i felt that you needed to include
that so that you don't have to
worry about it again the best practices
are that you have to trade off the balls
if you are the weaker side if you have
the stronger side you're trying to trade
the pieces and here the white king is
slightly cut off now from the action i
mean some moves ago white had the knight
on where was it again on e4 at least he
could have landed on e4 the king was on
f4 and now the king on f3 knight on b3
one can't help but feel this is just not
the way to go and uh dania i'm not sure
i have a feeling that now again makidov
is taking over the game here no i i
everything you said i agree with
completely i think warmer dam has to try
to keep his foot on the gas pedal maybe
go knight a5 in this position
i feel like that might be the best
chance
but
you're okay three and then you activate
the king right so this is probably not
what black is going to do
yeah
three knight c6
yeah knight c6 king e5 slowly white is
very active oh but there is a problem i
think instead of rook a3 i can go rook
c5
or maybe even rook c5 first
just like rook c5 in response to knight
a5 and if you play 9b3
yeah i guess you just go back to b3
no it's not so easy to keep this pawn
alive it's crazy no it's not actually
you know i want to continue this line
daniel you mentioned the rook c3 king of
four and then rook c5 because i saw g5
check incoming
i mean here rook c3 king before rook c5
now g5 check is coming next you need to
push those pawns eventually yeah you
need to start setting those pawns in
motion
but here specifically i think i have
king okay i have to blink in g4 yeah
king e4 is a fork you have to go king g4
maybe this is actually giving wise some
chances again king h5 kg6 those pawns
don't don't have any support it's tricky
it's tricky
i mean it's unbelievably difficult
it's unbelievably difficult to set those
pawns in motion it's like no matter how
how you slice it you're always either
losing the b-pawn or your knight is
loose or your rook is loose or white
gets too active
and the time continues to dwindle like
hit up is under 20 minutes that's not a
lot of time in a position like this
right and then we have the other board
in the camera benjamin bark against
cindarov
is there any progress
let's take a look
and this is the current position
you know
actually
i feel uh
at least when i'm playing in these
positions when i'm completely winning
let's say like vaquita completely
winning three extra pawns
uh so i like calm down okay i'm gonna do
it uh the job is done and the game drags
on it just
keeps continuing for another hour
another hour another half an hour the
more you play the more nervous you
become because it's like i mean it's
gonna be there right it's right there
this victory should be right there and
yet my opponent is not resigning it
starts to get annoying at some point you
should have been an easy positional
victory now you have to work very hard
and very often this is where you start
to slip and make a mistake
that's exactly that's very well
explained my coach should always say
that when you miss that first win the
wins become harder and harder and harder
the longer the game drags on even if the
evaluation stays the same even if it
stays plus three as you're saying
psychologically it feels like the
situation is deteriorating because
with every passing
half an hour with every passing ten
moves you start putting more pressure on
yourself to make more progress and
eventually that is likely to lead to
uh as you said to a mistake
born of impatience
okay what to make of this position crazy
i don't know what to make of this again
uh here's the thing cindaroff is not
sure what he's supposed to do
i i think actually this is contributing
to the confusion because he doesn't know
for sure if fajita is going to win
because he needs
he needs to win if he knows vaquita is
winning okay he's going to try to
liquidate he doesn't know that so he
might have to make some very big risks
at some point try to push for the win in
case vaquita doesn't do it which
actually might give a chance for
netherlands
so let's say he's operating under the
assumption that he's okay with the draw
the move rook a5 i'm having a hard time
understanding how benjamin reacts to it
what happens if flag goes right okay
five goes after the pawn maybe that's a
draw actually rook c6 or k7 maybe this
is uh the way to fix a draw or
oh rookie five
oh but then maybe maybe black i think
has to liquidate with something like
knight d3
on some nasty checks on seto
yep and okay i mean black should be able
to hold the draw here but clearly not
more than that
clearly not more than that cinderella
would love to see that i mean having a
risk-free uh position to play for the
win he would love to see that definitely
this would be really good
just force the draw
okay five works c6 and no not like this
rookie 5 or xd6 and back to a7 attacking
g7 forcing the rook to come back to g6
this is what you're saying
yeah
yeah i think he's going to do it i have
a feeling he's going to repeat moves
here
god that's such a difficult decision
again
and listen the captain could give you a
very very important advice i mean
right
just do this or that can the captain do
that i don't think so
god it's crazy to me that max warmer dom
is is still in the game like it
literally seemed like the game was over
but all of a sudden there's this
uncertainty
and sindarov was hovering over the rook
on a7 i think he was about to play rook
a5 maybe he thought better of it i don't
see if there are any other candidate
moves i guess
maybe you could start with rook e5 same
idea
all right rookie five is on the board by
the way
i think
sticks
rookie five or d6 and then again you can
repeat
um this would be one way out of this
otherwise if you play too long
those pawns on e4 and e5 they might
become a problem if they are getting
pushed to something like d4 e3
yeah one misstep you're done i mean
they're essentially a new queen and you
don't want to do that especially in such
a responsible moment like here playing
for the gold medals in the olympia 14.
very very responsible moment here for
sundara
jeez
and positive developments for team
armenia i think mokumen is essentially
forcing
at the very least to draw an end game in
his game against paco allejo so that
would conclude
the armenia
um spain match and it would put
uzbekistan in a must
win situation okay so
after
rookie five can black try rook g5
no i don't think so take takes on rook
a5 i guess yeah
um
this is close
way but you need to like that right
i mean no i'm scared
e5 if you're e3 king this loses
yeah rook c1 d4 d3 d2 oh my unbelievable
look at this and after rookie one this
is a classic idea you of course go d1
queen you don't take the rook
right that's a beautiful line so i guess
after e3 the winning move for white is
to drag the king a little bit closer and
the biggest stopped opponent e4 you play
king of three right not rook d5 again
rook d5 there's e2 you're right king f3
d4 still not over
five yeah everything just falls or rook
a4 everything just falls yeah it's
you've got to start collecting the
harvest here yeah yeah
um benjamin less than four minutes on
his clock he's got to make a decision
he's got to make a decision and he's
probably calculating that line
i mean that needs to be calculated if
you're trying to win the game with black
but
once you realize that you can't play it
then
rook b6 or rick d6 i think you have to
play right and again let's not
completely rule out team netherlands
chances for the medals because they also
have a say in this matter right they
also want to get medals or at least have
a shot so finishing 2-2 draw because
it's already pretty clear that farmer
dumb is not going to win them and win
the game against vaquita
maybe this is a chance also for
netherlands to strike back that's why i
hear instead of trying to immediately
secure draw benjamin is trying to figure
out do i have even slightest chances to
play this for the victory as well right
right and but i think with the time
situation the answer basically is a very
resounding no i mean you have three
minutes for the rest of the game
so if anything
you know benjamin also can't afford to
lose this because if he loses this then
vaquitas game becomes a completely moot
point
right so
okay it's official ron milkumien has
drawn his game
against paco vallejo
a huge result for team armenia they win
their match with a score of two and a
half one and a half on the strength of
gabriel sarkisian's incredible
performance and victory over alexey
sheriff
here at the final round of the olympiad
and it is official uzbekistan is in a
must win situation if they want a chance
at that gold medal and that means also
team armenia secures at least a silver
medal because they were in the first and
second place shared place before the
final round they win nobody can take a
medal away from them either way it
doesn't matter how's back is not going
to finish maybe they're going to have
the victory and the best tiebreaks but
still team armenia had an amazing run in
this tournament
i mean simply incredible again not a
single player over 2700 but what they do
have
is magical
team chemistry that has been written
about that has been built up over many
many olympiads of playing together
of experience and of team camaraderie
what a performance by gabriel sergio and
the armenian team
that he led this year
okay back to the warmer dom game
oh looks like progress is finally
starting to be made by bakidov
those pawns sooner or later you have to
roll forward yeah now that the white
king cannot get to h5 easily
eventually you have to start pushing
them and he found the opportunity to do
that now this check gives absolutely
nothing because of king d8 right
right i mean king of faith is the wrong
way to go because white has this very
unusual drawing idea knight h7 king g8
knight f6 so you don't go to the corner
unless you're looking for trouble
rock h7 is an arabian mate
that it is so king d8 is the way to go
and here the black crook on d4 is really
well positioned because it defends the
pawn on b4 they cancel against and he
checks on d7
i think fajita is going to do it the
more i look at it i think that
uh whatever chances varmadam
had
they're gone
it just doesn't feel like the position
his knight is in a terrible spot and the
reason his knight is in a terrible spot
is because it's not it's neither here
nor there you can't attack before
but you're also not doing a good job of
stopping
the progress of black spawns not to
mention that you're down to 10 minutes
on your clock and that might be
you know one of the bigger problems here
he just doesn't have the time to figure
out
you know the most resilient defensive
sequence
right all right let's try tricks can i
play rook b5 here rook b5 oh i plundered
the fork on e4 oh rook takes e4
check
yes okay doesn't work nice trick but the
big idea is i want to sacrifice the
knight on g5 so let's say you remove
your knight to wherever
i don't know h4 probably is the right
way to go but 97
yeah i know what i want to take on g5
somehow take take take take rook g5
yeah you want a position like this
i don't
know if i want this but i might have to
at some point
yeah this might be as good of a
defensive chance as any
robin it's losing i i don't think that
white can play at any given moment 83 to
trade the b-pawn yeah it's probably just
lost
the king is too far away
and the rook cuts off the king along the
d-file which is another problem
which means that white's king can never
get to for example b3 which would
totally change the landscape of the
position
all right all right but maybe something
like this might happen at some point and
this is also what black needs to
account for but i think knight h4
actually makes more sense i mean not
even venture there uh give a check uh
improve the night although knight h4
king e3 whatever happens there
still some chances for team netherlands
no question about it but warmer dog
needs to play a move here and he's got
to do it pretty fast
how will he coordinate his pieces in an
effort
to save a miracle draw
and secure gold medal for armenia
by the way benjamin block i think has
correctly decided
to trade the d5 pawn for the b3 pawn and
according to the eval bar this is the
dead draw cindarov is very likely just
to repeat moves here
so king of four is
risky right king four is just not the
way to go because i might give you a
check on f3
rook f3 king e5 and my e-pawn could just
roll forward very fast yeah this is
already a problem
right rook c5 e2 rook c1 rook f1
so this this pawn is actually
unstoppable this is not where you want
to go and if you don't go there where do
you go
he goes back to h2 after a lot of
hesitation there
i think
he went king h2 we're looking there on
top right of your screen at the camera
and it appears to me that a repetition
of moves is totally inevitable here and
we have an update of second team india
nikola starring has won his game against
matthias blue bomb and that means second
team of india has secured probably at
least a medal so we have two medalists
we just don't know how they're
positioned it's quite clear tier mamina
is taking at least silver team india is
gonna take uh probably a bronze so team
uzbekistan fighting for the gold
unfortunately for team usa i think this
means probably no medals other men
armenia uzbekistan and india too they've
got dibs
on the three medals
and even if team usa wins that is just a
testament to how strong this olympiad
has been
okay benjamin bach you see him checking
on b2
and
repetition of moves here seems imminent
you don't want to go to h4 because
that's running into a checkmate there's
no progress for white
and benjamin looking over you can see
max warmer down there looking over at
his teammates game but there's nothing
either side can do here
right
yeah of course unfortunate
for max because
normally the fourth board with a white
caller would expect to try to play for
the victory but something clearly went
wrong for max in the opening phase he
was just outplayed he got a second
chance uh after vakidov misplayed things
but now maybe it's already too late and
at the moment team uzbekistan is on the
way to not only
get a victory in the match but also a
victory in olympia most likely and it
does appear that vaquita is literally
knocking on the door he's got his pawn
on g4
warmer dom still trying still trying to
use his knight
to do whatever he can
but the eval bar here seems to reflect
it's over i think it's all francis
there's a draw handshake draw in
benjamin box game against sindarov and
it's all down to this final game can
vaquita put the finishing touches
and
win the match for team uzbekistan i
think it's 95
daniel that team uzbekistan is going to
clinch the victory in the final fourth
game uh against max varmadam this means
uh both top teams after the ten rounds
armenia and uzbekistan they scored two
and a half points and since team
uzbekistan had the better tiebreaks much
better tiebreaks venturing into the
final round i think it's a very good bet
that uzbekistan in the end are going to
take down the gold medals that's what it
looks like
yeah we are
you know obviously it's not 100
tie breaks are complex
but you're absolutely right and armenia
watching
max swarm or dumb with disappointment
they of course we're hoping for at least
a draw in this game
oh and after king f3 here i think the
move rook d2
ends the game
is this the most efficient method
it looks very good g2 g1 very nice idea
to cut off the king or give a check
first then gm first yeah then g2 and
it's over that lights out rook b1 rook
f1 shake yes we might actually see it on
the camera happening there these are the
final moments barmerdam's body language
says it all this game is over
yeah
and by the way uh as we watch max former
dumb agonize over his last couple of
moves before resigning king f3 by the
way is on the board uh a quick update on
team usa sam shankland is about to win
his game
against aaron on equalizing the match
and wesley so
it appears has failed
to convert that extra pawn position so
team usa is going to tie india with a
score of 2-2
and uh
basically conclude all of the big
matches of the day
um god there's some crazy positions
that i'm looking at in some of the other
matches but we're obviously going to
wait
uh for the conclusion of this game when
we're going do we have an update also
what's happening in the women's section
who is looking likely to get the gold
medals is it team ukraine probably right
i think their final board was having
this uh drawing rooking game olivia
calabaza against who was it anusha and
you know they're still playing but i
mean obviously anu shannon is the only
one who can
who can do anything in this position so
a draw would be perfectly sufficient i
think for ukraine it's official you
crane with the gold medal
in the women's section
incredible
yeah that's what it looks like right now
maria music took such a clutch
performance to defeat alina kashlinskaya
and wins the match for ukraine but let's
keep watching vakirav
rook d4 to c4 he doesn't play rook d2
amazing
i thought rook d2 was just resigns
right
c4 is this also good
i think the idea is 96 rook c3 rook c2
track so you pretty much have to put the
knot on e4 but then rook takes c4
oh that's pretty
room
king of seven
that's a fourth by the way on d6 so you
can't think of a check yeah oh yeah
here 97 at a minimum oh wait i missed
something oh my goodness i missed
something there okay doesn't matter what
were you thinking i was thinking uh
there's a fork no
no there wa there was a fork right so
rook b8 yeah yeah there's also 96 that's
true yeah yeah
oh so what you're saying is you have to
start with this move
but it doesn't matter right king e4 g2
now uh the black king conveniently
defends the g8 square for the rook
unfortunately the b4 pawn is there you
can't play rugby one which will be final
hope for white no there's no hope for
white
96 rook c3 check accurately delivered by
vaquita there's no perpetual the knight
on f5 is doing a great job of holding
together some of the key squares and
after king f4 g2 king takes f5 g1 it's
not hard to establish that there is no
perpetual the king runs towards c8
and resignation is imminent here by max
warmer dumb
indeed uh about the women's section i
wanted to ask actually um if we go back
to that uh is team poland and azerbaijan
still within the contention because
there was like a massive tie of 16
points so it was
uh india first team obviously is going
down but there's poland azerbaijan
ukraine georgia who could contest the
gold medals
so
is it a certainty that if ukraine wins
which they will that they will get gold
so
i i felt like it was a certain scenario
that if india loses which they did to
team usa
and ukraine wins they get gold
but that's not necessarily true because
azerbaijan
and georgia might have something to say
about that as well
uh exactly
yeah let's check it out poland
azerbaijan and also georgia might have a
say
okay so in the poland
okay so first of all azerbaijan is
playing georgia
and they are down to two boards they're
they have drawn
on two of the boards
and the last remaining games here are
betsya schweli against
uh balayava
which should be a draw
this should be a drawn rocket game
although this game is going to last for
a while
and then we have mary arabij on the
other board
with white pieces in a completely
winning position
so that means that means that georgia
might win but actually you know then we
might get to the tiebreaks because
georgia was slightly
had a slightly worse score than ukraine
they are having the same amount of
points you would have die it's not even
clear who's going to take the gold
another by john
azerbaijan is losing this right so
they're out of contention and poland
what are poland doing
poland lost to ukraine
all right right paul lost to ukraine
poland is out azerbaijan is out
so it looks like it might be a very
close tie between ukraine and georgia
wow it's so close it's so close there
was like a very very narrow margin in
the tie breaks 330
and a half against 315 the tie breaks so
it really matters what score i mean you
win the final round the opponent
wow it's a
coin flip
it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be so so
so so so close
between
between ukraine
and georgia but yeah we're
basically looking here and the tie break
seems to be
the funny thing is if azerbaijan had won
they had better tie breaks than ukraine
and ukraine has better tiebreaks than
georgia so it's actually really good for
ukraine that georgia is about to win
this match
right
yeah but it does appear that ukraine has
the better tie breaks i i'm pretty
confident that ukraine is going to take
gold
i guess we're gonna see either way i
think uh so far we are looking towards
uh first weight tie between
uh ukraine georgia whoever is going to
have the better tiebreaks in case the
match is going to finish how they are
looking at right now and probably team
india
is gonna take the third place that's how
it looks like at the moment despite the
loss in the final round
indeed that would be crazy too losing
the last round still getting third place
but it's going to be very very close
based on the tie breaks we are watching
uh
wakiraf putting the finishing touches
on his pivotal win against warmer dam
look at how patient he is he's not
moving
until he makes completely sure that he's
got the right move in mind king d8 here
is game over
all right all right let's see it king d8
eva
yeah it should be resignation right
after that there's just no more moves to
make okay one check out of spite on e6
or b8 but that's it in the end this jeep
owner is unstoppable i think he's just
in you know
slightly disbelief what is happening
here he's making history here team
uzbekistan uh i think it was yesterday
they got the rise to organize 2026
watches olympiad in tashkent and
scoring olympia the victory here in the
2022 watches olympiad in chennai would
be something in 1992 team uzbekistan got
silver is this history here in the
making do they got gold i guess we are
going to find it out
that would be nuts
and uh one of the most epic olympiad
performances in history for sure by
uh an incredibly young team rugby a
chuck by the way is on the board warm
adam continues to make moves but king d7
here i think is the most clinical win
because
warmer damage
one last trick rook g8
and if you blindly make a queen
then it's actually a draw after 98 check
never too late to blunder
never ever too late to blunder
it's actually easy to miss it because i
was looking at 96 check
you know 96 king d6 i'm in the chill
mode i'm gonna just collect the knight
uh extra piece extra pawn whatever but
98 very smart
right but none of this i mean even if
that's winning for black king d7 avoids
all of the checks so
um uh vakidov is probably just like
quadruple checking every line
before playing king d7
right i don't know why warmer thomas
isn't resigning this but
hoping i'm hoping for one last miracle
yeah
i guess he has nowhere to go anyway
right that's the final round final day
um
not not a great way to finish the
tournament but still
that is what it is
team um alexander is going to do it
and that's it
that was the final move i think there
you go yes he avoided lost rap
resignation
uzbekistan wins the match
what an incredible finale is both
leaders win their match with a score of
two and a half one and a half and it's
all down to the tie breaks and we
believe that uzbekistan is very likely
to have the better tie breaks but
nothing is for certain until all of the
games are over
right
incredible
all right now
uh what were the tie breaks again
no maybe we can try to caulk like that
right because now it's official there's
gonna be a tie there is a tie for the
first place and there you see i mean
daniel i'm not so good with advanced
mathematics what do you make of yeah
this takes me back to calculus class so
there's a formula to determine the tie
breaks and the formula can be calculated
basically it's the sum
of is of 10 for 10 highest ranking team
opponents and you can see the
designations their gpi is the game
points scored in a match against a
certain opponent and then fmpi is the
final number of match points scored by
an opponent so i'm not going to pretend
to understand
exactly how this is calculated this is
outside my job description but one way
or another it will be calculated by
people in the know
and what i can tell you what we can tell
you for certain is that uzbekistan had
the better tiebreaks going into this
round that's
an indisputable certainty so barring
something crazy given that they both won
with the same score
i'm pretty sure that uzbekistan is going
to edge out armenia by tie breaks i also
think so so for the moment it looks like
uzbekistan has taken the goal but let's
not jump the gun before it's official it
looks like that but i mean maybe
something uh miraculous happens and i've
seen this actually happen dania what's
been your worst experience in terms of
uh you're going in the final round with
an amazing uh lead in the tie breaks
like i'm talking about the book hauls
and then something unthinkable happens
and you lose this entire uh lead you can
and
yeah all of your bullets has just lose
the final round well i
i played uh two title twos days ago i
was leading by an entire point going to
the last round at nine out of ten
so of course i need only a draw to get
clear first i lose
but i
figured that since i'm leading the
tournament by an entire point i must
have better tie breaks and not only did
i not have better tie breaks but i
actually end up in third place rather
than first
so that's the problem with tie breaks
they're totally unpredictable and just
because you have better tie breaks
before the last round doesn't mean that
you keep your lead but in this case i
think the tie break edge is sufficiently
vast
to where i i just don't see how how
uzbekistan
is going to squander this lead
right so for the moment this is what the
top three looks like in the open section
most likely i mean it's not yet official
it's unofficial that uzbekis uzbekistan
is going to take gold on better thai
breaks team armenia is going to take the
second place and second team of india
are going to clinch the bronze medals
by the way i pulled up a funny position
here in the game between
uh mcshane and hamitavichi
with the english player
struggling against two of black's queens
and there's a beautiful mating sequence
here queen takes h4 rook h2 and queen
takes f3 check would finish the game
nice
and a big upset here by the moldovan
grand masters he's going to defeat
uh the english
gm aldo a couple of rounds ago was it
the last round i mean in uh yesterday
they beat norway who had a downhill
tournament i mean they also lost today
and avicii beat um
christensen i think i mean again one of
their strong groundmasters
so he's been having a pretty good run in
the final rounds yeah very impressive
stuff
and looking around at some of the other
matches we have a couple of games still
going but all of the metal games
all of the metal matches
have been completed the only remaining
game is wesley's game against vidit but
this is obviously a dead dead draw
and i think we're going to see a
handshake here very shortly as well usa
even if they win i don't think they can
score a medal here because the second
team of india has won the match their
tie breaks were so much better
um
and that means that
there's just impossible to catch it
maybe share third and fourth place and
remain in fourth place at starbucks
either way disappointment probably for
usa men team who are pre-tournament huge
yield of favorites but i mean
that's the olympia it's unpredictable
exactly it is it is
why we watch
and i think we almost see that every
year i mean the the pure rating
favorites
they have won in the past i think it was
the time that the us actually won the
olympiad a couple of olympiads ago
uh in tromso they were the rating
favorites
but
you can see here that a team with not a
single player over 2700 is more than
capable of long lasting success both
armenia and uzbekistan demonstrated that
here
now can we try to make some predictions
how the women's tournament is going to
finish because again it's not very clear
who indeed takes the gold
or who even is fighting for the bronze
is it really team india or usa has
surpassed
uh team india because what was the final
score again of team usa versus uh india
it was three to one it was well that's
actually pretty impressive you know
that's incredibly impressive
yeah they might just overtake india this
is i don't know how to predict
yeah there's there's going to be highly
convoluted complex calculations being
made
um but it is
clear that either ukraine or georgia are
going to take gold
um
and silver obviously both of them are
going to meddle and then either team usa
or team india who they just beat
and that's crazy the fact that a team
can beat another team and the team that
they beat can still
meddle
pretty crazy but that's just how the
olympiad happens we are going to do
those calculations
and bring the results of them to you but
first we're going to go on one more
very short break just to take a deep
breath settle down all of the metal
matches are over uzbekistan and armenia
claim gold and silver medals what a
finale we just watched here at the 44th
chess olympiad stay tuned we have a lot
of conclusions to make we have a lot of
tie breaks to calculate and we will do
that right on the other side of this
short break
see you in a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
man we just played like three games it's
a four to one streak my way
me and him actually learned around the
same time
you know it's been fun watching him grow
he's early on who treasures cleaning off
cool he doesn't mind losing his queen
but he uses his horses more i'll be i'm
a little mad if you take my horses
because they the deadliest piece on the
board
everybody think it's the queen but it's
the horse because
you can't defend it
[Music]
welcome back to the 44th chess olympiad
our coverage continues we know most of
the medalists in both of the sections
but not all of the intrigue has ended
just yet now we know that ukraine
defeated poland in the women's section
to guarantee themselves either gold or
silver medal now we were assuming that
georgia has it in the bag on account of
mario beatze having a completely winning
position against her azerbaijani
opponent but our tourists something
crazy is happening this game bishop
takes c4 check or caf7 the move queen h3
led to immediate checkmate the threat of
queen h8 is unstoppable instead arabic
decides to liquidate
and
she's still winning
but this gets a little bit more
complicated how easy do you think this
is going to be
um i guess it's uh quite important for
uh not allowed to black to block those
central pawns so if black is allowed to
trade the queens put the king on b5 then
out of e6 then white
simply can't win this game so here i
guess you have to push d5 d5 remove the
bishop play e6 but one thing dania what
i see here is one particular square in
my mind
that's the a8 square right so i'm
looking at this square i'm looking at
the color for my bishop and i realize
that's the wrong corner
oh so if you trade queens you're saying
that black will then be able to give
potentially her night away four whites
two remaining central pawns but i have
some news for you which is that the
result of this game actually seems to be
a moot point
because ninobatsiyashvili has managed to
win that endgame against uh
i amazing right and that run
and that means that team georgia is
already ahead so it's i mean
maybe i mean maybe it is actually
important you know because if the game
finishes if the match finishes two and a
half against one and a half maybe
they're gonna miss out the gold medals
because there's gonna be probably a tie
of uh team georgia
against uh team ukraine if i'm not
totally mistaken so two and a half
against three one this might be the
difference of gold medals
indeed and by the way olivia kielbasa in
the match against ukraine has managed to
lose that game against anno shenan that
was an end game she should have drawn
and she loses with this loss her
undefeated status in the tournament so
first it was gukesh
now it's kielbasa and a disappointing
finale for some of these
uh incredible competitors across both
sections
but understandable fatigue
the pressure of having to perform
and uh a sad finale here for kilbasa but
ukraine scoring another big win and
they're going to win with a margin of 3
to 1. and again this might be the
difference of the gold medals right
because right then we're going to
calculate the tie breaks we just
discussed the team georgia might make
3-1 and team ukraine already did it 3-1
so in the end we are going to have a
very very narrow tie in the woman's uh
tournament
with uh ukraine after round 10 slightly
edging of georgia but it's so narrow
it's completely unpredictable
right
right and um
we will only be able to tell you
uh after all of the results have
concluded who which team edges the other
by tie break
okay
yeah let me move on from here i believe
there's still a number of uh games being
played at uh at the top boards
yeah we can switch back for a second to
the open section
um because it is quite clear that
georgia and ukraine both have their
matches in the bag as we see i know
putting
the finishing touches against kilbasa
but in the open section we do have a
couple of ports still remaining
in some of the top 10 games here we have
andre velakedan against thomas larussa's
from lithuania
with laura russos trying to promote his
far advanced passer
so this means probably that malakitian
can't play this for the win despite the
fact he has an extra pawn on the queen
side it's the pawn on h3 which matters
with the queen g through uh with the
queen of two quincy to a threat
so if the pawn on h3 remains i think
here it's white who has to make a draw
he has to make a throw but how do you
make a drop probably it should be a draw
even without a pawn and b pawn but
not more kind of well you have to give
the right you have to give the right
checks i guess and queen c1 is is forced
right so king g2 probably is the move to
be played queen uh you can't trade the
queens queen c6 is a bad check on the
queen any check on the second rank also
is just suicide so i guess queen g5 back
yeah i think this is actually a pretty
straightforward draw king g2 queen g5
king
h2q no matter where the king goes you
have a corresponding check that doesn't
allow black to block it with this queen
um yeah that's what it looks like today
yeah if the black queen is allowed to
get closer to the uh king and protect
from the checks this is unnecessary risk
and of course white is not gonna
try to find it out if there's a draw or
not
queen d3 king g2 and here i think it's
important to deliver a check on g6
in order to force the king onto the h
file so that you can then return for
example to c2 can i try to zugzwang use
uh no zuzwang about triangle king h2
king g1 king h1 and somehow get the
queen in front
so yeah like this yeah but of course i
think it's useless king h1 i think
whitney for a shock
okay
brilliant yeah if your queen was only on
g7 like that would change everything
but for some reason he put his queen on
f8 like he had this position a while ago
but i guess he he just kind of lost his
composure he lost his cool
and ultimately just decides that there's
no way he's going to pull this off and
team lithuania actually is leading
against ukraine i'm surprised to see
that and this is one of the surprising
teams
uh so far in the olympia they had a
number of great results they played 2-2
against germany i think now i'm telling
this from memory because we're following
their matches a while ago then 2-2
against france or was it for france
against germany doesn't matter they're
playing really good it's a nice uh team
with young grommesters motivated hungry
grandmasters and they're playing well
yeah valerie kasikovsky who i've never
heard of before defeated voldemort on
the
this game by the way is a game that
lithuania cannot lose and
and on this board lithuania cannot lose
either so they're going to win that's it
uh regardless of how these other games
finish
but it of course lithuania would like to
win in crushing style
and that depends on whether pulitzes can
pull out a win
out of an end game that i've actually
had in my career a couple of times this
type of end game with bishop
a rook and two against rook and three
what do you make of this should be a
pretty easy one
should be yeah
yeah because that's even the right
corner and speaking about powerless pull
to now he is the top scorer for team
lithuania so far going seven and a half
out of nine
for ward four
2750 performance this is clearly a
breakout tournament for powerless i i
obviously know him because latviana we
are very very close
neighboring countries same history
pretty much so i mean team lithuania
might just make it i'm not sure top 10
because if they win this match after the
round 10 they were something like 20
21st place with the victory they might
just find themselves catapulted to
something like 11th 12th place which is
probably going to be one of the finest
achievements of later nhs in the past
years
very impressive very impressive
performance by as you said the young and
hungry group of lithuanian grandmasters
um looking around we
we have this little end game in the game
it's in burkish oh my god now this is a
game
in which fair and sparkish was
completely winning out of the opening i
mean it wasn't even close and somehow i
mean tabatabai has managed to get it
and pull his way into a drawn rook and
bishop versus rook end game but probably
he's not not gonna be very upset about
it because team congress is winning
anyway the match would have been
slightly different story if it was iran
leading the match so team hungary leads
2-1 at the moment and having already
clearly drawn the pocket so this means
hungary is going to take it
down winning iran in the final round
again catapulting himself probably in
top 10.
yeah if we rewind a little bit earlier
this game it was a crushing attack right
out of the opening by berkus
rook takes d7 knight takes f6
look at these tactics you can sleep with
a knight then you get forked on e6 so
you have to take with a rook
bishop takes f2 check total desperation
and barakish deciding to transition
into
what has to be a completely winning
endgame up upon
dominating with his peace tandem and
somehow he failed to win this kudos to
amin for a crazy second actually a bit
surprised there was not like a direct
win right i mean that this is the best
he could have got but uh maybe there was
something because that attack looks
totally crushing and in then you do get
upon an end game
but whatever i mean maybe actually i
think king h1 was probably more accurate
just to keep as many pieces on the board
as possible
right
just yeah
bishop c queen g to rook g1 huge ideas
incoming that should be
very good yeah even rookie one just pile
up on the e6 pawn this is basically
resignable
right um but when push came to shove
berkush didn't quite have that crushing
blow in him and how many moves have they
made
uh not many they've only made 13 moves
of this end game so this could
potentially last for all 50. depending
on how long burkish wants to torture him
well actually it's actually quite
interesting danya that you chose this
game because in my fresh memory is
tabata bay being from the stronger side
couple of rounds ago rook and bishop vs
rock playing against jordan when forest
but he was the one pushing his opponent
i think it was tabatabe who did it and
he was the one pushing it up to move 50
and jordan showed his flawless technique
rook on the second rank uh in the end it
finished with a stalemate trick you give
it a check bishop takes the rook it's a
stalemate and now it's tabatabe who
cares to show the right technique how to
draw this i mean that's fate
yeah
another interesting endgame we have is
in the game of matisse bartel and dragon
solak that's poland against turkey
this seems to be a pretty
straightforward win for white
yeah i actually think this is just
resignable
um right
what's so like what i'm doing here yeah
all the difference
oh so that's actually a close match with
mustafa yomez drawing way to check okay
and resignation so bartel wins but uh
alimorandi beats miranda so it all comes
down in poland against turkey to this
last game
where casper pioren is trying to torture
emery khan in this
queen end game where white is up upon
what does it mean for the rankings
it's a fight for i guess top ten
so not every single team is starting for
the medals i mean of course you want to
have this great finish finishing top 10
and world chess olympia that's a great
achievement
turkey at the moment they are ranked
paul 14th
this 18th after round 10
so probably poland is not going to make
it
if they win
maybe get close i mean either way very
very narrow match what do you think
danny is this possible to win for wine
i want to say no i want to say no
because
in order to win this i think eventually
white will have to play g5
right how else are you going to make any
pro i just think the king is too weak
i i don't see
how white is going to be able to prevent
black from constantly delivering
just a barrage of checks from all
different sides of the board
but wait you know what i'm going to say
uh queen b to check and you're not
accurate i think f6 has to be played but
let's say you're not accurate you play
king h7
now i could play queen e5 and the queen
on e5 does wonderful things it controls
the e1 square against jack's queen d3
checking h4 queen and the next mo
and g5 and i claim that there's no
perpetual check i don't know if my claim
is right but that's the idea
check
here
yes and there's some ideas
because if i check you on c2 you go
queen e4 and then you you move up with
the king with another check
or just king of six yeah oh yeah that's
true there's some challenges away with
check
oh no now definitely king f6
okay okay you're you're convincing me
that there are some chances here no but
i think f6 is sealing the deal probably
but it's such a responsible move right
it weakens some of the squares around
the king
uh but king h7 is played by the
way yeah
so queen e5 queen e5 seems to be a very
very good winning attempt
right the bar is of course unimpressed
you know you know daniel this reminds me
one of the early round games of marcus
carlson against uh george meyer i think
it was round two when uh carlson cut uh
h pawn and g pawn uh with the white
collar against black's
b-pawn and it was a theoretical draw but
of course carlson showed his magic
end game magic and then he managed to
convert the victory but the drawing
technique was
by no means obvious from myers part
oh yeah i mean i i remember looking at
that end game pretty carefully after it
was played there were some really really
pretty ideas in that game with stalemate
all sorts of things
right king chet instead of king g8 now
it brings to my memory very beautiful
queen g7 stalemate trekking oh yeah b1
queen and queen g7 yeah yeah yeah very
beautiful
totally totally remember that
okay so by the way in the uh polya's
pulsing damages has officially beaten
shivchenko with the black pieces to cap
off
an incredible olympiad performance
and that means the final game of our
lithuania
ukraine match is
going to be a draw stormovicious fails
to win this rocket game but it doesn't
matter
actually he might take a medal uh you
know the one thing we haven't really
talked about who is going to take the
medals in the
uh ports but paolo spokane which is
bored fort for team lithuania was in the
third place
uh behind santos latassa from spain and
santos latassa did not really win right
so
that's probably going to cut apart him
to the second place and vaquidov
won the game against varmadam so i think
uh for poultry which is not only a
victory for him and team latina but also
a very respectable most likely silver
medal on board four very nice right and
i mean meddling at the olympiad
is such an incredible achievement i
remember when sam shankland
uh scored something like eight out of
nine
for team us a couple of years ago it was
it was unbelievable i mean to do that
for your country in the best possible
most important possible world stage
is beyond impressive big big hats off to
fulton avicius it was outraged in a lot
of those games
um talking about the medals i think uh
board one most likely gold medal will go
to gokesh this park is drawing upon
around
uh it was a right
put some catapults into a terrible seven
and a half out of nine what a what a
poor performance on board one
right
so gakesh is probably gonna take gold
board one board two is
um
less clear there was a very narrow race
of another backyard boy from nicolas
theodore oh board tree
david cavall how did they finish by the
way today because david caldwell was
going on monster performance for team
england at some point he was having
something like seventh cup out of eight
or maybe even more england actually got
upset by ivan shitko drawing adams
england got upset by moldova who scored
several upsets with hamita vichy
defeating mcshane with black but howell
did not play today
ah did not play today
i see
that's smart david smart that's mine
i can't really blame him for that but i
get it i get it didn't want to
jeopardize that metal same with nicolas
theodoro by the way who didn't play for
greece today
um so it's gonna be a close battle with
a lot of players with like seven and
nine seven and a half out of nine
with some absolutely monster scores
and uh the top uh the the i mean fourth
board is probably jackongi yavakirov
taking the gold on
for board four and reserve i don't
really know by the way mateos bartel the
uh gamer witnessing team poland fighting
the screening game extra pawn this also
is not only fight for the team
team poland to win the match but also
for matthias bartel to take gold as a
result player
it's very important it's very important
why
does it say that piorent beats uh
m ray khan
i'm sorry that was pioneer not not
bartel my mistake i thought that's but i
wonder why it says one zero
did it flag
i don't think so it says he has three
minutes um maybe this is a wrong result
and this was that but i wouldn't imagine
that bjorn would give him a draw here
huh
okay
i'm going to ask if we know if we can
determine what happened
in this batch range maybe it's a wrong
result i guess we're going to get the
confirmation at some point later it
doesn't look like a flag to me
and it does appear if we can go back to
the women's section for a moment here
with ano shanina defeating kielbasa in
that endgame
mary arabidsee winning her game
and uh
batsyashvili winning her game as well so
georgia wins with a score of three to
one ukraine wins with a score of three
to one and i think all of the games from
the women's section are officially
complete
right and uh before the final round
bought prizes the gold medals
individually board one was the swedish
chess legend pia crumling
leading the charge i don't know if she
played today
uh then we have board to hanin balayeva
from azerbaijan who lost today right if
i remember correctly
um i think yes i think she lost right
third board olivia khalbasak her amazing
nine out of nine streak ended yesterday
today she lost as well but i think she's
still gonna take the gold on board
number three
board number four where's very close
tanya sachdev and uh butter then
gonzole we're tying pretty much the
performance but tanya
uh did not play successfully today
and then we have the fifth board uh jana
schneider from germany she was leading
again i mean you have to check out all
of them finish the final rounds but
those are the board prizes before the
final round so actually it's official i
mean that is official we have the
winners for the women's and the open
section in the open section we
congratulate team uzbekistan with fidei
just officially confirming
that the thai breaks have already been
calculated in uzbekistan edges out
armenia by tie breaks incredible it was
the closest of close margins but armenia
will have to settle for silver with
india 2 going for bronze uzbekistan and
its team of young jogger juggernauts and
all of these players who will have
illustrious careers and ratings of over
2 700 in the near future a gold medal
for the host of the next chess olympiad
and in the women's section team ukraine
edges out georgia so that 3-1 win in the
last round on the strength of ono
shenana and uh maria musuchuk's
victories propel team ukraine through
all of the adversity that they
experienced just getting to the site of
the olympiad was already a monumental
effort to win the entire thing archers
what a story
right they didn't lose a single match i
mean look at that eight victories three
draws i mean despite the fact that this
uh very very competitive field not a
single
match loss and probably a well-deserved
victory for the amazing team of
uzbekistan second place go to armenia
worst tiebreaks sharing the first place
this time missing out the gold medals
and the third is the very young and
promising second team of india with
dhammaraj gugesh the hero of the first
eight rounds who in the end slightly
missed his opportunities
god there's always this feeling when the
olympiad starts coming to an end
um it's a feeling of sadness but at the
same time a deep satisfaction at what
we've just seen archers i must have or
you must have been asked this already on
the commentaries how many olympiads have
you attended either as a player or six
wow six uh the last one was in 2016 in
baku which uh in my memory was
the best olympiad ever because i was
just stunned i mean everything was right
i mean they even stopped the entire city
just to deliver us from the hotels from
five star hotels in hilton to the
playing call which is like the most
awesome playing call you've ever seen
with a giant azerbaijani flag winging in
front of that on top of that right and
then there's the
chenille olympiad you know
it's uh quite amazing what um indians
have done again uh they they got the
chance to organize olympiad after it was
removed from russia it was initially
scheduled to be organized in hantaman
seas then it was moved to moscow then
indians were handed over to organize it
and in several months i think they did
it absolutely unthinkable i watched the
opening ceremony it was absolutely
stunning the new uh torch thing right uh
making a new tradition carrying the
torch to about 75 indian cities
uh
all of the india is watching what's
going on you have entire city dedicated
for they went i there's even a chess
bridge daniel i mean do you see that
there's that bridge
painted in the color yeah i i heard
about that that's great it's just insane
yeah all of the photos photos from the
event really really show the care that
was taken by the organizers and
organizing an event like the olympiad is
not that i would know but it is a
monumental effort
to make sure that you know to coordinate
all of the country's arrivals to to make
sure the playing hall is spacious
uh to make sure that the teams know
where to go
to coordinate things and all of the
languages that are being spoken all of
that taking together
a monumental effort and to do that in
several months is especially impressive
um what can we say
this well this olympia flew by
time flash was having fun as they say
right i mean these almost two weeks flew
by
uh really really fast we had a lot of
fun here in the in the commentary right
uh also i was absolutely honored uh
to do so many rounds i mean have you
daniel with us and uh also yasso serwan
was for the first part of the olympia
then we had alessia santoramo
uh for several days it was an absolute
pleasure and from my part at least i
would like to thank also
the coast all of the coasts uh the
amazing producers of chescom kubatis
event possible they're the people you
don't see in the background or amazing
producers water and challah we're
silently doing the work and making the
show possible of course the
viewers yeah the viewers
are who make an event like this magical
and i know that we had
so many fans on site in india rooting
for their favorite teams
uh it's it's awesome that india got uh
to put in three teams in the in the open
section and i think that players like
bukesh like pragnanda have
uh have taken home an invaluable
experience that they are going to use
to advance their chess careers and of
course we are going to keep a very very
close eye on gucash this was his
breakout performance but
in any case uh archers unfortunately the
time zone made it a little bit difficult
for me to commentate the olympiad uh
from the united states but i i got a
chance to do two of the rounds
and i had an absolute blast commentating
with you today and uh commentating with
yasser earlier so
before we
wrap up for the last time archers any
final thoughts
on how you saw the olympiad this year in
yeah the olympiad was absolutely
stunning and you know i have a small
regret i wasn't really there there's
couple of reasons
right while i didn't go there but uh we
just wanted to mention before we look
back at olympia that it's official
actually the result team ukraine winning
the women's olympia that has been
confirmed as the final result also the
winner in the women's section goes
without losing a single match seven
victories four draws amazing result for
ukraine
an amazing result indeed through all of
the adversity that they've experienced
we congratulate ukraine we congratulate
team uzbekistan and with that ladies and
gentlemen
our
coverage of the 44th chess olympiad from
chennai has reached his conclusion its
conclusion today was the final 11th
round we hope that you enjoyed the show
we hope that you enjoyed the coverage
and echoing what arthur said we want to
thank all of the thousands the tens of
thousands of you who tuned in day in and
day out whether the time zone was
convenient for you or not to cheer on
your country your favorite team your
favorite players and for now ladies and
gentlemen for
archer snake sons our producer pick our
entire amazing team at chess.com
grandmaster daniel nardiski bidding you
goodbye
from
windows 22. namaste 44th chess olympiad
we'll see you guys at the next olympiad
bye i'm budapest
we have uzbekistan in first place right
now our
india third and fourth and team usa
closing out the top five any of those
teams can win gold and we will be
delving into that the gong has sounded
the games have started and so
has taken so many scopes in this
tournament he beat fabiano hari krishna
and mom and yara if i beat uh
hari krishna in one tournament just that
i would go around telling my grandkids
for the rest of my life
wha what
he played
i thought he sacked and i thought he
sacked it and it's been the narrative
all olympiad long the fact that india
two might actually be a stronger team
than india one stronger not in the pure
chess sense obviously but in the sense
of how hungry they are and how on form
they are and they have displayed
absolutely incredible performances all
around as india too india too is going
to win their match assuming that nothing
crazy happens here very important game
obviously for her as well i mean to
bring home gold medal i think the entire
nation is just waiting for this to
happen a huge huge result till her
genome has held a draw against hampi
canero and this is the position of tatev
abrahamian against kulkarni tatev is not
losing this i mean this is totally
winning as well team ua said the women
need them taking down the leaders india
and that means there's no gold medal for
a woman being india team what a
heartbreaker and this is a dead draw i
know shannon is up a pawn she's
obviously not going to lose that it
looks like team ukraine is about to
secure gold medal a huge result for team
armenia they win their match with a
score of two and a half one and a half
on the strength of gabriel sarkeesian's
incredible performance and victory over
alexey sheriff
and that's it
that was the final move i think there
you go yes he avoided lost rap
resignation
uzbekistan wins the match what an
incredible finale as both leaders win
their match with a score of two and a
half one and a half and it's all down to
the tie breaks uzbekistan and armenia
claim gold and silver medals what a
finale we just watched
so
do
[Music]
so
you